THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS TO
MANAGE ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
RISKS THE SENATE CONTINUES TO
WELCOME THE PUBLIC. AND HAS
PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH IN
PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE BURKE
DISSIPATION FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER. IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND- I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO. WE WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY WE DON'T EXPECT ANY
ISSUES BUT IF SOMEBODY IS
DISRUPTIVE THEY WILL BE REMOVED
FROM THE MEET REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE ARE
HOLDING A COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE- STREET BUILDING I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HERE PLEASE
COME NOW. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES AND COMPUTERS. THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOUR REC. TO
SPEAK UP A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO A MUTE PLEASE SELECT A NEW
BEFORE YOU SPEAK R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. WE WILL FIRST
DISCUSS PUBLIC SAFETY AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES IN PARTS
A- AND LABOR WORK FORCE. PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND PUBLIC RETIREMENT
ISSUES AND PART B. AND THEN
AFTER BOTH PARTS WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. FROM BOTH ALL
ITEMS WILL BE HELD OPEN TODAY.
BEFORE WE BEGIN. LET'S ESTABLISH
QUORUM NO WE CAN'T OKAY. WE'LL
WAIT. ONE KALRA. OKAY THEN WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL MR HACKER.
ZERO ZERO HERE GROWTH CORTESE
NEWMAN HERE. OKAY IT'LL HAVE A
QUORUM. ON HERE I JUST WANT TO
SAY A COUPLE OF THINGS AS WE
MOVE ON TO THE TRANSPORTATION OF
THESE INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSPORTATION ARE URGENTLY
NEEDED I KNOW I'VE TALKED TO A
NUMBER OF- ADVOCATES A AND
ACTIVISTS AND MEMBERS- WHO WORE-
VERY. RAISING THIS ISSUE ACROSS
THE STATE SO WE HAVE BOTH IN ON
URGENT ISSUE ON TRANSPORTATION
ITEMS ACROSS THE STATE
GEOGRAPHICALLY THERE'S NO ONE
AREA MORE IMPORTANT THERE ARE
OTHER. ISSUES FACING
TRANSPORTATION RANGE FROM GRADE
SEPARATIONS TO BART TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WORD FRANKLY I THINK
SOMETHING LIKE 40% OF THE
POPULATION OF LIVES- I ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR COMMITMENT
TO THESE INVESTMENTS ALSO RESULT
IN THE CREATION OF GOOD JOBS.
HIGHROAD GOOD PAYING JOBS BOTH
IN THE CONSTRUCTION ARENA AS
WELL AS IN MANUFACTURING.
OPERATIONS BENEFITS- SOME-
MAINTENANCE SO I HOPE TO HEAR
FROM THAT ASPECT OF THE
PRESENTATIONS THAT WILL BE MADE
TODAY- BEFORE WE BEGIN- WITH
INDIVIDUAL ISSUES THE L. A-
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE SOME OVER
ARCHING COMMENTS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
BUDGET. ALEJO PLEASE PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR SENATORS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE WORD
UNDERSTATED ANALYST'S OFFICE-
BEGIN WITH THE GOVERNOR'S NAME
REVISION. EIGHT FIFTY TWO
DOLLARS FUND SURPLUS THE LARGEST
CATEGORIES FROM THE SURPLUS
SEARCH FOR NATURAL RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. IN
ADDITION ON RELIGION ALLOCATE
THIRTY NINE BILLION MOBILES IN
ORDER TO MEET THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS ARE WOMEN
REQUIREMENTS ALSO KNOWN AS ARMS
THE TWO LARGEST CATEGORIES OF
THE HANDLES ARE ELEVEN POINT
FIVE BILLION TAX REFUNDS AND.
THIRTEEN BILLION FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY. THIS THIS THE AVERAGE
LEAVES SOUR AND ADDRESS.
SPECIFICALLY THE LEADS THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION HUNDRED ALL.
AND. TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS IS
CONCERNED BECAUSE SUCKS EIGHT
CLIFF BUT COULD POTENTIALLY FACE
STATE TWENTY THREE FOUR ABSENT
JANE. SPECIFICALLY WE ARE THAT
THIS WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS WHAT WORKS BILLION
IN TWENTY FOUR THREE TWENTY
FOUR. THE MAY REVISION DOES NOT
INCLUDE A PLAN TO ADDRESS THIS
REQUIREMENT AS RESULTS AS A
RESULT THE STATE WOULD VERY
LIKELY FACE A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
PROBLEM IN THAT YEAR. IN
ADDITION WE KNOW THE OF A- AS
HIGH. CERTAIN A INDICATORS HAVE
HISTORICALLY OFFERED WARNING
SIGNS IN THE RECESSION IS ON THE
HORIZON. AND MANY OF THESE
INDICATORS CURRENTLY SUGGEST THE
HEIGHTENED RISK OF A RECESSION
WE'RE HOMES TWO YEARS. GIVEN
THESE FACTORS WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE STATE
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF RESEARCH
HAS AS RESERVES WILL BE
ESSENTIAL TO THE STATE TRAINING
WILL SUBSISTENCE PROGRAMS IN
LIGHT OF THE BUDGET RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS ONE. AND THE
POTENTIAL A RECESSION THAT MY
REMARKS ON THE OVERALL. BUDGET
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS ARE WE-
RECEIVED RESPITE HERE. OKAY THE
TICKET COMMENTS ON OPENING- TO
THE MEMBERS OF ALL RIGHT- THANK
YOU MISTER- LET'S BEGIN WITH A
DISCUSSION ITEMS- ISSUE ONE-
THAT'S WHEN YOU JUST IT I REMIND
. C. I'M SORRY IT IS ISSUE OKAY
- WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LA- EMBARRASSED
DEPARTMENTS THAT WILL PRESENT OF
WHO WILL BEGIN I DON'T HAVE A
PARTICULAR ORDER HERE. HELLO
THIS IS STEVE WILSON BERMAN
FINANCE. OKAY GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MY NAME IS TO WELCOME BARBARA
FINANCE AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PERFECT FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
ITEMS FROM THE MAY REVISION
UPDATE TO THE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE BUDGET FOR A TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET FOR TRANSPORTATION.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCY
REPRESENTATIVES- ONLINE TO HELP
BUT RESPOND TO QUESTIONS. ON I
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT SOME OF OUR
REPRESENTATIVES ARE IS ACTUALLY
CURRENT HEARING. SO WE MAY HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU. WITH
FEEDBACK LATER- IN ORDER TO
ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
UP FIRST UP ON THE AGENDA- WE
HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY FOR
FALLS OFF. IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING GOVERNOR FOR. BOTH
CENTERED ON PROVIDING FOR A
DOLLAR TAX REBATE- TO EACH
ELIGIBLE REGISTERED VEHICLE
OWNER FOR. WILL BE DISCUSSED IN
DETAIL IN SUB COMMITTEE FOR
HOWEVER THERE ARE A FUTURE.
ASIAN ELEMENTS THAT I'D LIKE TO
NOTE. OUR FIRST PACKAGE
INCLUDES. A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
ADDITIONAL- ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM DOLLARS.
ABOVE THE- OUR FOOTBALL FOOTBALL
FROM FROM BUDGET FOR TWO OF
BILLION DOLLARS. ALL PACKAGE
INCLUDES SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THREE ALLOCATED
FOR GRANTS TRANSIT AGENCIES IN
RETURN FOR PROVIDING. OF THREE
MONTHS OF FREE TRANSIT SERVICE
THE GRANT AMOUNT IS BASED ON
FAREBOX REVENUE REPORTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND WOULD
APPROXIMATELY BE A 150% OF THE
AMOUNT OF TO THE FOR THE
PARTICIPATING AGENCIES. AND
FINALLY THE REACH REALLY RAPIDS
PROPOSES THE PAS COLLECTIONS OF
THE ALMOST 4% GENERAL FUND
PORTION OF THE DIESEL SALES TAX
FOR ONE YEAR. HOWEVER THE
TRANSFERS FROM THE- FROM THOSE
FUNDING TO THE- TRANSPORTATION
ACCOUNTS WILL BE FULLY FUNDED SO
THIS OUT POSSIBLE HAVE NO IMPACT
ON A TRANSIT FUNDING. NEXT ON
THE AGENDA WE HAVE A REVISIONS
RELATED TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT OR I J.
WORK WHAT. CALIFORNIANS TO
SURVEYS TO RECEIVE ALMOST 40%
MORE HIGHWAY FUNDING OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS FROM THE I. J.
BENNETT RECEIVED OVER THE
PREVIOUS FIVE YEARS- UNDER THE
FIXING AMERICA'S. SURFACE
TRANSPORTATION OR FAST ACT IN
ORDER TO ACCOMMODATETHIS LARGE
INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES OF RESOURCES
THE- FIRST THE COS PRO. SEE ALSO
CAPITAL OUTLAYS OR- WHICH
DESIGNS BEEN OVERSEAS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF PROJECTS ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. BASED ON
CALTRANS FIVE YEAR PROJECTED
WORKLOAD PROJECTIONS AN INCREASE
OF A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
AND SIX HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
POSITIONS IN THE CAPITAL A
SUPPORT PROGRAM IS REQUESTED FOR
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. RESOURCES AND COS ARE
USED FOR PROJECTS SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS ENGINEERING
DESIGN RIGHT AWAY ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS. AND OTHER- PROJECT
BASED- ACTIVITIES. NOTE THAT
THIS REQUEST IT HERE'S TO THE
HISTORIC- NINETY TEN SPLIT FOR A
CONSULTING AND- STATE- EMPLOYEE
SERVICES. SECONDLY SECONDLY
CONSISTENT WITH THE INCREASED
NUMBER PROJECTS RESULTING FRM
THE INFLUX OF IJA DOLLARS
CALTRANS DELIVERY OF NON PROJECT
SERVICES WILL CORRESPONDINGLY
DECREASE. PROGRAMS IS EXPECT TO
SEE AN INCREASED WORKLOAD
INCLUDE MAINTENANCE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE TRAFFIC OPERATIONS
AND PLANNING AMONG OTHERS. THE
MAY REVISE INCLUDES AN INCREASE
OF FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE
POSITIONS. CALTRANS MARY BY THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDES UPDATES TO
THE PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE. THAT'S RIGHT EARLIER
THE UPDATE GOT DATA PROPOSAL
WILL INCLUDE THE GOVERNOR WILL
PUT THE UPDATES TO INCLUDE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- BY ADDING
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE PRO FOR BOTH ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM BRINGING
THE TOTAL EIGHTY P. FUNDING THE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. IN THE POLL
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE TO NINE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS WHICH
INCLUDES FOUR POINT TWO BILLION
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO ONE POINT TWO
BILLION PROPOSED REPORTS
IMPROVEMENTS. ALSO AS PART OF
NAY REVISION. TO THE GOOD AS
PART OF THE MAY REVISION TO THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
REQUEST HE PROPOSES THREE NEW
POSITIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT AND
REPORTING OF PROGRAMS IMPACTED.
BY THE INCREASE FUNDING LEVELS.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE FOR THE
PROPOSED TRANSIT AND INTERCITY
RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM- THAT
ADDRESSES CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED SINCE THE
PROPOSAL'S REPAIRS ONLY
INTRODUCED A SIMPLE DEFINING THE
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ALLOWING FOR
FUNDING OF EXISTING TRC PEOPLE
OBJECTS WITH THESE NEW FUNDS.
ALSO MADE A REVISION INCLUDES
NEW TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL CONTRACTING
OPTIONS INCLUDING THE USE OF JOB
ORDER CONTRACTING BEST VALUE
CONTRACTING AND ALLOWING
ADDITIONAL USE OF DESIGN BUILD
PROCUREMENT AUTHORITY. ALSO
PROPOSED LANGUAGE WILL
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
PROGRAMMING IN A REGIONAL RAIL
PROJECTS HELLO CALTRANS TO
PROVIDE ADVANCE PAYMENTS TO
LOCAL AUTHORITIES FOR TRANSIT
PROJECTS AND UPDATE CALTRANS
RIGHT OF WAY AUTHORITY TO
FACILITATE BROADBAND
INSTALLATION- THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES A FEW OTHER CALTRANS
REQUEST. INCLUDING TO
REAPPROPRIATION ITEMS THE FIRST
BEING THE BALANCE OF THE FUNDING
FOR THE LIBERTY CANYON WILDLIFE
CROSSING PROJECT. THESE FUNDS
WILL ALLOW CALTRANS TO COMBINED
WITH FUTURE REIMBURSEMENT
FUNDING FOR BOTH CONSTRUCTION
SUPPORT AND CONSTRUCTION CAPITAL
EXPENSES AS THE PROJECT MOVES
FORWARD. SECOND WE LAST FOR THE
REAPPROPRIATION OF FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR THE GENERAL TRANSIT
FEED SPECIFICATION OR GTF BEST
PROJECT- ADDITIONAL TIME IS
NEEDED TO FINALIZE AND EXECUTE
CONTRACTS THE WILL HELP SMALL
MEDIUM AND WORLD TRANSIT
AGENCIES NEED TO BE CONTACTLESS
PAYMENT STANDARDS PROMISED BY
THE PROJECT. LASTLY FOR CALTRANS
WILBUR STING EXTENSION FOR TWO
YEARS OF THE REIMBURSEMENT OF
FORTY FOUR FORMING RIGHT AWAY
LEGAL SERVICES FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF
AGREEMENT OF AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE AUTHORITY AND
CALTRANS IS OF. THE FISH. THE
SERVICE FROM YEARS. NEXT ON THE
AGENDA CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
. THE VISION INCLUDES- SEVERAL
REQUESTS FOR CALIFORNIA I WOULD
CONTROL INCLUDING THREE POINT
SIX MILLION- THE NBA FOR TWENTY
TWO POSITIONS THE PROCUREMENT OF
RECORDS MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. AND
SOFTWARE FOR PERFORMING
REDACTIONS THIS WILL SUPPORT
WORKLOAD RESULTING FROM NEW
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. I
REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES FORTY
THREE POINT SIX MILLION IN V. TO
COVER INCREASED COSTS. WITH
WORKERS COMPENSATION
EXPENDITURES. AND FINALLY A NET
THIRTY TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN VA. IS REQUESTED FOR
THE QUINCY BALDWIN PARK SANTA FE
SPRINGS OFFICE REPLACEMENT
PROJECTS AND CONSTRUCTION OF THE
TELLER P. TOWER PROJECT. LAST ON
THE LAST ON THE AGENDA BUT NOT
LAST IN OUR HEART. IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES THE
FOLLOWING REQUESTS FOR THE DMV-
INCLUDES THIRTY FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION REAPPROPRIATION FOR THE
DIGITAL EXPERIENCE PLATFORM
PROCUREMENT WAS INITIALLY
DELAYED AS DMV REQUIRED VENDORS
PROVIDE PROJECT DEMONSTRATIONS-
THE USABILITY OF THE FINAL
PRODUCT. ALSO THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES NINE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST FOR SANTA MARIA
INGLEWOOD AND REALLY FIELD
OFFICE REPLACEMENT. BACKUP WAS
THE TRANSPORTATION REQUESTS
INCLUDED MAYREVISION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME WE HAVE FOLKS
ONLINE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MISTER WELLS. OF WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE L. A.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER THANK YOU WITH
THE LEAD AND OFFICE I MADE A
PROVIDER OFFICES- MY HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS- ON OUR INITIAL
COMMENTS ON THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL RELATED TO
TRANSPORTATION- OVERALL THE MAY
REVISION DOES NOT INCLUDE MANY
NEW TRANSPORTATION PROPOSALS-
THE GOVERNOR MAINTAINED
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
SPENDING AND TRANSPORTATION THAT
WAS PROPOSED BACK IN JANUARY.
MANY THROUGH THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE AND THE
SUPPLY CHAIN PACKAGE- THE FEW
NEW PROPOSALS IN THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDE FINDING A
POLICY CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT THE
NEW FEDERAL FUNDS UNDER I. AJ IN
THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE AND THE
RELIEF- REVISION INCLUDE
SOMETHING. STAFF AND COULD A
TOWARD AND FUND FOR AROUND A
THOUSAND NEW POSITIONS THAT
CALTRANS. WHICH WOULD BE
DEDICATED TO ADMINISTERING
IMPLEMENTING I. AJ AND THE
PROBLEM AND THAT A MILE NETWORK
PROGRAM. WELL THESE ARE LARGE
AND INCREASES THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING AND THE BROADBAND.
NETWORK PROGRAM WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT AND LAST FOR SEVERAL
YEARS- THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
SEVERAL POLICY CHANGES THROUGH
BUDGET TRAILER LEGISLATION
RELATED TIE AJ FUNDING. AND A
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE- FOR INSTANCE THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO PROVIDE
CALTRANS WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
UTILIZE DESIGN BUILD PROCUREMENT
THROUGH TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. CURRENTLY THE APARTMENT
HAS- VERY LIMITED AUTHORITY TO
USE THIS PROJECT TO LIBERATE
METHANE. GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE
CHANGES THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER WHETHER IT IS
PREPARED TO TAKE ACTION ON THESE
PROPOSALS NOW. OR WHETHER IT
MIGHT MAKE MORE SENSE TO DEFER
ACTION ON THESE ITEMS UNTIL
LATER IN THE SUMMER OR NEXT YEAR
TO ALLOW FOR TO SIT THAT
DECISIONAL DISCUSSION. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO CHOOSE TO
DEBATE THESE CHANGES TO THE
POLICY PROCESS RATHER. THAN
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS- THE
MAY REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION- TO
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES FOR
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
TAX REFUNDS TO VEHICLE OWNERS.
ON THE NEED FOR THIS FUNDING
WILL BE BASED ON WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OR SOMETHING
SIMILAR- BESIDES STOPPING IN
TRAILER BILL- BEING PROPOSED THE
ONE BIG NEW TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING PROPOSAL NÚMERO VISION
IS AN ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM- THIS IS
IN ADDITION TO THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION INCLUDED IN THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE BACK IN JANUARY- THIS
PROGRAM IS THAT SIGNIFICANT
DEMAND EXCEEDING AVAILABLE
FUNDING IN RECENT YEARS. ALSO
BACK IN APRIL AS PART OF THIS
RELIEF PACKAGE THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS INCENTIVE GRANTS
TO TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE FREE TRANSIT SERVICES
FOR THREE MONTHS. WE SUGGEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE THINK ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL AS PART OF ITS
OVERALL PRIORITIES FOR PROVIDING
RELIEF. RATHER THAN A STANDALONE
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL. AND
THEN FINALLY AS MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER SORT OF WORD MENTIONED-
SAU WILL BE- SAU THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS AND IT WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE ON
THE MIND OF THE LEGISLATURE.
SUSSING OUT OF THE TRANSFER
PROPOSALS LEGISLATURE WILL WANT
TO CONSIDER THEM IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE SOUTH- SPENDING RELATED
TO TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IS EXCLUDED UNDER THE STYLE- SO
WILL BE PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE STATE'S CURRENT BUT-
DISTRICTS- AND WITH THAT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. FOR OKAY
THANK YOU MR- HUMANNESS. OUR
TURN OVER TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. FOR THOSE FOR THEM OKAY I GREW
UP WITH THREE. OKAY I- I DO HAVE
A FEW- HERE IN THIS IN THIS. THE
THE FREE NOT TRANSIT PROPOSAL.
NOT SURE WHO WILL ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS ON THAT- BUT THE FREE
TRANSIT- PROPOSAL- COULD YOU
DESCRIBE THAT- A LITTLE BIT MORE%
- INYO ISSUES HAVE COME UP ABOUT
THREE TRANSIT ACCESS AND THEN
YET THE NEED FOR SAFETY AND
SECURITY. MANY WRITERS DO YOU
ANTICIPATE A WILL BENEFIT- WHERE
IT'S LIKE WHERE IS IT LIKE
LIKELY TO HAVE THE HIGHEST USE.
PUTIN MINISTRATION. SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION I'M I'M SORRY TO SEE
WHAT'S GOING FORWARD FINANCED-
I'M OT SURE IF WE HAVE- ANYONE
ON THE LINE FROM- FROM-
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY THAT WOULD
HAVE THAT INFORMATION- AVAILABLE
I THINK THE CONCEPT BEHIND THE
PROPOSAL IS THAT- YOU KNOW- YOUR
BOXES WAY DOWN NOW- YEAH DO A
LOT OF FACTORS. AND YOU KNOW TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SORT OF IN THE
LAST YEAR PRIOR TO THE- PANDEMIC
THAT AND SINCE ALL OF FAREBOX
REVENUES REPORTED WE'RE ABLE TO
LOOK AT FAREBOX REVENUE AND SEE
WHERE IT WAS. AND BE ABLE TO
CALL THE PROPOSAL THAT PROVIDES
A BIT MORE FUNDING THAN THEY
WOULD RECEIVE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. AND AND WE WANT THE
PART WE WANT THE DIFFERENT
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO BE CREATIVE
AND TO COME UP WITH WAYS ANYA
THEY ALREADY THERE'S ALREADY
MANY PROGRAMS THAT THEY DO FOR.
A DIFFERENT YOU KNOW FREE
WEEKENDS OR FREEDOM TO- YOU KNOW
ABOUT STUDENTS THAT SORT OF
THING I THINK WE WANT TO EXPAND
ON THAT WE WANT TO TRY TO MAKE
THAT- YOU KNOW LARGER AND- I
THINK TO SOME DEGREE AT LEAST ON
THE FINANCE SIDE WE'RE VERY
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING-
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT DOES YOU KNOW
WHAT. WHAT ARE THE RESULTS OF
THAT I MEAN YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
SORT OF BANG FOR THE BUCK I
THINK IT COULD BE PROVIDED SOME
REAL IMPORTANT DATA- REGARDING
YOU KNOW WHERE RIDERSHIP. IS
POSTED BY PRICE CONCERN- ENACTED
HELP THEM GAIN FUTURE- WHAT'S
THE AYE I THINK I'M NOT SURE IF
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE WHICH
WERE KIND OF STRICKEN OF
FRAGMENTED THE LITTLE THE SURVEY
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE
ANYBODY FROM THE FARM. OKAY LIKE
YOU SAID I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE.
ADDRESSING AN ISSUE AND HOW ARE
WE ADDRESSING THAT- WHO ARE WE
LOOKING TO GIVE RELIEF TO ARM
AND IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WILL
BE HELPFUL TO THE TO THE TRANSIT
SYSTEM AND THE IMPACT IT WILL
HAVE. ON SAFETY AND SECURITY-
THE NUMBER OF REQUESTED
POSITIONS HERE IS. OBVIOUSLY
QUITE HIGH FOR- I THINK GOOD
REASONS BUT HOW DO YOU INTEND-
TO THE HIGHER THE NUMBER
POSITIONS REQUESTED. IN A TIME
FRAME THAT MAKES SENSE THAT'S
THAT'S REASONABLE TO FILL THESE
NEEDS. I WE'VE HAD CONVERSATION
HERE IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
WAS- KELLY CHART AND THERE
REALLY WASN'T- FULFILLING THE
NEEDS AND THE VACANCIES WITH
MUCH SMALLER NUMBERS. EACH.
HELLO HELLO OKAY AGAIN I GUESS
I'LL- I DON'T KNOW SUPPOSE WE
MAY NOT HAVE SOMEONE ON THE LINE
FOR CALTRANS GAS THAT I CAN GIVE
YOU THE BEST- HE IS SO CALTRANS
HAS EXPERIENCED AND WE PASSED SB
ONE- BIG SYRIANS- THE
FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN THE OVERALL
BUDGETING- THAT THEY HAD
AVAILABLE FOR PROJECTS. AND THEY
REALLY HONE THEIR ABILITY TO
BRING ON ADDITIONAL ENGINEERS
AND- BRING ON ADDITIONAL SCHOOL
SUPPORT STAFF- TO MANAGE THAT
WORKLOAD SO- THEY'RE PRETTY
CONFIDENT THAT THEY CAN HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING AND- YOU KNOW
REPEAT SOME OF THE SUCCESS THEY
WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL IN BRINGING
IN I THINK THEY BROUGHT IN EIGHT
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN THE IN THE
FIRST FULL YEAR AFTER- AFTER
THE- THE- BEST YOU ONE WAS
PASSED. SO THIS REQUEST. FOR
SOMEWHERE OVER SIX HUNDRED- THIS
SEEMS DOABLE BASED ON THEIR
PREVIOUS- THEY'RE PRETTY THE
PREVIOUS SUCCESS AND- YOU KNOW
SO THAT SO THAT'S BUT I THINK IS
WHERE IS WHERE WE FEEL LIKE.
THIS IS A YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A
HISTORY OF BEING ABLE TO DO THIS
SO I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE SEE
THAT DENTIST AND IJA YOU KNOW
BECAUSE IT'S FIVE YEARS OF MONEY
I THINK WE'RE REALLY TREATING IT
AS A NEW. ELEVATED LEVEL I MEAN
NOT THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. AN
ELEVATED LEVEL OF THE PROJECT-
SO PROJECTS SUPPORT FOR MULTIPLE
YEARS SINCE MOST PROJECTS
AVERAGE PROJECT IS ABOUT FOUR
YEARS SO WITH FIVE YEARS OF
FUNDING YOU KNOW WE MAY BE DOING
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS SUPPORT IT
WITH NO OTHER CHANGES THAT WOULD
BE NINE YEARS- AT THIS HIGHER
LEVELS SO- SO THAT'S WHERE I
THINK WE CAN. WILL BE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE. OKAY. THREE OH ON
CALTRANS AGAIN- ON THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL RIGHT OF WAY
POSITIONS TO ASSIST HIGH SPEED
RAIL AW WHAT'S CAN YOU FEEL THAT
IN A LITTLE BIT MORE THE ACT OF
THE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS AND-
THE TIMING OF IT AND- WHERE WILL
THE WORK BE DONE SO ABOUT SIX
YEARS AGO- CALTRANS THEIR OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL STARTED- ENTERED
INTO AN INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT
CONTRACT WITH- CALTRANS- TO DO
TO PERFORM SPECIFIC- RIGHT AWAY
LEGAL DUTIES THAT ARE VERY THAT
ARE VERY CARILLO. THEY ALREADY
PERFORM UP FOR HIGHWAY
CONSTRUCTION UNDER THIS DEAL
THEY'RE ABLE TO- BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THE WORK FOR MUCH LESS
HOURLY RATE THAN THEY WOULD IF
THEY WENT- IF THEY CONTRACTED
THAT SERVICE OUTSIDE SO- THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES WE'VE BEEN%
WE'VE WE'VE COME BACK THE
LEGISLATURE EVERY TWO YEARS- ON
THIS SO THIS DOESN'T NECESSARILY
REPRESENT AN INCREASE THIS
REPRESENTS A CONTINUATION OF THE
FOURTEEN EMPLOYEES IN THE
CALTRANS LEGAL DEPARTMENT THAT
HAVE BEEN DEDICATED. TO THIS- TO
THE SERVICE IT ALSO FIRST MET SO
THEIR THEIR SERVICE IS ONLY AS
NEEDED SO BUT- BUT THE
FOURTEENTH OF P. WISE YOU KNOW
BASED ON HISTORY IS ABOUT THE
RIGHT NUMBER FOR THE FOR THE
SERVICES THIS. THIS WOULD ALL
HAVE TO DO OF- WITH WORK BEING
DONE IN THE SAN VALLEY. HE SAID
THE BAKER AREA. OKAY THANK YOU-
C. THIS CALL- ON THE- CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL ON THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION AUGMENTATION- CAN
SOMEONE TALK TO WHAT IS DRIVING
THE INCREASE COSTS OF FOR
WORKERS COMPENSATION- AND AS
WE'RE YOU KNOW WE HAVE MANY
VACANCIES IN C. H. B. WHAT CAN
WE EXPECT AS FAR AS- FILLING
THOSE. VACANCIES AND AT THE SAME
TIME TO INCREASE COSTS FOR
WORKERS COMP.
CAPPY ARE- CAPPING NAP. WE'VE
GOT THE MCLEOD- ARE YOU ONLINE
FROM FORMING FINANCED.
FOR CASTING A CLOUD DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I'M SORRY I JUST HEARD
MY NAME I WAS IN THE OTHER
HEARING. THE QUESTION IS BEING
ASKED REGARDING- THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION- THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION REQUEST ON THE CHP
AND- WHAT'S DRIVING THAT AND- SO
YOU KNOW HOW HOW HOW HOW DO WE
GET THERE AND HOW THE SECOND
IMPACT THE ABILITY TO HIRE.
ADDITIONAL WELL CURRENTLY CHP.
AS A VACANCY IN OFFICERS IN THE
OUTLOOK THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
COVER THAT INCREASES IN THE WORK
ME WORKERS COMP BOTH IN THEIR
SKIVVIES AND IN THEIR USAGE OF
WORKERS COMP. SO BY FINDING THE
DIFFERENCE THAT THEY'VE USED TO
ABSORB TO COVER THAT COST THAT
WILL FREE UP. V. REDIRECTED
FUNDING AND THAT CAN COVER
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED SEVENTY
OFFICERS. AND I BELIEVE CHP IS
ALSO ONLINE IF THEY WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING. WE'LL MISS MACLEOD DO
YOU- DO YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS
DRIVING THE INCREASE COSTS IN
WORKERS COMPENSATION. I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT OKAY OKAY. I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT I DO
THINK- ALL OF THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN
AT ONCE I BELIEVE THAT THE COST
OF BEEN GOING UP OVER TIME AND
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN. SOME
VACANCIES AT CHP FOR A WHILE
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO ABSORB THE
COST OVER A PERIOD OF TIME IT'S
JUST NOW FOR- YES WE PUT
TOGETHER A PLAN SO THAT WE CAN
YOU KNOW FOR HIGHER FULLY WE
WANT TO ALSO FULLY- FULLY BUDGET
FOR THE- WORKERS COMP COSTS.
WELL YES THANK YOU AND I JUST-
IT STANDS OUT IS QUITE A LARGE
AMOUNT FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. YEAH I THINK IT'S BEEN.
A LITTLE BIT OVER A OT OF YEARS
OKAY IF YOU CAN GIVE ME A FEEL
THAT AND I WOULD APPRECIATE IT.
SENATE MORNING THIS IS TRUCKING
FROM C. H. P. IF I COULD ADD
JUST A LITTLE BIT SURE THANK YOU
YES LIKE KERN COUNTY AND STEVE
BOTH INDICATED THESE COSTS HAVE
BEEN GOING ON THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ABSORB THEM- WE ARE- PRACTICALLY
AND WE HAVE A VERY PROACTIVE
HIRING CAMPAIGN RIGHT NOW
VACANCIES- SONY'S COST THE
RELATED TO SKIP FEES WHEN WE
HAVEN'T HAD NOT- THIS IS
LEAVING. OFFICE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND TEN A WELL AND THEN
OTHER COSTS- OVER A TRIBUTE TO
WORKERS COMP IN MEDICAL COSTS
WHICH I BELIEVE IT WAS- FISCAL
YEAR I THINK IT WAS- TWO OH
THREE SINCE WE HAD A LAST
AUGMENTATION SO WITH THOSE TWO
IT ADDS UP TO THE REQUESTED
FORTY THREE POINT SIX MILLION.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER KING.
CENTER COURTESY DID YOU HAVE.
COULD YOU SEE A SIGNATURE-
POACHER'S FINISH SPEAKING OF
EARLY EARLIER I WAS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WAS IN THE CORRECT-
THE GENDER AREA HERE OF CONCERN-
A COUPLE QUESTIONS ON ON THE
PROCUREMENT SIDE ON THE DESIGN
BUILD PROCUREMENT AUTHORITY I'M
- TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- WHAT
INTEREST IS. AND BEING SATISFIED
BY- BY THE BY THEMODIFICATION
ON THE DESIGN BUILD IN THE DEAL
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS IN
THE JOB ORDER CONTRACTING BUT A
WAIT IN S. THAT- YOU KNOW AFTER.
AFTER HEARING A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT- ABOUT THE DESIGN BUILD IT
IT IT SEEMS LIKE- THE IT IT
WASN'T VERY LONG AGO THAT WE
THAT WE PUT A CAP. ON THE NUMBER
PROJECTS CALTRANS IS AUTHORIZED
TO DO A DESIGN BUILD IT I'M
UNDERSTAND THIS TO BE- MODIFYING
THAT THAT CAP- BUT IT WAS IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS PRETTY
DEBATED OF LAST YEAR BEFORE
BEING SIGNED INTO LAW SO I'M
JUST I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. WHAT'S CHANGED OR
WITH THE THINKING IS AT THIS
MOMENT. ASSEMBLY PROTESTED THIS
AGAIN YEARS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
I CAN'T THANK YOU. GREAT ZERO
I'M LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALTRANS AND DO WE PUT THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE SINCE LAST YEAR
WITH THE I. IJA BEING PASSED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. ARE WE SEE A
LOT MORE I NEED TO DELIVER A LOT
MORE PROJECTS TO CALTRANS AND SO
WE ANTICIPATE. I NEED APPROVED.
SIX PROJECTS PER YEAR COULD
POTENTIALLY USE A DESIGN BUILD
AUTHORITY- TO MOVE MORE SWIFTLY
AND MORE EFFICIENTLY THROUGH THE
PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AND
MAKE THE DEPARTMENT. MORE
ADDITIVE FOR I JUST HAD A ROLE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS RIGHT NOW
THE CAP IS SET AT TEN PROJECTS
AND WE'RE USING FIVE OF THOSE
SLOTS AND SO IF WE WERE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO. USE AS MANY AS SIX A
YEAR- WE WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY BUT IT WOULD BUT. A
JOB HUNTING. WOULD WHO THE
DETAIL THEN ON THE PART BY IT UP
TO ANOTHER SIX OR ANOTHER TEN
PERHAPS TO CREATE A LITTLE
BUFFER THEIR LITTLE PADDING OR
IT JUST I'M NOT CLEAR. THAT WE
WANT TO IN PURPOSE TO THE AT
THIS POINT. ELIMINATE THE CAP
I'M I'M NOT SURE THAT WE DON'T.
BUT THE I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I'M
THAT'S WHAT I'M GETTING AT. IS I
GUESS PART WRAPPED UP IN THEIR
QUESTION IS WHAT'S THE
EXPERIENCE BEEN THUS FAR AND DO
WE HAVE A SAMPLE SIZE. YOU KNOW
WITH THE FIVE THAT- I GET IT
THAT YOU'RE JUST. INTO THOSE
PROJECTS NOW BUT- WHAT WE HAVE
IN TERMS OF EVIDENCE ABOUT HOW
THAT'S GOING- CLEARLY SOMEBODY
FEELS LIKE HE MUST FEEL LIKE
IT'S A GOOD THING IT'S GOING
WELL TO BE PROPOSING THIS BUT- I
GUESS I'M LOOKING FOR A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL WE COULD TAKE THAT
OFFLINE. OF THAT'S A BILLABLE OR
IF IT'S SOMETHING DALY ALWAYS IS
LOOKING AT CURRENTLY IF THAT'S
THE THROUGH THE NATURE MY
QUESTION. WE'VE HAD- TERM
PROJECTS USE THIS THERE WERE.
FIVE PROJECTS CURRENTLY UNDERWAY
UNDER THE EXISTING AUTHORITY. HE
PROJECTS IN A PILOT PROGRAM AND
THEY SHOW THERE'S CLEARLY- A LOT
OF SAVINGS IN TERMS OF TIME-
EVEN AT THE AWARD UP TO DESIGN
BUILD CONTRACTS THERE'S BEEN AT
LEAST A YEAR OF SAVINGS- AND-
CERTAINLY OUR COST SAVINGS AS
WELL IN THE ORDER OF TEN
PERCENT. A PROJECT COST TO THAT
JACKIE WARD OF THOSE CONTRACTS
AND SO- WE ARE ALSO YOU KNOW
PUTTING TOGETHER MORE
INFORMATION AS PROJECTS CLOSE
OUT TO SHOW THAT THE FULL LIFE
CYCLE AND WE WILL BE HAPPY DID
SPEAK OFFLINE FURTHER IF YOU'D
LIKE. THE I. EIGHT EIGHT THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL I AM AM NOT
LOOKING FOR I'M JUST I'M LOOKING
FOR A THUMBNAIL SKETCH YOU KNOW
THE- SORT OF THE TOP LINE YOU
KNOW EXPERIENCE THE SPUR OF THE
OF CHANGE ORDERS. BEEN A PROBLEM
HAD THEY BEEN. TO THE-
COMPETITIVE BIDDING PER. PER SE-
THE COST SAVINGS YOU JUST TALK
ABOUT THIS VERY INTERESTING TO
BE. INTERESTING TO JUST MAYBE
GET ANOTHER SENSOR TO ON. ON HOW
AND WHY THAT OCCURRED OR WHAT
THE BET WHAT YOU'RE BENCHMARKING
THAT 10% AGAINST- I THINK
EVERYONE JUST WANTS TO FEEL GOOD
ABOUT IT IT'S I THINK MOST OF US
HAVE- HERO LOCAL EXPERIENCE
FURTHER EXPERIENCE WITH DESIGN
BUILD THAT'S- SOLID. BUT I
THINK. THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
. IN A WAY FOR RESPONSIBILITY
FOR YOU KNOW FOR ASKING A FEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW YOUR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY SINCE YOU. HERE YOU
HAVE THOSE FIVE PROJECTS NELSON
THANK YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOWING UP WITH YOU AND-
HOPEFULLY WHATEVER YOU COME UP
WITH CAN BE SHARED WITH EVERYONE
HERE ON THE DAIS. ON THE JOB
ORDER CONTRACTING. THIS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I'VE HAD-
EXPERIENCE WITH US A COUNTY
OFFICIAL. PLUS AND MINUS- GOOD
AND BAD IN ITS DIRECTORS. THE
CONCERN I HAVE BEEN AGAIN IT'S
MOSTLY ABOUT NOT SEEN DETAILS
HERE. IS WHAT ARE THE
LIMITATIONS- YOU KNOW ON THE JOB
ORDER CONTRACTING GOING TO BE.
OF HOW MUCH CUMULATIVE JOB ORDER
CONTRACT JOB ORDER CONTRACTING-
WILL BE ALLOWED BEFORE- BEFORE A
REPEATED YOU KNOW BEFORE YOU
HAVE TO GET- GO TO A MORE
TRADITIONAL PROCESS- IT'S JUST
THAT KIND OF DETAIL IN IN THESE.
TO BEGIN MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
THAT THOSE DETAILS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S NOT- SOME OF
THE VERY THINGS THAT COMPETITIVE
BIDDING WAS ORIGINALLY DESIGNED
I THINK TO. TO SOLVE OR TO
SATISFY WHICH IS YOU KNOW
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT OVER LACK
OF DIVERSITY IN IN IT BIDDERS OR
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY HAVING. UP
WITH EVEN IF IT'S AN OVERLY THE
SAME- CONTRACTORS AND UP- OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN- YOU
KNOW GETTING THAT THE- ON IT
WOULD BE GETTING THE STATE
FUNDING TO DO THE WORK- IT JUST
BECAUSE IT AT THE END OF.
GUARDRAILS HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
THE JOB ORDER CONTRACTING SCHEME
THAT YOU'RE USING SO AGAIN
DETAILS ON THAT WHICH AGAIN I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE OFF LINE UNLESS
YOU WANT TO. ADDRESS SAID NO. A
U. S. SENATOR BE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THOSE OFFLINE JUST
REALLY QUICK I KNOW. WITH SOME
OF THE WAY THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT
IMPLEMENTING MESSAGES WITH THREE
YEAR CONTRACTS WITH. RENEWALS
EVERY YEAR I WITHIN THE CONTRACT
TERMS SO THAT WE COULD EVALUATE
PERFORMANCE AND LOOK AT THE- THE
EXPERIENCING YOU KNOW. WHAT
FUNDING THOSE CONTRACTS MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE COMPETITIVE
THEY WOULD BE- COMPETITIVELY BID
BASED ON A UNIT PRICE BOOK- AND
SO THEY'LL BE MARKUPS FINDING
THE- BY THE CONTRACTORS. AND
THEN WE WOULD- EVALUATE THOSE
UNITS I SPOKE. FIVE AND SO WE'D
BE HAPPY TO SPEAK MORE OFFLINE
ABOUT HOW WE WOULD DO THAT. YEAH
GREAT AT JUST LOOKING FOR THE
MODEL THERE'S NOT THERE'S MORE
THAN ONE WAY TO. OBVIOUSLY TO
BUILD THOSE- THOSE SYSTEMS IN
AGAIN JUST TRYING TO DO MY DUE
DILIGENCE HERE THANK YOU MANAGER
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER FOR DISEASE- THANK YOU
KNOW WE CAN WE WANT TO ISSUE TO
- ISSUE TWO IS ADMINISTRATIONS
OVERVIEW OF MAY REVIVE MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS. AND PUBLIC
SAFETY CORRECTIONS AND THE
JUDICIARY AND FOR THAT WE HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A LEO
AND VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS- WHO
WILL PRESENT. ALL WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS JUST NAY NEWMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND I'M
GONNA PROVIDE THE OVERALL
SUMMARY FOR THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSALS ADDRESSING PUBLIC
SAFETY. PERSONAL SAFETY IS ONE
OF THE MOST NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS REVISION MAKES
SEVERAL INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PROTECT
VICTIMS OF CRIME BUT BUILDING ON
THE PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. HELLO THIS
PRESENTATION WILL NOT INCLUDE
EVERY PROPOSAL ON THE AGENDA
BEFORE YOU I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE MAJOR
ELEMENTS STARTING WITH
CORRECTIONS THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES A TOTAL FUNDING OF
THIRTEEN POINT NINE BILLION
INCLUDING THIRTEEN POINT THREE
BILLION GENERAL FUND FOR CDC ARE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. IT IS
AN OVERALL REDUCTION OF ABOUT 2%
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SIGNIFICANTLY THE MAY REVISION
REFLECTS A FADED ANDREDUCE
POPULATION PROJECTIONS BY THE
LATEST ESTIMATES ANTICIPATED
AVERAGE DAILY INSTITUTIONAL
POPULATION OF ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
AND THREE THOUSAND AND TWENTY TO
TWENTY. THE ABOUT. FROM THE
GOVERNOR. ACTIONS AS OF MAY. THE
CURRENT INSTITUTION POPULATION
WITH NINETY SEVEN I. THE LATEST
PROJECTIONS INDICATE THE
POPULATE IS TEMPORARY INCREASING
BUT IS PROJECTED TO RAISING LONG
TERM DOWNWARD TRENDS REACHING
ABOUT NINETY SIX THOUSAND BY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE
LONG TERM TRENDS IF THE COLD
PRESENT A SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA RIGHT
SIZE ITS PRISON SYSTEM- AND
WHILE I CAUTION THAT LONGER TERM
PROJECTIONS ARE SUBJECT TO SOME
UNCERTAINTY AND ASSUME NO MAJOR
STATUTORY OR POLICY CHANGES THAT
WOULD INCREASE THE PRISON
POPLATION THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES IT MAY BE POSSIBLE TO
CLOSE THREE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
BY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE- BACK
TO CLOSING A TOTAL FIVE PRISON
BY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE
STATE COULD REALIZE SAVINGS ON
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY ARE RELATED LIAM
PERCENT TO SB NINETY TO THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE IS
SCHEDULED TO CLOSE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
ATOMI REVISION REFLECTS A
DECREASE OF ABOUT NINETY NINE.
AND ROUGHLY FIVE. REPOSITION IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND ONGOING IN
RECOGNITION OF THE REALIGNMENT
GIVEN OUR COMMITMENT CITY COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICER. AS FINDING
ADEQUATE HOUSING REMAINS
ESSENTIAL THE SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
PROVIDE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING TO
YOU IS CHARGED BY THE BOARD OF
JUVENILE HEARINGS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE MADE AVAILABLE TO
YOU WHO ARE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS UPON THEIR RELEASE
. CDCR HAS SEEN CONSIDERABLE
IMPROVEMENT MANAGING TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN PANDEMIC AS WELL
PARTICULARLY SINCE THE- MAKRAN
SURGEON JANUARY. OPEN A REVISION
INCLUDES A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE POINT ONE MILLION FOR
KOBE PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES WHICH IS A DECREASE
OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THESE
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW CDCR TO
CONTINUE TAKE PROACTIVE MEASURES
AND PRECAUTIONS PROTECT
INCARCERATED POPULATION AND THAT
. THERE IS ALSO BUILT ON INVEST
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IMPROVING. THE PROCESS BY
WHICH THE DEPARTMENT HANDLES
COMPLAINTS FILED BY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ALLEGING STAFF
MISCONDUCT. MAY REVISION ADDS
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION GOING.
TO INSPECTOR GENERAL TO OVERSEE
AND MONITOR CCAR'S NEW STAFF
MISCONDUCT PROCESS WHICH BEGAN
IN JANUARY. IN TOTAL THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
FUND- I. G. SEVEN POINT NINE
MILLION TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND FIFTEEN POINT ONE MILLION ON
GOING. TO PERFORM THESE ASKING
FOR. DEEP IT'S ALL IMPORTANT CAL
. NEED TO INVEST IN ESSENTIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIORITIES SO
THAT THE CITY'S REMAIN SAFE AND
SECURE FOR THOSE WHO LIVE AND
WORK IN. A FOR THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION OF WHICH A HUNDRED AND-
SIX POINT THREE MILLION IS
GENERAL FUND. FOR FOURTEEN
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
INCLUDING A SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION THE HEALTHCARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
FIVE STATEWIDE MEDICATION
DISTRIBUTION IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS A LICENSED FIFTY BED
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FACILITY
AND AIR COOLING FACILITY THAT
CALIFORNIANS COULD FERMENT. AND
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION COST
INDEX INCREASES FOR PROJECTS.
ROGER APRIL FIFTH- WITH
COMPONENTS WITHDRAWAL OR- AND A
NEW APPROPRIATIONS. TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION PREVIOUS YEAR
VERSIONS THE OVERALL NET
INCREASE IS A HUNDRED TEN POINT
NINE MILLION OF WHICH EIGHTY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION IS GENERAL
FUND FOR EXISTING PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE NINE RE
APPROPRIATIONS OR EXTENSIONS
APPLICATION OF FOX. TURNING TO
THE JITTERS JUDICIAL BRANCH THE
MAYOR VISION PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND MODIFY EXISTING COURT THE
LADIES IN TWENTY NINETY SIX
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF NEW
COURT ROOMS TO ACCOMMODATE THE
TWENTY THREE A NEW JUDGESHIPS
FUND IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IN A REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
THIRTY NINE POINT FIVE GENERAL
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND THIRTY
SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION. BONTA
GOING. BRANCH TO CONDUCT
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE RECOVERY
AND EMPOWERMENT OR CARE COURT
HEARINGS AND TO PROVIDE.
RESOURCES FOR SELF HELP CENTERS
- ANTICIPATE THAT A DRESS
ANTICIPATED REVENUE DECLINES IN
THE TRIAL COURT TRUST FUND IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE MARY
VISION INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND BRINGING
THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOR THE BACK
FILL TWO HUNDRED FIFTY ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THE REVISION ALSO
REMOVES FORTY NINE ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND BACKFILL PROVIDING
THEGOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS
THE STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND AND THERE IS
SUFFICIENT FUND BALANCE TO
MAINTAIN CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS
. THERE IS ALSO AS NUMEROUS
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
POLICING AND ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF FREE FALLING MARGINALIZED
GROUPS FEES ONE TIME INVESTMENTS
TOTAL APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. A GREAT. VISION
INCLUDED STATE LAND FOR GRANTS
TO IMPROVE LOCAL FRONTLINE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH FILLED
RESILIENCY REDUCE STRESS AND
TRAUMA AND IMPROVE COMMUNITY
TRUST RELATIONSHIP HEALTHIER
OFFICERS. ANOTHER TWENTY MILLION
TO ESTABLISH A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR COUNTY STREET MOBILE
PROBATION CENTERS INCREASE
ACCESS FOR INDIVIDUALS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH HOUSING
OR TRANSPORTATION STRUGGLES. TO
ME OBLIGATIONS AND RECEIVE
SERVICES. ALSO TWELVE MILLION TO
BE PROVIDED OVER THREE YEARS TO
ESTABLISH A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM FELL CALIFORNIA TRIED TO
LOCATE AND IDENTIFY MISSING
INDIGENOUS PERSONS FOUND IN THE
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES AN
INCREASE OF THIRTEEN POINT IN
PROPOSITION FORTY S. SAVINGS.
WHICH BRINGS THE TOTAL NET
SAVINGS FOR PROPOSITION FORTY
EIGHT VERSION TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE POINT ONE MILLION. IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. A CRIME
VICTIMS IN THEIR FAMILIES PAYER
CIGNA PHYSICAL AND FINANCIAL
BURDENS MAY REVISION REFLECTS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO ASSIST VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES RECOVER FROM THE
STRONGEST. AND PROACTIVELY MAKE.
INVESTMENTS TO PROTECT THOSE WHO
FACE HIGHER RISK OF
VICTIMIZATION. SPECIFICALLY THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES. THIRTY
DOLLARS TO THIRTY MILLION- ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO BE SPENT
OVER THREE YEARS TO ESTABLISH AN
INNOVATIVE PILOT PROGRAM FIFTY
COULD INCLUDE OPERATING
SATELLITE TRAUMA CENTERS OR
SUPPORTING VICTIMS SERVICES
PROVIDERS IN HARD TO REACH RURAL
AREAS. AND THREE MILLION ONE
TIME RESTITUTION FUND TO CONDUCT
AN OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF VICTIM SUPPORT
SERVICES SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO
INFORM VICTIMS OF A THAT
AVAILABLE RESOURCES AND AGAIN
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE HARD TO
REACH POPULATIONS- REGARDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE MAYOR
VISION BUILT ON SEVERAL
INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND EXISTING
DOJ TASK FORCE IS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. BY
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION HI ON
GOING TO ESTABLISH A FAN ON. FOR
THEREIS ALSO A GOOD. FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME CHEN FUND TO
DEVELOP AND- REPARATION TASK
FORCE RIGHT. THIS IS ON TOP OF A
TWO POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL
FUND PROVIDED OVER TWO YEARS AND
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. I REGARDING CALIFORNIA THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES THEY MAY REVISION
PROPOSED A HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION. OF WHICH A
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE POINT NINE
MILLION IS GENERAL FUND AND
FIFTY POSITIONS TO ADDRESS THE
MOST FREQUENT COMPLICATED AND
OFTEN SIMULTANEOUS EMERGENCIES
AND FACTORS ACROSS THE STATE.
FIVE INVESTMENT FRANK HOW- YES
IT'S TOTAL FUNDING TO TWO POINT
THREE BILLION. OF WHICH
APPROXIMATELY. HUNDRED SEVEN
NINE IS GENERAL FUND TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. PHYSICALLY THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES A HUNDRED
FOURTEEN POINT THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO PROVIDE
WAREHOUSE SPACE PURCHASE NEW AND
REPLACE EXPIRING PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. INCREASED
COMMODITY SUPPLY FIRM ALL HAZARD
EVENT AND- SUPPORT PUT ME. AT
NINETY MILLION OF WHICH TEN
POINT FIVE NINE IS ON GOING AND
EIGHT DECISIONS TO MODERNIZE
COW- YES THIS TECHNOLOGY AND
DATA CAPABILITIES WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND UPDATING OUTDATED
SYSTEMS. AND FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME IT
IS A SIGN OF A PERMANENT
SOUTHERN REGIONAL EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER AT THE FORMER
FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTAL MENTAL
CENTER AND COSTA MESA. THIS NEW
FACILITY WILL PROVIDE
COORDINATION RESPONSE EFFORTS
BETWEEN FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION IT WILL BE THE
CRITICAL FOCAL POINT FOR
MOBILIZING SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISASTER RESPONSE ASSETS AND
INTELLIGENCE. IN A REVISION ALSO
AND PROPOSES EIGHTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND OF WHICH TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IS ON GOING TO
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING LOCAL
RESPONSE PREPAREDNESS AND
PREVENTION EFFORTS. AT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING AND FIVE POSITIONS TO
PROVIDE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
SUPPORT DURING DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCIES. THIS FUNDING WILL
REDUCE LOCAL COST XCELERATED
RESPONSE TIME AND PROVIDE
SUSTAINABLE PARTICIPATION OF ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WITHIN THE
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM. BY MINIMIZING FUNDING
CONSIDERATIONS FROM THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS. A FIFTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME FOR THE
NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE SECURITY ASSISTANCE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AT RISK
OF HATE MOTIVATED VIOLENCE.
SECURITY ENHANCEMENT PROJECTS
INCLUDE REINFORCED DOORS AND
GATES HIGH INTENSITY LIGHTING
ALARMS AND OTHER SECURITY
RELATED IMPROVEMENTS. AND FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
JUST FOR THE INTERNET CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN TASK FORCE
PROGRAM WHICH HELPS STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
DEVELOP INFECTIVE RESPONSE TO
TECHNOLOGY. HAVE FACILITATED
CHILD. SEXUAL EXPLOITATION IN
COMBATING UNDERGROUND CHILD ****
RINGS. THIS INVESTMENT MAINTAINS
THE LEVEL OF STATE RESOURCES
PROVIDED TO THIS EFFORT IN EACH
OF THE LAST THREE YEARS. AS A AS
A FINAL NOTE I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE MANY OF THE PROPOSALS THAT I
PRESENTED THIS MORNING A ONE
TIME INVESTMENT. AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. BUDGET
EXCEEDED THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS THE NET FOR THE
GAME WINNING IN BOTH TWENTY TWO
OR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO- BY SMALL
MARGINS. HOWEVER THE MAY
REVISION DOES. NOT EXCEED THE
LIMIT. I SAID THERE IS A VERY
REAL POSSIBILITY THAT THE LIMIT
MAYBE EXCEED FUTURE YEARS AND IF
WHY THE ESSENTIAL FOR THE STATE.
MAINLY ON THE IMPORTANT ONE KIND
EXPENDITURES MAINTAIN FIX STEP
FOR CONTAINING A BALANCE BUDGET
OVER THE LONG TERM WILL MINIMIZE
DISRUPTIONS TO CRITICAL PROGRAMS
WHEN REVENUES DECLINED. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ME REVISION PROPOSALS COVERING
THE CORRECTIONS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY AREA. AFTER AREA AND IT
IS FROM THE DEPARTMENT. AND FROM
INDIVIDUAL APARTMENTS WERE HERE
WITH ME TO ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON ANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER ADELMAN- WE WILL HAVE. NO ANY COMMENTS BY THE LA L.
RENDON JR SENATOR. WHO SORT OF
WAR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. ALSO TODAY IT'LL BE
PROVIDING SOME OVERVIEW OF SOME
OF THE KEY PROPOSALS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S NAME REVISION WE ALSO
HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND
SOME OF THE PROPOSALS THAT MR
EDELMAN. ARE PRESENTED EARLIER
AND THOSE WERE EMAILED OUT YOUR
STAFFING HERE TODAY AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO GO ON BECAUSE. S. BEGIN
ALTERNATIVELY ON DEPARTMENT
LEGAL. AS MYSTERY ONLY NOTED THE
ADMINS IS PROJECTING AS THE-
DECLINE IN THE NUMBER OF INMATES
. HOLDEN THE PRISON WHICH WILL
THE- TO CLOSE IT IS QUESTIONS
FIVE TWENTY. FIVE ONE THING WE
WOULD KNOW HOW. IS THAT EVEN
WITH THE CLOSURE MUSIC THIS
PRISONS STAY RESIDENTS. BASED ON
THE PROJECTIONS CURRENTLY FOR BY
MINISTRY WANTS HAVE TEN THOUSAND
THAT. ACCORDINGLY THE WHAT IS
MIGHT WANT TO ASK THE ADMIN.
WHAT IT'S ARE FOR DEALING THE
ACT TO PAST WEEK IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND BEYOND. IN
ADDITION AS MR IN NOTED THERE
WERE NOTABLE. IN HALF AWAY. ARE
MOST NOTABLE. KICK THAT PROJECT
THAT WAS NOT. THE GOVERNMENT
GONNA HIT BOB CROWD WITH BECAUSE
WHILE YEAR DEPARTMENT HAS
REQUESTED AND ALL. AND HEAD IN
THE AT THAT ABOUT WOULD BE A LOT. YES SIR. GROSS OF THE
INCREASES X. BY THAT. IN CAN'T
PROJECTS AND SEE CITIES ARE OUT
OF THE CONTROLS AS CREASES IN.
OR HAND THEM RELATED FACTOR.
GIVEN WILL NOT AND MAGNITUDE AND
FREE. OF COST INCREASES AND
ARTICLE PER. WE THINK THAT THE-
MAIN TO CONSIDER EXERCISE
GREATER OVERSIGHT OVER YOUR
KAPPA. PLANNING AND- MANAGING.
RIGHT SPECIFICALLY BY REQUESTING
FREE IT OF THE FORMER. I'M SURE
THAT YOU KNOW THE POLICY OR
PROCEDURE ARE BEING TO COST
INCREASES BECAUSE THEY WERE THE
VERY CONSIDER THAT WILL
CERTAINLY. AS A DEPARTMENT TO
TAKE ON ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
IN. PROJECTS THE NEXT TEN YEARS. HEARING NO JUDICIAL. OF MOSTLY
PROPOSAL THE JUDICIAL MAY
REVISION. IS AS MR- WE ARE. IS
FOR EMPOWER. COURT THE PROPOSAL
WE DON'T THIS IS WHAT PROPOSAL
FOR THE JUDICIAL. IS ACTUALLY ME
THE PROPOSAL FOR THE OF AGING AS
WELL AS A FOR HEALTH CARE SIR.
CAN PACKAGE PROPOSALS IN
INTENDED TO INFORM THE FOR WHERE
YOU KNOW WHEN THIS PROPOSED.
WHAT YOU JUST IS GOING TO KEEP
IN MIND THAT THE DEEP OF HOW
COURT WOULD OPERATE. FOR A LONG
CURRENTLY OUT IN A SPEAKER THREE
EIGHT WHICH IS GOING THROUGH THE
POLICY. AND IS THEREFORE TO
CHANGE THIS MEANS THAT TOTAL OF
ONE NEEDS AT THIS FOR MOBILE
OPERATE HERE FOR A- COULD BE
AFFECTED BY. FACTORS THAT WE
SOME TO YOUR- WITH INCLUDE HOW
REPORTS WONDER THIS THING HOPE.
IS ENDED TO USE CARE PRICE RAW
THAN OTHER COURT. AVAILABLE OF
YOUR SUFFICIENT STATE READ. THE
LEVEL OF THE REQUIRED SEATING
AND THE RULES OR IS TO OF WHICH
IS THE NUMBERS. PARTICULARLY. TO
IT'S GOOD TO FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO WAY THIS PROPOSAL AGAINST
OTHER GENERAL FUND OR EASE
REPORTING WE THINK THAT FREE TO
THIS PROPOSAL FORTY GOVERNOR'S
MAIN REBEL MATHIS ONE. NO TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OF MORE THAN SIX.
FUNDS WOMAN THERE ARE PROPOSAL
IN THE GOVERNOR NAME RIVER TO
CANCEL STATE'S EMERGENCY
OFFICERS HOWEVER SIMILAR TO YOUR
CHEN FOURTH HOPEFULS FOR THE
IT'S DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHAT
THESE FOR GOAL. REFLECT AMONG
EFFECT AND EFFICIENT APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THIS WORK NEEDS
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT BASEBALL
COOPER PLAN TO ENHANCE THIS WORK
YEARS CAPACITY ACCORDING WE CAN
. TO RECOMMEND THAT LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE WELL YES SUCH A PLAN.
REMARKS AND WE'RE HAPPY. MY
FATHER LMAO COLLEAGUES ON.
HEARING TO QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH- THERE ARE SEVERAL
AREAS IN THIS THAT- PROBABLY
HAVE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON
MAYBE WE COULD- DO THE MALL AT
THE SAME TIME BY SECTION SO WHY
DON'T WE START WITH-
CORRECTIONS. ANY ANYTHING ON
CORRECTIONS AND THEN WILL GO TO
JUDICIARY AND PUBLIC SAFETY AND
THE OTHER SECTIONS SIR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MANAGER JOB WANT TO
TOUCH BASE ON- BUT PRISON
CLOSURES MR EDELMAN NOTED THAT I
THINK IT'S OUR COLLECTIVE THREE
PRISONS MAYBE STATE FOR CLOSURE
AND IN. THE NEAR AL YEARS- ANY
PREVIOUS COVERAGE WE WE'VE WE'VE
ADDRESS QUESTIONS TO- AND TO THE
ANSWER COMING BACK WAS IT THAT
YOU KNOW THIS IS HOLLOW IT'S
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY THOSE
PRISONS MOREOVER IS A BIG IMPACT
ON THOSE COMMUNITIES SO IT'S
SOMETHING TO BE. TO TREAD
LIGHTLY AROUND BUT- IT OBVIOUSLY
HAS IMPLICATIONS FOR BUDGETING
AND A COUPLE AREAS A CAP OUT
LASERS I THINK MR SODERBERGH
NOTED- ALSO BELIEVE THIS BROADER
QUESTION EXCESS CAPACITY NINE
SHOULD BE YOU KNOW SOMEONE EXTRA
EXCESS CAPACITY WILL BE
ADDRESSED. THROUGH THOSE
CLOSURES SHOW THAT TO MR EDELMAN
HOW CAN WE- THIS COMMITTEE BUT
THE LEGISLATURE MARGINALLY GET
GREATER INSIGHT AS TO WHERE THE
CLUB WHICH MIGHT TAKE PLACE.
THAT SHOW THAT THAT CAN INFORM
SOME OF THE OTHER DISCUSSIONS
AROUND BUDGING AS I MENTIONED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION THAT
ANY IT'S A REALLY GOOD ONE ANY
IS A DAY. AND THAT WE DO NEED TO
MAKE THESE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE NVESTMENTS A LOT
OF THEM HAVE TO DO WITH- GARCIA
POPULATION HEALTH CARE KIND OF.
YOU KNOW SAFETY OR FIRE LIFE
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS WE DO PRIORITIZE
OUR ON CAPITAL INVESTMENTS. YOU
KNOW ON A YEAR TO YEAR BASIS
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
TO PRIORITIZE THOSE INSTITUTIONS
THAT HAVEN'T URGENT AND
IMMEDIATE NEED- BUT IT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT WE
BALLOTS AND TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WE'RE PLANNING FOR
LONGER TERM OUTLOOKS- BUT AS YOU
MENTIONED IT IS KIND OF A
DIFFICULT PROCESS AND- IF THERE
ARE ESSENTIAL. NEEDS ANYTHING
BACK. WHILE KIND OF BALANCING
PROJECTIONS THEY GO INTO THE
FUTURE. BUT LIKE MIGHT NOT BE
CERTAIN. INCEPTION THE AND
OTHERS HAVE H. FOR YOU YOU KNOW
THIS IS A ONGOING. QUESTION
GENTLY YOU HOME YOU KNOW THE
SUPPOSED TO GO IS REDUCE THE
PRISON BY. SHIP DO YOU KNOW BY
A- FORGET HAVE TO. WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF FACILITIES- BUT I THINK MORE
PORTLY TO YOUR POINT WITH YOU
KNOW THEIR WHOLE BUNCH OF.
RELATED CONSIDERATIONS- THAT
COME INTO INVESTORS THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT AUTHORIZED. SO
OBVIOUSLY IN NEED OF FURTHER
DISCUSSION EITHER YOU KNOW IN
SPITE YOUR FUTURE CONVERSATIONS
OF THANKS. THANK YOU SEVEN
NEWMAN. THE COURTESY. IT CAN
ASSUME OUT A LITTLE BIT AND A DO
AGREE WITH THEM. CENTER NEWMAN
CONCERT WE JUST SAY STATE- ON
THE RECORD WE TALKED ABOUT IT IN
THE- BUT I THINK. THE TIS
COMMITTEE. I THINK THE MAJORITY
THIS COMMITTEES. OF BEEN. REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT- THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CAPITAL
INVESTMENT IN ENCLOSURE BECAUSE
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THE
CRITERIA IS FOR CLOSURE WITH THE
SCHEDULE IS- IS IT KIND OF
SOUNDED LIKE THAT HASN'T BEEN
DEVELOPED IN PAST HEARINGS BUT I
JUST WANTED TO GO BACK TO THE
CRITERIA BECAUSE YOU MOUNT A
LITTLE BIT- YOU TO SENATOR
NEWMAN AYE- ACTUALLY TOURED- ONE
OF THE PRISONERS RECENTLY AND IT
WOULD BE PRETTY CLEAR TO ME
WITHOUT HAVING ANY KIND OF
FORMAL CRITERIA AT THAT
PARTICULAR LOCATION. WOULD NOT
BE- WOULD PROBABLY NOT BE DOES
NEED FOR CLOSURE BASED ON THE
POPULATION- AND YOU KNOW THE
SENSE OF THE POPULATION ALTHOUGH
OBVIOUSLY POPULATIONS CAN BE
MOVED- SO I'M I'M UNCLEAR ON
JUST WOULD. AGAIN USE THAT TERM
TOPLINE I MEAN WHAT ARE THE
BASIC CRITERIA THAT ARE IN PLAY-
ADEQUACY OF THE BOTH OF THE
FACILITIES- THE- NEED FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY. IT IS THAT. IT
SOMEBODY MUST BE WORKING OFF
SOME BASIC CRITERIA AT THIS
POINT BECAUSE TOOL AND- AND-
HERE AND THEN THE STAND THIS IS
A BILLS FACILITY. YOU KNOW HAVE
HAVE HAVE ALREADY BEEN MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION SOMEBODY APPLIED
SOME CRITERIA THAT AND I GUESS
MAYBE THAT'S THE REAL QUESTION
IS THAT IS BASICALLY THE SAME
CRITERIA IT'S GONNA BE EXTENDED
OUT AND IF SO- HOW DO WE GET OUR
HANDS ON THAT SURE NACHSHON
QUESTIONING AND SENATOR THIS IS
JUST NEWMAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THERE IS EXISTING
CRITERION PENAL CODE SECTION
TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
INCLUDES FACTORS INCLUDE BUT
AREN'T LIMITED TO THE COST TO
OPERATE THE FACILITY SO KIND OF
THOSE INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS. BUT
ALSO THE WORK FORCE AND TAXED AT
A LOCAL- COMMUNITY A
SUBPOPULATION GENDER SPECIFIC
HOUSING NEEDS DEPENDING ON EACH
FACILITY THEY KIND OF HAVE THEIR
INDIVIDUAL PURPOSES AND CAN
POPULATIONS- LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
PROGRESS INSTEAD OF MAY MATER
DEFINITELY CONSIDERED ONE WORK
FACTORING IN KIND OF WHAT
CRITERIA WE'RE LOOKING AT. TAKE
IN REHABILITATION AGAIN SO OF
DEPENDING ON THE PRIORITY OF
INSTANT AND WE POPULOUS IT
SERVES AND KIND OF JUST TERRIBLE
ONGOING SOLUTIONS FOR PRISON
OVERCROWDING POPULAR. A
SITUATION. SO RECENTLY THAT
INCLUDES CERTAIN THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW IN THE SAFETY AND ANALYTE
AND I MAKING KIND OF VARIOUS
FACTORS WITH THE HEALTH OF THE
POPULATION- BUT THERE ARE
EXISTING FACTORS STATE BANK
MINISTRATION DOES CONSIDER WHEN
CONSIDERING PRESENTS TO CLOSE-
AND THEY ARE VERY COMPLICATED
AND- OBVIOUSLY AND MISS EDUCATED
BY. THINGS LIKE THE IMPACT TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY HAS TO
MENTION- WITH CLOSURE OF. THE
INSTITUTIONS. USING ABOUT. BUT
WHEN START MOVING YOU KNOW I IT
IS BECAUSE- IN- THERE'S- YOU
KNOW IT'S KIND OF A PUZZLE IS
THE WAY I WOULD DESCRIBE IT WITH
WITH MOVABLE PIECES AND- IN IN.
IT WOULD SEEM TO RESULT IN A SET
OF OPTIONS OR ALTERNATIVES-
SCENARIO A SCENARIO B. IT IS IT
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE AN EXERCISE IN
SCENARIO PLANNING- IN IN IF SO
IT WOULD SEEM THAT THERE'S SOME
RANK. B. TO. GO FOR CORRECTIONAL
STUDENTS TO BUILT YOU KNOW. YOU
KNOW I I'M JUST IMAGINE THIS IN
INTERNALLY SO TO SPEAK- THAT
THERE'S MAYBE A SCHEDULE IS
SCHEDULED BE A SCHEDULE C.
DEPENDING ON HOW HIGH YOU WAIT
THOSE THOSE MOVING PARTS THAT
YOU JUST DESCRIBED IF THAT'S THE
CASE THAT IT I GET IT THAT IT
WOULD BE SENSITIVE TO- YOU KNOW
RELEASE DETAILS LIKE THAT
PARTICULARLY WITH. THE COMMUNITY
IMPACT PEACE IN MIND BUT- HOW
MUCH OF THAT CAN WE CAN WE COME
TO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW AT THIS
POLICY LOW. I GUESS WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS MUCH OF THAT
INFORMATION AS WE CAN- WITHOUT
PREMATURELY. YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW
PUTTING INFORMATION OUT THERE IN
THE PUBLIC SPHERE. I UNDERSTAND
AND AGREE COMPLETELY AND WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TAKE HAVING
CONTINUING ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON IN
PARTICULAR THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
KIND OF WHAT FACTORS WITH
CONSIDERING AND OPTIONS. OKAY
WELL WE'LL KEEP ASKING IN- YOU
KNOW I WOULD. EXCEPT IN EXPECT
THAT WE WILL GET INFORMATION
BACK INCREMENTALLY ASSIST
DEVELOPED AND IT'S SUITABLE FOR
RELEASE BUT- YOU KNOW I ALSO-
JOB IS NOT TO ASSUME THINGS BUT
TO. THE REQUESTED TO KEEP ASKIN
SO- BOOK FORTY GETTING
INFORMATION IS S SOON AS YOU
GET IT TO US THANK YOU.
COMMITTER THANK YOU SENATOR
CORTEZ THE- DO YOU COULD SENSE
FROM AT LEAST THREE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE. THAT
WE HAVE ASKED FOR INFORMATION.
PLEASE AS LONG AS- TWO THREE
YEARS NOW WE'VE BEEN HERE- TO
HELP US MAKE THESE DECISIONS.
ALL HELP US MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
OR HELP SUPPORT. ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DECISION AND WE
KEEP COMING BACK WITH. NOTHING
MORE THAN A HANDFUL OF.
POTENTIAL FACTORS ARE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT SO HOW DO WE MAKE
RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS WE KEEP
ASKING THAT QUESTION WE DO NOT
GET THE INFORMATION- THERE'S THE
EXCESS CAPACITY OF TEN THOUSAND
BEDS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
THAT YOU CONSIDER A REASONABLE-
EXCESS CAPACITY- WHAT DO WE DO
ABOUT THAT. I RAISE THE ISSUE
THAT YES THERE'S IMPACT ON
COMMUNITY THE COMMUNITIES- WE
ALWAYS TELL THEM. TO GO THROUGH
OF A PROCESS THAT TAKES THEM
INTO CONSIDERATION WHAT WOULD
THE IMPACT BE OR WE THINKING
THAT IT'S BEST JUST TO DROP IT
ON THEM. IS THAT IS THAT HAT
YOU THINK IS THE BEST OF ALL.
THE WAY TO GO. I DON'T THINK SO
I THINK PEOPLE WOULD WANT TO
KNOW THE WANT TO PLAN- FOR
ANYTHING THAT COULD BE COMING.
SUCH AS THE CLOSURE SO. WHERE WE
GONNA END UP HERE WE KEEP ASKING
INFORMATION AND WE DON'T GET
THAT PLAN WE DON'T GET THE
FUNDAMENTAL INFORMATION THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS AND
IT'S- IT'S I THINK IT'S
DISRESPECTFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE
NOT TO PROVIDE THAT BASIC
INFORMATION. BUT WE'RE GOING TO
GET ANY FURTHER TODAY WILL HAVE
TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING ELSE-
HI I HAVE A SPECIFIC QUESTION
THOUGH OF FOR CDC ARE. OF WITH
REGARDS TO PROJECT MANAGEMENT I
THINK THIS WAS MENTIONED BY. OF
ALL THE L. A. O. WITH EGARDS TO
THE VOLUME OF CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS AND HOW ARE YOU MOVING
FORWARD- IT'S PRETTY. PRETTY
HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S
GOING INTO CAPITAL OUTLAY HOW DO
YOU PROPOSE TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE
THAT. THE MANAGER MEMBERS- CHRIS
LEAF WITH. CITY C. AREN'T ANY
DIRECTOR FACILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION AND MANAGEMENT
DIVISION- YEAH THAT'S YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF- PROJECTS
MOVING FORWARD AND- WE HAVE-
YEAH I READING INTO YOUR
QUESTION A LITTLE BIT- I THINK-
YOU'RE CONCERNED WITH HOW DO WE-
PREVENT THE MISTAKES THAT WERE
MADE WITH THE TECH FOR PROGRAMS
AND PROJECTS GOING FORWARD- WE
ARE ADDRESSING- THE LESSONS
LEARNED WITH EXCEPT IN ANOTHER
AND A NUMBER OF WAYS. LEE AND
THE PLANNING OF NEW PROJECTS-
FOR INSTANCE- WHEN WE ARE
CONCEPTUALLY DEVELOPING PROJECT
SCOPE COST AND SCHEDULE. WE NOW
ENSURE THAT EVALUATION OF
EXISTING UTILITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS IT'S
INCLUDED IN THE PROCESS. ALSO IN
PICKED UP WE HAD A NUMBER OF
FAILURES OF WITH THEIR
ARCHITECTURAL ENGINEERING FIRMS-
AND HEALTHCARE- TWO CHILDREN
CELLS FORMS WHEN THEY WERE
DEFINING PROJECTS. ACCORDINGLY
WE HAVE ADDED A CONTRACT
LANGUAGE WITH THOSE FIRMS IT
CLEARLY IDENTIFY THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES WORK FIELD
VERIFICATION OF SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS I DON'T
CREATION OF UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES AND DESTRUCTIVE
TESTING TO THE EXTENT FEASIBLE
WITH THEM. OPERATING FACILITIES
. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER LEAF
LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO- TO
JUDICIARY. I THINK MAY HAVE THE-
MOST THE- ISSUES AND- AND
QUESTIONS HERE ARE I DON'T KNOW
WHO'S GOING TO ANSWER THAT ON
BEHALF OF THE ADMINISTRATION ALL
I'M SORRY BY THE WAY- THE DAILY-
HAVE ANY OTHER ISSUES ON
CORRECTIONS I BELIEVE YOU
ADDRESS THEM BUT- IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE. THOSE OF. WE ARE
PREPARED REMARKS ON ON THEM BUT
IF THERE'S ANY PARTICULAR-
PROPOSAL WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
NAME REGIONALLY BY DEFAULT THE
PRINCIPLE OF MORAL. OKAY. FOR
OKAY- OKAY WITH TO JUDY- I DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS AND I
THINK FOLLOWING ALONG WITH WITH
THE L. A. O. OF THE ISSUES THAT
THE L. A- RAISED- WE KNOW THAT
THE- CARE COURT PROPOSAL IS
STILL BEING WORKED OUT AND IT.
COVERS AND CROSSES ON A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT AREAS- I THINK WHAT
IS BEFORE US MIGHT BE JUST A
GUESS I WITH THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
IS GOING TO NEED- MY CONCERN I
HOW DO WE- ENSURE. THAT THE
WORKLOAD OF FOR THE COURTS-
DOESN'T OVERWHELM THE EXISTING
TRIAL COURT DUTIES- HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THE RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUALS TO LEGAL COUNSEL.
AND DUE PROCESS ARE PROTECTED- I
THINK THAT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
HOW MANY PETITIONS DO YOU
EXPECT- HOW DO PEOPLE FILE THEM
ARE THERE-FILING FEES. I DON'T
THINK ANY OF THESE ARE OF
FINALLY- DECIDED- IN TERMS OF
MOVING FORWARD BUT- BEYOND THE
FUNDING FOR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH-
ARE THERE ENOUGH SERVICES SUCH
AS BEDS AND BE BEHAVE.
FACILITIES THAT YOU GET A
BUILDER REFER PARTICIPANTS TO
SO. IF THERE ARE ANY NORMA'S
NUMBER OF OPEN QUESTIONS SO IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO EVALUATE THE
FUNDING THE BUDGET SIDE OF THAT
WITHOUT THAT FOG CONTEXT- SO- I
DON'T KNOW WHO. WILL RESPOND TO
THAT. HI- TOM MARKHAM THE PART
OF FINE- I CAN. RESPOND TO THE
POINTS THAT YOU'VE MADE IN THE
IN THE ARE ALL REALLY GREAT
POINTS AND- WE'VE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT THE- THE POLICY FOR THE
CARE COURT IT'S STILL UNDER-
UNDER- THERE IS STILL BEING
DEVELOPED AND ADDS YOU'VE ALSO
NOTED DEFENSE AND OTHER- OTHER
AGENCIES UNDER THE- THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES- BUT THE
PROPOSAL FOR YOU IT'S REALLY
SPECIFIC TO THE DISTAL BRANCHEN
AND YEAH AND MAYBE TO ADDRESS
YOUR YOUR FIRST ARE CONCERNED
WITH REGARDS TO. THE IMPACTS TO
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH AND YOU KNOW
I'M THE USER BY. WE RECOGNIZE.
THAT AIRPORT WILL- I WILL WORK
MORE OF THE-BRANCH IN. THIS IS
CERTAINLY WHY HAVE- IDENTIFY.
THESE IT DOES. THESE COSTS
INCLUDE THESE- APPOINTED THESE.
WITH THEM- THE GIRL FAVOR. TO-
THEY'RE NOT- THE ADDITIONAL. ON
THE TO DO BRANCH AND TO THEM THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO- TO YOU
KNOW BY. WE CONTINUE THEIR
CURRENT SERVICE THEIR CURRENT
OPERATIONS BUT ALSO TO TAKE ON
THIS ADDITIONAL WORK LOAD- NOW
WE- WE'VE ALSO INCLUDED
RESOURCES FOR SELF HELP CENTERS. TO- GUY. TO SOMEHOW SAN IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT- I- TO ASSIST- IT IN
THE- WHO- BY MY- ONCE READ THE
OR AT S. LEVEL IN. BEING PART OF
THAT THAT THEY CARE- THE IN IN A
LOT OF YOUR I FEEL LIKE A LOT OF
YOUR YOUR QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
ARE THE RE REALLY DEPENDS ON HOW
THE POLICY WILL- WILL. LAND AT
THE AT THE END OF THE DAY AND AS
YOU HAVE NOTED IS STILL BEING
UNDERDEVELOPED AND YOU KNOW-
WERE OR- WERE TAKING NOTE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE BEING RAISED
BY- BY YOUR- BY YOU YOURSELF OFF
YOUR- YOUR STAFF AND HAS ALL THE
L. A. O. WERE- LOOKING FOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH. THE LEGISLATURE- IN IN-
REFINING THE POLICY I- AND
MAKING SURE THAT I. D. THE-
FIVE. IS IT IS IN PLACE AND
EVERYONE IS SET UP TO. DO YOU
HAVE- MISS. I GUESS THE GET AT
THIS I KNOW HOW YOU IT I HER THE
NOT- SOMEWHERE ABOUT. THE
POTENTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
COULD FILE THE PETITIONS MAYBE I
GOT THIS CONFUSED WITH SOMEWHERE
AROUND. SEVEN THOUSAND MAYBE GOT
THAT CONFUSED WITH ANOTHER
NUMBER BUT- HOW ARE YOU TO MAKE
THIS KIND OF A REQUEST- FOR
THIRTY NINE MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. I KNOW THERE'S
ADDITIONAL OF FUNDING FOR THE
TRIAL COURT FACILITIES BUT WHAT
DO YOU WHAT DO YOU SO FAR BASE
IT OFF OF SO THAT WE COULD KNOW.
HOW TO RESPOND TO THE SPECIFIC
REQUEST THAT'S BEING MADE. SO
OUR OUR OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS
THAT MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR ON THE
CARE PROGRAM IS BETWEEN SEVEN TO
TWELVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS AND
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU ASSUMES-
THE- THAT THE MIDPOINTS ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND- HEY INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATING IN THE CARE
PROGRAM. AND BASED ON THAT IS
THIS- THIS ITEM FOR UP THIRTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN
SOME ADDITIONAL TWELVE COURT
FACILITY FUNDING. THE B.
TRACKWORK BASILIDES FINDINGS ARM
ARE SEPARATE AND APART FROM THE
CARE FOR OKAY SO IT'S REALLY TO-
FOR OF EXISTING I'M PROJECTS
AND- OR ANY EXISTING FACILITY.
SO THE- FUNDING FOR THIRTY NINE
AND A HALF MILLION THAT'S THE
AMOUNT THAT YOU BELIEVE WILL
COVER THE APPROXIMATELY TEN
THOUSAND. CASES CORRECT THAT'S
WORK ENOUGH YES GOOD OKAY-
MEMBERS ON THE CARE COURT. I
KNOW I AM SORRY I HAD ONE MORE
IS- I THEIR COURT FEES- ARE YOU
THINKING OF A- ADDING COURT FEES
IN THIS. COURT PROCESS. WORK-
CURRENTLY HAS FORTY AREN'T
REFLECTED IN THE CURRENT VERSION
OF THE SPELL CONI'M AND I'M I'M
NOT AWARE. OF ANY DISCUSSIONS
WITH WITH INCORPORATING ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME OKAY. AND
UP HAVE YOUTH- THOUGHT ABOUT
RULES CREWS GOING TO PROVIDE
LEGAL ASSISTANCE. SO- WOULD BE
AS THE THIRTEENTH EIGHT FOR-
PUBLIC THE CORE TO APPOINT A
PUBLIC DEFENDER AS WELL AS THIS-
OFF FOR THE- FOR THE PART TO. ON
I WE ARE- THEY WERE BE REACHED.
ARE THERE MAY BE SOME FOR THE
OFFICE OF. THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE- AS PART OF THIS. EFFORT
OKAY DO YOU KNOW IF THAT INCLUDE
IN THE THREE NINE AND A HALF
MILLION. IT'S NOT PART OF THE
THIRTY NINE AND A HALF BILLION
IT IS PART OF- IT'S STILL ON
SOMETHING ABOUT THE INITIATION
IS STILL DEVELOPING- AND FOR
WORKING WITH LOCALS ON TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND- AND FINALIZE OUR
ESTIMATES. OKAY THAT'S IT FOR ME
YES SENATE QUARTERS YES OF
COURSE IS THIS IS SOMETHING OF A
OF STATED- UNIT IN A NUMBER OF
PER MEETINGS BUT NOT AT THIS
COMMITTEE OR AND I'M SURE IN A
PUBLIC HEARING- IN TERMS CARE
COURT THAT I. THINK NEEDS TO BE
OUT. ON THE RECORD- FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. THE ONLY PREFACE BY
SAYING THAT I PUBLICLY SUPPORTED
YOU KNOW THIS THIS DIRECTION
THIS CONCEPT OF CARE COURT BE
PER TO- ANY KIND OF LEGISLATIVE
LANGUAGE EVEN BEING INTRODUCED.
THE EXPLANATION. HE HANDED THAT
I'VE BEEN GIVEN IN IN SOME OF
THAT'S BEEN DIRECTLY BY THE
GOVERNOR- HAS BEEN THAT. IT AT
SOME LEVEL THIS IS INTENDED TO-
HE BEAT THE FACT TO EXTENSION OF
THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY OR FIFTY TO
FIFTY PROCESS FOR PEOPLE
PARTICULAR PSYCHOSIS AND
SCHIZOPHRENIA WHO. MIGHT BE A
HARM TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS AND
THEREFORE- THERE THERE WOULD BE
TO BE. PLANS- MANDATED CARE OF
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME THAT WOULD
EXTEND BEYOND WHAT'S CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE THROUGH TODAY STATURE
TODAY'S PROCESSES- WHICH DON'T
EVEN ALLOW HOLDS YOU KNOW FOR
LONGER THAN THE FIFTY TO FIFTY
PERIOD CERTAINLY NOTHING LIKE
THIRTY DAYS- IN AND I THINK
THAT'S ACTUALLY GREAT BECAUSE MY
OWN. EXPERIENCE AS AS A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL IN AN OTHERWISE HAS
BEEN- AROUND THE POPULATION WHO-
IS DIAGNOSED THAT WAY- THAT-
THEY NEED THEY NEED BEDS SHORT
TERM BEFORE GOING TO STEP DOWN
FACILITIES- YOU KNOW SO THAT
THEIR STABILIZATION PERIOD IS
ENOUGH TO GET THEM. TO THE TO
THAT NEXT STEP OF STEP DOWN
FACILITIES AND OF COURSE IN
ESSENCE MAINSTREAMING BACK INTO
SOCIETY- ALL THAT REQUIRES AND
BRING THIS BACK THE BUDGET HERE
RICK WOULD REQUIRE I THINK A
HUGE INVESTMENT IN- IN BEDS IN
FACILITIES AND I'VE I'VE HEARD
THAT STATED BY OTHERS IN IN
VARIOUS DIFFERENT WAYS- I HAVE
YET TO SEE ANY KIND OF
CORRESPONDING INVESTMENT COME
FORWARD. IN A NEWS. RELEASE ONE
OF OUR COLLEAGUES- FROM
LEGISLATIVE STAMP- INTRODUCED.
BACK IN JANUARY OR FEBRUARY THAT
WAS LOOKING. AHEAD TO MAKE JUST
A VERY DIRECT INVESTMENT INTO-
PSYCH BEDS I MEAN THAT'S HOW HE
REFERRED TO IN HIS BILL- SO YOU
KNOW I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
TENSION AROUND THIS CONCEPT IN.
AROUND THIS IDEA OF YOU KNOW
LET'S NOT MANDATE LOCKING PEOPLE
UP- I AGREE WITH THAT AS WELL-
BUT- TO THE EXTENT THAT- A CARE
PLAN- PRESCRIBED NOT JUST BY A
JUDGE POPE COULD PRESCRIBE BY
THOSE QUALIFIED TO DIAGNOSE- THE
INDIVIDUAL'S CONDITION IN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT IS GOING TO
TAKE TO STABILIZE THEM. REQUIRES
BETS REQUIRES FACILITIES THOSE
FACILITIES JUST AREN'T HERE YET
AND I JUST DON'T BELIEVE I KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT. APPS THE
INVESTMENT IN IN ROM KEY- HERE
AND IN OTHER PROGRAMS SAID
FRANKLY ARE MORE DESIGNED FOR-
THE GENERAL AND HOUSE POPULATION
OUT THERE THAT YOU KNOW HOMES
POPULATION THAT SOMEHOW. THOSE
COULD WORK OF FOR THESE PURPOSES
IT BUT THOSE ARE NOT. HEALTH
CARE. PSYCH BEDS FOR BED SAID.
YOU NORMALLY WOULD SEE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR WRAPAROUND SERVICES ON
SO I JUST WANT TO PUT IT OUT
THERE THAT I'M I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT SINCE WE ARE IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE- THIS IS BUT
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE OF BROTHER-
IN IN YOU KNOW I AGAIN I'VE
TRIED MADAM CHAIR AND I THINK
YOU KNOW ANYTHING COME SIR
NEWMAN SAID HER ME AT LEAST.
COMMENT ON THIS BEFORE IN IN
VARIOUS OTHER FORMS- BUT IT BUT
I DON'T THINK I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR IS I MEAN
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSAL
BUT A I JUST THINK THAT- WE NEED
TO BE VERY VERY CAREFUL YOU KNOW
NOT TO CREE IN EFFECT. A HUGE
FOR IN TERMS OF AN UNFUNDED
ASPECT OF WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE REQUIRED. TO MAKE THIS
WORK. THANK YOU. GREAT REMARKS
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I THINK
IT'S A IT'S A SIMILAR
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION
THAT'S HAD ABOUT OUR OWN HOUSE.
OF HOW WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THEM
WE DON'T WANT THEM TO SUFFER ON
THE STREETS LIVE IN TENTS LIVE
IN THOSE KIND OF ENCAMPMENTS AND
YET WE DON'T. WHERE DO YOU PUT A
- WHERE WHERE DO WE SET WHAT WE
SAY TO THEM ABOUT WE WANT YOU TO
LEAVE THE STREETS AND THE
SIDEWALKS AND YOU'RE TENSE. AND
WHAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE FOR THEM
WHERE DO THEY GO TO WORK AND
THEY FEEL SAFE TO GO AND IS IT
GOING TO BE FOR ONE NIGHT AND
TWO NIGHTS AND THEN THEY'RE BACK
ON THE STREETS SO WE HAVE TO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE IF THIS PLAN'S
GOING TO WORK HE'S GOT A REALLY
LOOK AT THE WHOLE PROCESS AND- I
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING IN THE WAY
THAT THAT YOU SET IT. UP BECAUSE
IF WE DON'T HAVE THOSE OF
SERVICES WHERE WHERE WE'RE JUST
KIDDING OURSELVES THIS IS JUST
COULDN'T TURN INTO SOMETHING
ELSE A MANDATED TREATMENT BUT
NOT REALLY THE SERVICES AND THE
BEDS AND THE FACILITIES THAT
THAT THEY WILL NEED TO GET
BETTER. IN THEIR HEALTH- IN THE
ELSE- L. A. O. AND ELSE ON THAT
THAT YOU COULD ADD OR WANT TO
ADD. I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO HAPPEN WILL SET
. MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS FOR US
OKAY THANK YOU I WILL MOVE ON
TO- PUBLIC SAFETY IN TERMS OF
OUR OWN COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
HERE- I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
THE SENTINEL ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
- HOW IS THAT WORK- GOING TO BE
COORDINATED WITH THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND OTHER ENTITIES ON
THIS. TOPIC. GOOD MORNING KEVIN
CLARK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. OKAY SO THE IDEA DOJA
INTENDS TO FULLY COLLABORATE
WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES LIKE
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENTS. AND
DPH AND ALSO- INTENDS TO
COLLABORATE WITH LOCALS TO
REALLY ADDRESS WHAT'S GOING ON
IN CERTAIN AREAS ACROSS THE
STATE. OKAY. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
ON THAT NOTE OKAY. I JUST HAVE
THIS IS- THIS MAY HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WAS A SKIPPED
OVER BUT ON THE NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT. ISSUE. AT THAT
ON HERE- I JUST WANNA ADD THAT-
HE SHAPE THAT THE INVESTMENT IS
GOING INTO THAT ESPECIALLY
NONPROFITS OF THE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES BUT- SINCE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES WERE IDENTIFIED I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE- THE
LATINO COMMUNITY IS ALSO ADDED
TO THAT- TO THAT ISSUE. OR TO
FINANCE STEVEN BENSON YEAH B.
THE LIST THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
THE DESCRIPTION. WASN'T INTENDED
TO BE A COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF
WHO'S ELIGIBLE. FOR THAT SO I
CERTAINLY FEEL ANY ANY COMMUNITY
THAT- HAS THESE NEED TO BE
ELIGIBLE. FOR THAT IF THE
FEATURE THAT FUNDING AND GRANT
PROGRAM. OKAY IT WAS A IT WAS A
GOOD LIST THAT WAS THE ONLY
COMMUNITY THAT I SAW THAT WAS
LEFT OUT SO THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT WE IT IT WOULD BE GOOD JUST
TO. IF WE'RE GONNA. DO MOST OF
THE COMMUNITIES THE LIST. TO
ALL. OF THE COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THANK. THE
JUDICIARY IS TWO HUNDRED. RIGHT. NO WE DID THAT OKAY WE DID
THAT I JUST JUMPED OVER- OKAY
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO PART
B. ARE WE READY FOR THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE- TO PART B. OBARA GENDA.
AND THAT IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
THE START WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OVERVIEW OF THE
MAY REVISE PROPOSALS AND LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT RETIREMENT
EMPLOYMENT ISSUE ONE- WE HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE L. A. O.
AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS FIRST
DEPARTMENTS- PRESENT. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN. ORINGER BETTER
TELL THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
ME GIVING ME OVER YOUR FOR ISSUE
ONE ON THE CATEGORY- THE MAYOR
REGION INCLUDES A NUMBER OF ONE
TIME PROPOSAL- FOR THE LABOR
AREA- WILL BEGIN WITH THE
EXTREME HEAT THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS.
YOU CAN SEVENTEEN MILLION OVER
TWO YEARS TO EXPAND HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS AND
INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT THE FOURTH
THE STATE'S RESPONSE THREE FEET.
AND TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS PROTECT VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. GET OUT REACHED
EDUCATE ASSOCIATION. BEFORE AND
DURING THE EVENT TO PROTECT
WORKERS FROM HEAT RELATED
ILLNESS. THE PROPOSAL MORE OFTEN
PART OF A LARGER EXTREME HEAT
PACKAGES THAT WOULD GUIDE IN
DETAIL IN THE SENATE THEM
THROUGH LAST WEEK. THREE BILLION
- THE IMPRESSIONS. FUNDING
PROGRAM THROUGH A SHIFT FROM THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL OF
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACT THIS INNOVATION
WORKFORCE PROPOSALS. THE
GOVERNMENT'S GOVERNMENT BUDGET
JEFF THAT FUNDING PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS. TO ESTABLISH
THE APPRENTICESHIP INNOVATION
FUNDING PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR. INNOVATIVE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM AND EXPAND
THIS THING NONTRADITIONAL
APPRENTICES. AMERICAN ALSO
INCLUDES TRAILER LANGUAGE
EMPLOYED THIS PART. FOR THE
MARION INCLUDING THE HUNDRED
THANK MILLION ONE TIME BUT
EQUALLY FROM GENERAL AND IF
BILLION FIVE. IF YOU NEED HELP
PLANNING A- YOU KNOW A FIVE YEAR
MY INITIATIVE FOR EDIE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT DISABILITY AND PAID
FRAME LEAVE. FORTY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION- OVER THREE YEARS
TO THE FOR ONGOING EFFORTS IN.
HE CROWD INVEST. PROCESS SEVERAL
OF THE REDUCTION OF EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION SCRIPT LIKE UPDATED
ESTIMATE OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE LOAN INTEREST OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT THE END OF
DECEMBER. AND FINALLY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISED- THINK KELLY CHARGE THEY
DO THAT IT WILL BEGIN.
COLLECTING DATA DATA PERTAINING
TO THE ANCESTRY OR ETHNIC ORIGIN
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN EMPLOYEES.
THE EFFORT IMPLEMENT A PORTION
OF EIGHTY SIX YOU KNOW FOR- I AM
JOINED BY MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP
PROGRAMMATIC. AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU GUYS MAY HAVE ON
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU. OKAY
GALLIO FEEL LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS. MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON CHATS ALAMO DOT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
OKAY ALL- COULD WALK DURING THAT
THE SAME ORDER I HOPE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCING THROUGH- REGARDING
THE- A COMPONENT OF THE EXTREME
HEAT PACKAGE AT THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD- AS
YOU KNOW MADAM CHAIR THIS MAKES
SENSE AN UPBEAT. NOW TEACHER TV
HIRING PAR. GRANT PRO. HAN WITH
DISMAY REVISION FOR AS AS AS FAR
THE CASE ON THE- FOR. ARE COMING
TO ON RATHER AND WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE. CONNECT WITH THE RELEASE
OF WITH THE BOARD TO LEARN
THROUGH. AS MUCH AS WE'D LIKE TO
ABOUT THIS SPECIFIC PROPOSAL SO
THERE ARE SOME OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS- FRIENDS INSIDE THE
PROPOSAL ITSELF DOESN'T CLEAR
WHAT SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES WOULD
BE. THE TARGET OF THESE H. RTP
GRANTS AND HOW THEY WOULD BE
CONNECTED TO REDUCING EXTREME
HEAT- FOR HOW THESE- PROGRAMS
WOULD MEET THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF
THOSE INDUSTRIES- SO. OFTEN AND
QUESTIONS FOR THAT PROPOSAL-
MOVING ON OUR- WOULD ONLY NOTE
THAT THE- PRINTER SHIP EXPANSION
PROPOSAL IN THE MAY REVISION
WOULD REDIRECT SOME FUNDING THAT
WAS PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROF. GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
JANUARY FOR HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP IN HEALTH AND SOCIAL
WORK FIELDS- AND SO THAT'S A
COMPONENT IS BEING REDIRECTED
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S SORT OF
JANUARY PRIORITY TO
APPRENTICESHIP. PROGRAMS IN
NONTRADITIONAL. DISTRICTS ON
MOVING ON TO THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT NEW
INFORMATION TO. PROPOSAL FEEDING
NEXT I'M AT THE SUBTREE KNOWS
ARE HE DEFACED SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES DURING THE PANDEMIC
OXER MANAGING IT'S UNPRECEDENTED
WORKLOAD- AND IT IS GOING TO
HAVE PAYMENTS- IF ON INSURANCE
AND SO AS A PART OF THAT. ROSS
SAYS DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
EXISTING- TECHNOLOGY EFFORT THAT
HAD BEEN UNDER WAY THE BENEFITS
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION WAS PAUSED
AND REIMAGINED AS EDT MAX'S WITH
THIS THE FIRST WE'RE SEEING OUT
OF THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY PROPOSAL-
IN ORDER A QUICK ASSESSMENT OF
THE PROPOSAL THERE ARE SOME
INFORMATION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT CURRENTLY IS INCLUDING
CLEANINGS ARE. ONGOING PROJECT
COSTS- ESTIMATED TOTAL PROJECT
COST SOME DETAILS ABOUT THAT THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT AS IT'S
BEEN REIMAGINE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND TECHNOLOGY- TO
GET THIS INFORMATION BUT THE
THING WE DIDN'T WANT TO FLAG FOR
JUST SUBCOMMITTEE ITSELF IS THAT
BECAUSE THIS IS A NEW.
TECHNOLOGY OFFERED EFFORT. ON
THE HEEL OF LESSONS LEARNED
DURING THE PANDEMIC NOW IS
PROBABLY THE BEST OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO GET
CLOSELY INVOLVED IN HOW THIS
TECHNOLOGY EFFORT TAKE SHAPE-
FINANCIAL BRING THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. ANSWERED
BY AN FROM FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THE PROJECT IS THERE- SO WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THE BROADER LEGISLATURE TO.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION THIS MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL AND- ASKS.
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS AND DETAILED
INFORMATIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
FROM THE DEPARTMENT. ON THE
FOLLOWING AS MY COLLEAGUES AND
REFINE MANAGER THERE IS A IS A
MAJOR REVISION AT E. D. I TWO
TWO IN. FIX STAND SOME ITS FROM
INVEST AND- BEYOND WHAT WAS IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND SHOOTING A
TWELVE NO DOLLAR PUBLIC AD
CAMPAIGN TO RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT IDENTITY THEFT I WHICH WAS
A WIDESPREAD ISSUE IN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
POTENTIALLY MORE RECENTLY IN THE
STATE'S DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM WE HAVE NO SPECIFIC
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL BUT
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OKAY I WILL LOVE
TAKING A QUESTIONS FROM OUR OUR
MEMBER- FIFTY START WHERE. WHAT
EVERYONE. ABOUT DO INDEED THREE
VERY LET'S AT THIRTY FIRST IN
THE OVERALL TO THE OTHER. SENATE
NEWMAN. I THANK YOU ENSURE. BY I
GUESS QUITE FOR MR TOP THEN OR
SOMEBODY D. D. PRECIADO. THE
ANSWER AS THE PLAY FOR LONG TERM
. BUT LOOK BACK ON RESEARCH ITS
- A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS WITH YOU
CAN IT TO ABOUT CHALLENGES IN
WITH SEARCHES. IN DEMAND- BE
WHICH WOULD EVERE DURING THE
PANDEMIC'S PLEASE JOIN LIKE SOME
. IN A LITTLE BIT AND HOW WITH
ABOUT THE WELL LOOKING FOR AND
WHETHER OR NOT THE MODERNIZATION
PLANS SPECIFICALLY CONSIDER THE
IMPERATIVE TO COPE WITH OR TO
PREPARE FOR FUTURE SURGES. IN
DEMAND OF HELPING THAT CAPACITY
TO HANDLE SURGES. THANK YOU
SENATOR OF HUNDRED THOUSAND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MINISTER
IN THE A MAJOR PART OF THE
PLANNING PROCESS AND WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THOSE ARE THE
ISSUES- THAT. WONDERFUL
CONVERSATION AND I'LL THE PERSON
DEPARTMENT FOR. ON HOW WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THOSE GOING
FORWARD. SENATOR NANCY JERRY AS
- YOU- FIRST OF ALL I JUST TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE LEDGE. I
MEAN WE HER WHAT. YOU KNOW CAL.
SAID YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT THE CSA
SAID WHAT L. A. O. SAID- WHAT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS SAID WHAT THE
PUBLIC SAID AND WE ARE HERE TO
MODERNIZE EDT- THAT IS. THAT IS
OUR GOAL GOING FORWARD- I SORT
OF STATE OF MORE POINTEDLY TO
YOUR QUESTION YOU KNOW THE BEST
PART ABOUT EDT NEXT IT IS AN I.
T. EFFORT AS AS LBO MENTION
THERE'S ALSO. A CHANGE
MANAGEMENT SIDE OF IT BUT THE
MOST. EXCITING PART OF IT I
THINK IS THAT WHERE IT'S GOING
TO BE MUCH MORE NIMBLE SO YOU
KNOW NEW PROGRAMS LIKE PULL UP
THAT CAME INTO PLACE NEW
REGULATIONS POLICY CHANGES. WE
WILL BE ABLE TO- IMPLEMENT THOSE
MUCH MORE QUICKLY SO IN TIMES
LIKE WE HAD DURING THE PANDEMIC
THAT ASPECT WAS IS REALLY KEY I
MEAN THAT WAS. PART OF THE ISSUE
TO YOUR POINT THAT YOU MENTION
IS THAT WE COULDN'T PROGRAM
THINGS SUCH AS QUICKLY AS WE
COULD AND THAT'S WE HAD YOU KNOW
THE- THE WORD BACKLOG A WE HAD
BACKLOG ON. YOU KNOW FOR A FOR A
BIT- BEFORE WE COULD ACTUALLY-
RUN THROUGH IT SO. THAT IS
REALLY GOING TO BE THE- THE
MOST- I THINK EXCITING PART
ABOUT EDP. JERRY AND I AM THREE
FIVE FRAZIER THAT SO THE- THE
CONCERN I GUESS IS THAT WE DON'T
FIND OURSELVES. IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE MODERNIZATION PROCESS AND
THEN FACING ANOTHER SEARCH SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE KIND OF NOT
LATER THAN DATE DID DID WE USE
THE LEISURE YOU CAN ASSUME. THAT
THIS WORK COULD BE DONE TO AS WE
LOOK TOWARD YOU KNOW- AS I THINK
SOMEBODY EARLIER. IN THE
PRESENTATION MENTIONED YOU YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING ONE TWO YEARS
OUT GIVEN SOME OF THE LAGGING
INDICATORS AROUND RECESSIONS WE
YOU KNOW NOT UNLIKELY WILL HAVE.
SOME LEVEL SURGE IN THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. SO THAT THE GREAT. A
THAT- HAVE SOME JAN TEN.
PROPOSALS SO WE HAVE SOME. YOU
KNOW CURRENT THEN THAT ARE. FOR
ME. THE SPORTS. THAT WE'VE USED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS-
AS WE ROLL INTO EDT NEXT YOU
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE ACCENTURE YOU
KNOW TO COMPLETE SOME OF THE CSA
RECOMMENDATIONS- YOU KNOW WHAT
WE DO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
MODERNIZE AND WE ARE CONTINUING
TO MODERNIZE. AT THE SAME TIME
WE CALL IT CARILLO MODERNIZATION
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO BE
PREPARED TO YOUR POINT. FOR
RECESSION OR SOME SORT OF-
UNEMPLOYMENT SURGE YOU KNOW IN
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
CSA AND THE STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS- PUT FORTH AND
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE VENDORS
THAT WE HAVE. THAT THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY USING THAT WE HAVE
ASKED FOR- IN JAN TEN WILL
LIKELY BE REPLACED OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS WITH EDT NEXT YEAR
WE'RE FINISHING UP SOME OF THE
CSA RECOMMENDATIONS- AT SOME
POINT THOSE THINGS WILL MERGE.
AND SO BASICALLY IN A NUTSHELL I
GUESS WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT.
THE JAN TEN PROPOSALS ARE FOR
THE HERE AND NOW. AND THEN EDT
NEXT IS THE FUTURE- AND THAT IS
A WAY THAT WE CAN- SORT OF MERGE
THAT THE TO- TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PREPARED- FOR ANY OF
RECESSION OR SURGEON
UNEMPLOYMENT. CLAIMS NOT A
PRIVILEGE FOR TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSES. MOVE THANK YOU MISTER
. GREAT LOOKING OF. BONTA WAS
GOOD BECAUSE IT- I COUPLE OF
THINGS- GOOD TO SEE DIRECTOR
FAR- THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR- ON
THE EDT NEXT WHAT DO YOU WALL
PROJECT TO BE THE- TOTAL AMOUNT.
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT THIS- ONCE
IT'S FULLY IMPLEMENTED. ARE
THERE ANY POTENTIAL CUSTOM
PRESSURES THAT YOU'RE
ANTICIPATING. SO YOU KNOW WE
PROVIDED SOME OF THIS IN SOME
WRITTEN QUESTIONS BUT I'LL JUST
START A HIGH LEVEL IT- YOU KNOW
IT'S ESTIMATED TO BE ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
AND ONE TIME COSTS WHICH IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ROADMAP-
THAT YOU DON'T THINK THE LATE
LAST YEAR- THE LEGISLATURE-
PROVIDED- TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR US TO- BUT- CREATE THE
ROADMAP WITH KPMG OVER THE FIVE
YEAR PERIOD. AND THEN THE OTHER
COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
TO SUPPORT EDT AND TO SUPPORT
THE NEW PROJECTS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS IS AROUND THREE
HUNDRED MILLION- SO DOES THAT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION AS FAR AS
THE POTENTIAL COST PRESSURES I
MEAN PART OF THE INVESTMENTS- AS
I MENTIONED LAST YEAR WAS THAT
THE TWELVE MILLION YOU KNOW.
BASICALLY TO RELY ON EXPERTS
WHICH WE DID KPMG I'M TO PUT
TOGETHER THE ROAD MAP FOR THE
PROJECT WHICH OF COURSE INCLUDED
COSTING- IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE COSTS WERE ESTIMATED TO
BE ON THE CONSERVATIVE SIDE THEY
ERRED ON THE SIDE OF CAUTION-
AND KNOWING BECAUSE THE PROJECT
EATING NEXT PROJECT IS GOING TO
BE A PHASE PROCESS WE HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY- THEN IF THE PROJECT
WAS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL AND HERE
IT IS IN FIVE YEARS AND IT'S
DONE THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
INTERPRETIVE PROCESS- SO WE'LL
BE ABLE TO MONITOR EACH OF THE-
PROJECTS GOING FORWARD AND OF
COURSE. YOU KNOW WE'RE ALWAYS
GONNA RELY ON STATE STAFF TO THE
FULLEST EXTENT POSSIBLE- AND TRY
TO CUT COSTS THAT WAY. GREAT
COUPLE MORE OF COURSE. IS. GIVE
ME AN IDEA OF WHAT YOU ENVISION
IS GOING TO CHANGE FOR THE USERS
. WELL IT IS IT DOES IT MEAN TO
THEM YEAH I MEAN THAT THAT
REALLY IS A GREAT QUESTION AND I
WILL STAY YOU KNOW IT'S A FIVE
YEAR PROJECT SO I WILL FOCUS ON
YOU KNOW THE FIRST YEAR- WE HAVE
LOTS OF MILESTONES BUT SOME OF
THE ONES THAT I KNOW ARE NEAR
AND DEAR TO MY HEART AND I THINK
YOU'RE AS WELL AS- FORMS
REDESIGN YOU KNOW THAT IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FROM CLAIMANTS IN
CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
GENERAL CALIFORNIANS GENERALLY-
THE CALL CENTER IMPROVEMENTS I
MEAN THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE-
ARE WORKING ON NOW- BUT YOU KNOW
WE ARE THAT IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA
DEFINITELY ROLLING DDT NEXT-
JUST MAKING IT EASIER MAKING IT
SO- PEOPLE RELY LESS ON THE CALL
CENTER STILL BE ONLINE FOR
LINKING INSTANCE THAT WE'RE
DOING. SO IT'S SORT OF A ONE
STOP SHOP FOR PEOPLE OF
REGARDLESS OF WHICH- PROGRAM
THEIR BENEFITS THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE TRAINING STAFF ALONG
THE WAY- BUT WITH THE WITH ALL
THAT BEING SAID- LANGUAGE ACCESS
IS STILL A HUGE. DEAL FOR ME-
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON SINCE I STARTED
AT EDS I THINK MOST OF YOU KNOW-
AND THAT IS ALSO GOING TO- WE
ARE EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE DOING
FOR CLAIMANTS WE ARE DOING FOR
EVERYONE TO MEET EVERYONE SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS REGARDLESS OF.
LANGUAGE OR DISABILITY- TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS OUR BENEFITS AND-
I THINK THAT'S THAT IS LIKE OUR
FIRST YEAR GOAL IT'S A BIG GOAL
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEDICATED PEOPLE HERE EDT THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
HAPPENS. OKAY AND I'M SORRY IF
THIS ALREADY- I'M SURE THIS
ALREADY EXISTS BUT TO PROVIDE US
YOUR MENTION OF- MILESTONES AND
METRICS- I THINK YOU'D BE REALLY
GOOD FOR THE LEGISLATURE- A-
MAYBE YOU'VE- WE'VE ALL. AGREED
THIS A TO THIS BUT IT WOULD BE
REALLY GOOD FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO KNOW THIS IS WHAT WE CAN
EXPECT THE FIRST YEAR THE SECOND
YEAR. AND BY THE END OF THE OF
THE FIVE YEARS- BECAUSE I THINK
OTHERWISE WE HAVE A SENSE OF.
THINGS WORSE. WERE WRONG AND-
WHEN AND HOW WE GONNA GET
THROUGH THEM AND- I THINK IS
STILL ON EVERYBODY'S MINDS. AND
SENATOR JUST TO NOT POINT OUT
YOU CAN ASK BUT I'M GONNA SAY IT
BECAUSE THIS IS A REALLY
EXCITING PROJECT BUT- TO THAT
POINT YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL- PROJECT RIGHT SO
THIS THIS IS GOINGTO BE. AGAIN
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS GOING TO BE A PART OF EVERY
YEAR BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE TO
COME BACK TO YOU- YOU WILL SEE
MIGHT BREAK SHINING FACE FOR THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. YOU KNOW TO- TO
REALLY TALK ABOUT WHAT WE'VE
DONE THE FOR THE PREVIOUS YEAR
AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
NEXT YEAR AND THAT WILL BE YOU
KNOW A DECISION THAT WILL BE
MADE WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON TO
FUND THOSE PROJECTS. GREAT THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT- WITH
REGARDS TO- THE FRAUD AND
IDENTITY THEFT AWARENESS- I WAS
SACKED. CONCERNED ABOUT THE E.
D. D.'S ROLE IN FUNDING DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS OFFICES- ARE YOU
CURRENTLY OF PROVIDING OF
FUNDING OF ON THE PROSECUTION OF
CRIMINAL FRAUD CASES I DIDN'T
EXPECT THIS TO COME UP UNDER ET
DE. SO IT IS ACTUALLY A
PARTNERSHIP- WITH- WITH- YES- WE
DID IT SO EDT DOESN'T DIRECTLY
FUNDS- THE DA'S IT ACTUALLY IS
AN INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT THAT
WE HAVE WITH A WE ASK THIS WAS
BACK- IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
BELIEVE WHEN THE GOVERNOR
CREATED- YES HOUSE FORCE. AND
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WAS-
BASICALLY GIVEN TO- YES AGAIN WE
JUST IN CONJUNCTION WITH YOU
NEED TO SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATIONS AND PROSECUTION
PROSECUTIONS- SO IT'S NOT
REALLY- IT DOESN'T COME DIRECTLY
FROM EDT THEY HAVE TO APPLY- FOR
THE GRANTS OR THE- FOR THE
MONEY. THROUGH THE- YES TASK
FORCE AND THEREFORE- D. A.'S
THAT SIT ON THE TASK FORCE THEIR
REGIONAL THE AS AND SO ALL
THEIR- ALL THE REGIONAL D. A.'S
UNDER THAT UNDER THE- FOR
REGIONAL DJS. CAN APPLY- FOR-
MONEY FOR REIMBURSEMENT FOR
CRIMINAL CASES THAT THEY'RE
WORKING ON FOR ANY CASES THAT
THEY'RE WORKING ON. OKAY IS THIS
. MAYBE JUST- THE SEATTLE BIT
MORE TO THAT AND OF WHY AND
WHERE WHERE IS THAT. I
UNDERSTAND THE BASIC CONNECTION
RIGHT TRYING TO GET TO- WE'RE
TRYING TO GET TO THESE CASES
SINCE ALL THESE CASES AND I
UNDERSTAND WORKING TOGETHER BUT-
IT'S IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IT'S
MORE IT WOULD BE MORE WITH TASK
FORCE TYPE OF THING RATHER THAN
A DIRECT FUNDING SO MAYBE I'M
NOT QUITE UNDERSTANDING. SO THE
WAY THAT IT WORKS NOW- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IS IT'S RIEM IT'S
A REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM SO THE
FUNDING- YOU KNOW THERE'S- THERE
WAS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ORIGINALLY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT ADDS
THAT AS- EDT IN OUR FRAUD-
SPECIAL COUNSEL- LONG AND I DO
MEAN THOMSON REUTERS AND
ACCENTURE THEY PUT TOGETHER-
DATA AND INFORMATION AND THEN
THAT GETS DISPERSED U. F. B. I.
THEY ARE WORKING ON THESE CASES
THEY GET REIMBURSED AND I THINK
THAT THINKING IS THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATHER THAN JUST
THE GRANT IS THAT SO WE CAN KEEP
TRACK OF WHO IS WORKING ON WHAT.
AND HOW MUCH IT'S COSTING AND-
RATHER THAN JUST. YOU KNOW
GIVING OUT MONEY LIKE YOU KNOW A
MILLION HERE A MILLION HERE- AND
NOT KNOWING EXACTLY WHAT IT'S
GOING FOR I GUESS I ASSUME IT'S
A WAY FOR US TO KEEP TRACK. OKAY
GOT IT ALL RIGHT- AND- JUST
MOVING ON TO. THE OTHER LABOR
ISSUES- UNDER- THE EXTREME HEAT
PROPOSALS. OF THE A. R. AND C.
W. D. B- THE METRICS ON THE
MILESTONES OF FOR THE PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT YOU PLAN TO
IMPACT BY THESE PROPOSALS. COULD
EXPLAIN THAT A BIT MORE.
FRIEDMAN CHAIR PATRICK TOPPING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I AM GOING
TO TREAT THE QUESTION OVER TO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR PAYING AT THE I.
R. OR NEED METRIC ABOUT THAT
AND- AT THE HOUR. OKAY THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING YOU HAVE A PEN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS SO ON
METRICS AND MILESTONES. ARE
USING THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
I CAL OSHA ENFORCEMENT. WILL
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT ENHANCED
REVIEW PROCESS AND TRACKING
SYSTEMS TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND COMPOUNDED
IMPACTS FROM THE STRATEGIC
ENFORCEMENT TARGET OUTREACH
RELATED TO HEAT ILLNESS
PREVENTION WHAT OUR SMOKE
PROTECTION. SAID EXPECTED
TRAINING COORDINATE INSPECTORS
TO PERFORMANCE TARGETED
INSPECTIONS BEFORE AND DURING
HIGH RISK- I RISK FOR WORKERS
COUPLED WITH OUR REACH
ACTIVITIES TO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS AND
INFORMATION TO VULNERABLE
WORKERS IN TERMS OF METRICS
POLLUTION FORSMAN EXPECTS TO
INCREASE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
WORKPLACE INSPECTION BY A
HUNDRED FIFTY INSPECTIONS
ANNUALLY. AND THOSE ARE
PROACTIVE TARGETED DIRECTLY AT
HEAT ILLNESS PREVENTION WILDFIRE
SMOKE PROTECTION. AN ARMY OUR
REACH SIDE AFTER HIRING THE
ADDITIONAL STAFF HELLO CHAU
PLANS TO PARTICIPATE AT LEAST
THIRTY OUTREACH EVENTS AND EACH
YEAR WHICH WILL INCLUDE HIGHER
RISK VULNERABLE WORKERS
ORGANIZED BY WORKER AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
LABOR UNIONS AND CONSULATES. AND
EXPECTS TO PROVIDE OUR REGION
TRAIN TO AT LEAST SIX HUNDRED
WORKERS DIRECTLY ANNUALLY HOW
THE METS INCREASED AWARENESS OF
WORKPLACE SAFETY AND HEALTH
HAZARDS. RIGHT HOW TO EXERCISE
THOSE RIGHTS IN ADDITION TO
DEVELOPING MORE PUBLICATIONS AND
TRAINING VIDEOS AND ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGES AND ALSO ACCESSIBLE
FOR DIFFERENCE- LITERACY LEVELS
AS WELL. OKAY THANK YOU AND- THE
LAST ONE IS WITH REGARDS TO THE
APPRENTICESHIP- UP PROGRAM- IF
YOU COULD EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE ON
NONTRADITIONAL. PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS THAT YOUR VISIONING-
AND- A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHO YOU
WILL TARGET AS FAR AS BEING THE
APPRENTICES WHICH COMMUNITIES.
HI THERE- I AM A DAHLE BURNS THE
DEPUTY CHIEF OF THE DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS AND
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE AND I'M
HAPPY TO. SHARE A BIT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHO WE HOPE TO
TARGET WITH THIS INVESTMENT SO
THE IDEA OF THE PREP OF THE
APPRENTICESHIP INNOVATION
FUNDING IS TO HELP. NEW ALKA
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO SCALE
AND TO SERVE MORE EMPLOYERS AND
MORE APPRENTICES AND ULTIMATELY
TO ADVANCE MORE QUICKLY TOWARDS
THE GOAL OF SERVING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND APPRENTICES BY TWENTY
TWENTY NINE SO. I'M JUST TO GIVE
A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT WHEN
LAUNCHING AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM IT REQUIRES BRINGING A
LOT OF DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS TO
THE TABLE AND YOU REALLY NEED A
CONVENING FORCE TO BRING THEM
STAKEHOLDERS TO GATHER SOME OF.
THE STAKEHOLDERS OF COURSE
INCLUDE EMPLOYERS AND EDUCATORS
AND APPRENTICES- AND SOMETIMES
ALSO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARDS OR OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY ALL NEED
TO BE BROUGHT TOGETHER IN ORDER
TO. DESIGN REGISTER AND LAUNCH
AN APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND- I
MEAN ROLE. WE AND APPRENTICESHIP
. AND REALLY THIS FUNDING IS
TRYING TO IN. IN CREATING EAGLE
OF APPRENTICESHIP INTERMEDIARIES
AND ON THAT CA SEASIDE. WHICH IS
THAT I'M BUILDING AND FIRE
TRADES APPRENTICESHIPS IT'S
OFTEN THE UNION THAT PLAYS THIS
ROLE- HOWEVER ON THE
NONTRADITIONAL APPROACH TO
SHIFT. THIS CONVENING ROLE CAN
LOOK A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS I'M
IT CAN BE A UNION STILL ARM IT
COULD ALSO BE A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION A
NONPROFIT OR EVEN A FOR PROFIT
ENTITY LIKE A STAFFING FIRM OR
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. SO WITH
THIS APPRENTICESHIP INNOVATION
FUNDING WE WANT TO BE CREATING A
MORE SUSTAINABLE. AND HOPEFULLY
WE WANT TO BE CREATING A WHOLE
ECOSYSTEM OF THESE
APPRENTICESHIP INTERMEDIARIES
SUCH JUST TO. GIVE YOU A FEW
MORE SORT OF SECTOR AND CONCRETE
EXAMPLES- AS YOU LIKELY KNOW ACT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IS
REFERRING TO ALL SECTORS THAT
ARE. NOT THE BUILDING ON FIRE
TRADE SO THAT INCLUDES
HEALTHCARE. EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION TECHNOLOGY CYBER
SECURITY PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
PUBLIC SECTOR TRANSPORTATION I
COULD GO ON. BUT BASICALLY IT'S
EVERY SECTOR THAT'S NOT THE
BUILDING EMPIRE TRADES- AND- SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF NASCENT
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT IN
THESE DIFFERENT SECTORS SO. TO
GIVE A FEW EXAMPLES- LAUNCHES AN
APPRENTICESHIP NETWORK IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. AND THEY HAVE
OCCUPATIONS IN THE AUTOMOTIVE
HEALTHCARE I. T. ADVANCED
MANUFACTURIG AND SUPPLY CHAIN
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION SO
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF A- REGIONAL
APPRENTICESHIP INTERMEDIARY-
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND THE SEIU LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND HAVE PARTNERED TO
PUT TOGETHER A LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSE TO REGISTERED
NURSE. PROGRAM BUT COULD BE A
POTENTIAL RECIPIENTS OF THIS
FUNDING- OUR PROGRAM IS AMAZING
IT HAS 75% WOMEN IN 80%
MINORITIES AND- LEADS TO A
HUNDRED AND 35% INCREASE IN
WAGES OVER THE COURSE OF THE
APPRENTICESHIP SO- PRETTY COOL.
PROGRAM OTHER EXAMPLES- WISE
INDUSTRIES HAS A I'M OUT OF
FRESNO ACTUALLY HAS AN
APPLICATION DEVELOPER
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM- ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS SAM FOURTEEN
COUNTIES- HIGH SCHOOL
APPRENTICESHIPS. WHICH IS A POOR
EXAMPLE OF A NEW TYPE OF USE
APPRENTICESHIP- THEY HAVE A
TECHNOLOGY. SUPPORT SPECIAL.
PROGRAM THAT. FINALLY IN A
TOTALLY DAY SEX- THE FARM HAS AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM FOR FARM
AND RANCH MANAGERS SO THIS JUST
GIVES YOU SOME IDEAS SOME
CONCRETE EXAMPLES OF WHO WOULD
BE POTENTIAL RECIPIENTS OF THIS
FUNDING THERE ARE ALREADY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
FUNDING BUT THE MEAN NUMBER OF
APPRENTICES IMAMS IS TWELVE.
WHICH BUT THAT SHOULD TELL YOU
IS THAT WOULD BE ILLUSTRATED
PROOF OF CONCEPT BUT WE REALLY
NEED FUNDING TO HELP THESE
PROGRAMS FAIL AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE REALLY HEARD FROM THESE
PROGRAMS IS THAT HAVING ON GOING
FUNDING TO RUN THESE PROGRAMS
AND SOMETIMES TO COVER THE
TRAINING CLASS IS A REAL CHEAP
BARRIER TO SCALING- AND THIS
FUNDING IS ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT.
CHALLENGE GREAT OKAY WELL- YOU
DIDN'T MENTION SPECIFICALLY BUT
WOMEN AND YOUTH- I SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE A PART OF THE-
NONTRADITIONAL SIDE OF WHO GETS
TARGETED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
APPRENTICES OF FRIENDSHIPS EVEN
WITHIN THE- BUILDING AND FIRE
TREATS. SO NONTRADITIONAL IS
BOTH THE WORK ON THE CAREER AS
WELL AS THE COMMUNITY FROM WHICH
WE ARE LOOKING TO RECRUIT- SO WE
HAVE ALL OVER SEVERAL YEARS FOR
WORKING REALLY HARD TO DEVELOP
THE HIGH ROAD PARTNERSHIPS. HI
ROAD STANDARDS- BECAUSE WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO A CAREER THAT PAYS
MORE NOT GET STUCK ON ENOUGH
ENTRY LEVEL. AND THEN THAT
BECOMES THE JOB THAT YOU GO TO
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN SO
THAT THIS REALLY ENDS UP AS A
CAREER IS OF A BIG CONCERN. TO
ME I THINK TO MY COLLEAGUES IS
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING PROPOSALS AND THE
FUNDING THAT'S GIVEN OUT TO
WHEREVER HIS FOR PROFIT.
NONPROFIT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE- AT THEIR MEETING A HIGHER
STANDARD OFF I'VE BEEN AROUND
MANY YEARS WERE ICY AW EMPLOYERS
TAKE THE FUNDING- AND THEN JUST
GIVE SOMEBODY A JOB FOR SIX
MONTHS OR NINE MONTHS- AND
THAT'S IT. AND THAT'S CONSIDERED
TRAINING- HOW DO YOU MAINTAIN A
REAL HIGH ROAD- AND IT JUST IT
BECAUSE IT WAS NOT INCLUDED HERE
SPECIFICALLY IS THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY SCHOOL MEALS PATHWAY
PROGRAM. WHAT IS THE STANDARD
THAT YOU USING JUST USING AS
THAT AS AN EXAMPLE LISTED HERE
HOW ARE YOU MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S REALLY LIVING UP TO THIS
HIGH ROAD STANDARD. BOTH IN
CONTENT OF TRAINING- I DON'T
WANT TO YOU THE TERM IMPROPER
PRACTICE TO BECOME SO LOOSELY
USED THAT ANYBODY COULD SAY WELL
HIRED AN APPRENTICE AND THE
PRINCE IS BEEN THERE FOR SIX
MONTHS AND THEN THEY- FINISH THE
JOB AND THEY GO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WE REALLY WANT THIS TO BE
MEANINGFUL AS FAR AS REBUILDING.
A BIGGER METAL CLASS IN THIS
STATE SO WITH THAT- MS BURNS.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR A REASON ALL
THOSE POINTS I THINK THEY'RE ALL
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND I WILL
SAY THAT SO. THE DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS WHAT
WHAT WE DO IS TO OVERSEE THE
QUALITY OF PROGRAMS AND SO WE
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
AS THERE IS THIS APPRENTICESHIP
MOVEMENTS REALLY HAPPENING
NATIONALLY THAT WE ARE MAKING
SURE THAT WERE CREATING QUALITY
PROGRAMS LIKE YOU TALKED ABOUT
AND- AS YOU KNOW AN
APPRENTICESHIP AND HUSTLER TWO
FUNDAMENTAL COMPONENTS IT HAS
THE ON THE JOB LEARNING WHICH IS
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND HOURS OF ON
THE JOB TIMES ABOUT A YEAR.
COMPLEMENTED BY. FORTY FOUR
HOURS RELATED AND SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION RIGHT WHICH IS THE
EDUCATION COMPONENT OF THAT EARN
AND LEARN. RIGHT AND REALLY I
MEAN BY CREATING THIS PATHWAY
INTO A CAREER. IT IS YOU KNOW
IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY CREATING A
MORE EQUITABLE AND ACCESSIBLE ON
RAMP. INTO A CAREER AND WE HAD
DIAZ IS CERTAINLY CHAIR A LOT
ABOUT QUALITY OF. AND AS WE
REQUESTED FUNDING TO BE
INVESTING IN CREATING NEW
PROGRAMS ACROSS ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT SECTORS THAT I ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT. WE WANT TO BE
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE CREATING
PROGRAMS THAT CREATE THAT
ACCESSIBLE ON RAMP. TO WOMEN
MINORITIES FOLKS JUSTICE
INVOLVED PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OTHERS BUT
BASS. REALLY DEGREE BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT AND SO. IN I MEAN
THIS IS WHY I DO THIS WORK I'M
REALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT CREATING
THIS DIFFERENT ON RAMP INTO A
CAREER. AND I THINK I. DS WE'RE
REALLY WELL POSITIONED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE CREATING QUALITY
PROGRAMS AND PART OF THAT IS
CERTAINLY IN. SO HOW WE
STRATEGICALLY INVEST OUR TIME
AND ENERGY IN DEVELOPING
PROGRAMS I MEAN I GAVE YOU A FEW
EXAMPLES OF PROGRAMS- AND- WE
WANT TO BE FOCUSING IN AREAS
LIKE HEALTHCARE AND PUBLIC
SECTOR AND EDUCATION. WHERE WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE-
HISTORICALLY MORE WOMEN THAN
PEOPLE. OPEN WE'D BE USING THE
APPRENTICESHIP MECHANISM TO
PROCREATE ON RAMPS BUT ALSO
UPSKILLING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EXAMPLE THAT PROGRAM I WAS
TELLING YOU ABOUT WITH THE L. B.
AND ARE IN PROGRAM- THAT'S AN
UPSKILLING OPPORTUNITIES SO IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT THE ENTRY LEVEL
IT'S ALSO SOMETIMES ABOUT.
CREATING MOUTHWATERING WITHIN- A
CAREER SO I THINK. THAT'S
SOMETHING TAT WE'RE DEFINITELY
MINDFUL OF AND JUST FINALLY TO
COMMENT. ON THAT POPULATIONS
THAT WE WANT TO BE HE'S- WERE
ALL OVER DOING A LOT OF. AROUND
THE I DON'T REACH COME AND WE'RE
MAKING SURE THAT CREATING IS
PASS FOR THE FOLKS. WE WANT TO
BE SERVING THROUGH
APPRENTICESHIP- FOR EXAMPLE
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION TO
ELEVATE A PARTNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES WITH THE FOLKS
THAT THEY'RE SERVING- ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS LAST YEAR. SHOT D. A.
S. RECEIVED A GRANT FROM A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT FROM DEAL
WELL. AND HOW WE CHOSE TO DEPLOY
THAT EQUITABLE APPRENTICESHIP
BRANDS WAS TO. CREATE A
SOLICITATION FOR PROPOSALS TO
ENCOURAGE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARDS AND THESE APPRENTICESHIP
INTERMEDIARIES TO WORK TOGETHER
WE JUST ANNOUNCED ON MAY FOURTH
THE RECIPIENT ABOUT SO- WERE
LOOKING FORWARD TO MAKING SURE
THAT. THOSE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS ARE ALSO
INCLUDED IN THIS MIX OF NEW
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS SO THAT
WE'RE SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING IS
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE. TO
THOSE FOLKS THAT REALLY THINK
WILL BENEFIT MOST FROM THIS
APPRENTICESHIP PATHWAY. I'M
SORRY IN JUST THE FINAL-
QUESTION ON THIS IS HOW DO YOU-
HOW ARE YOU MAKING SURE THAT-
THESE RAMPS APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF. OF HIGH ROAD
STANDARDS. YEAH I WAS THE BEARS-
THERE'S FEW DIFFERENT WAYS I
THINK I WOULD LOVE TO COME BACK
TO YOU A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE SOME
ABOUT WILL COME INTO THE
IMPLEMENTATION LIKE THE DETAIL
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FUNDS
BUT I THINK ARE REALLY KEY
COMPONENT OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
FUNDING LANDSCAPE FOR
FRIENDSHIPS IS THAT THERE'S
START UP FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS
AND THEN THERE'S- ON GOING
FUNDING AND THERE'S REALLY BEEN
A LACK OF THAT THE ON GOING
FUNDING TO HELP PROGRAM SCALE.
AND ONE WAY TO STRATEGICALLY
INVEST IN THESE HIGH ROAD IS IN
THE START UP GRANTS WHICH IS
WHAT YOU'RE DOING WHEN YOU
INVEST IN THAT THE HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNER THOSE ARE OFTEN
START UP GRANTS THAT GET
PROGRAMS GOING AND THEN THE IDEA
IS THAT THIS A PARTNERSHIP
INNOVATION FUNDING CAN HELP TO
TAKE THOSE PROGRAMS AND HELP
SCALE THEM. SO IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S A VIRTUOUS PARTNERSHIP HERE
IN TERMS OF THE FUNDING
MECHANISMS THAT WE'RE CREATING-
AND SO AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU MORE ON THE
MECHANICS OF. HOW WE DEPLOY THE
F. FUNDING SURE THAT WE HAVE
THOSE PRINCIPLES IN MIND. OKAY
THAT- THING NEWMAN GEORGIA JUST
WANT TO SAY ONE OF CAN MS BURNS
SHOULD FOR YOUR- VERY CLEAR BUT
ENTHUSIASTIC- SORT OF OVERVIEW
AND SERVE DID IS CONTAGIOUS LIKE
I SHARE YOUR ENTHUSIASM- THE YOU
KNOW THIS IS ONLY AN ISSUE
CONCEPT I THINK IT'S AN AWESOME.
OPPORTUNITY FOR MAKING SMART
INVESTMENTS- KIND OF THE HIGH
HIGH ROAD OPPORTUNITIES AS THE
CHEERS MATCHES SO TO YOUR POINT
IMAGE IT'S REALLY ABOUT AT THE
END TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO SCALE
THE STATION AND THE KEY. IS
SCALING IS SOME COMBINATION OF
ALIGNMENT YOU KNOW LINE OF
EFFORT STRETCH ACROSS ALL THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARDS
ACROSS THE STATE- BUT ALSO SOME
CLARITY ON STANDARDS- SO THAT
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE- YOU KNOW
PERSPECTIVE WORKERS HAVE THE
ASSURANCE THAT AS THEY PURSUE A
PARTICULAR PATH THAT THEY'RE
GETTING INTO A CAREER THAT HAS.
YOU KNOW TRUE CAREER TO THE
PROGRESS OPPORTUNITIES SO I WILL
I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND WITH OTHERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE GIVE
YOU THE- KIND OF SUPPORT AND
INPUT THAT HELPS YOU MOVE
FORWARD THANKS. SIR TENZING.
YOUR WANTED. YOU KNOW I WANNA
SUPPORT THE DISCUSSION
CONVERSATION BUT BUT ALSO BY
SAYING- YOU KNOW I DO THINK THE
NONTRADITIONAL- FINANCING
MECHANISMS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
CAN BE REALLY USEFUL IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA THEY DON'T WORK
EVERYWHERE BUT- YOU KNOW I KNOW.
BACK INTO THE CAR COUNTY FEW
YEARS AGO WE WERE APPROACH TO DO
SOMETHING PEOPLE MORE THAN
CALLING SOCIAL IMPACT BONDS
WHICH REALLY AREN'T BONDS AT ALL
BUT THEY'RE BASICALLY-
MECHANISMS TO GET PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR DOLLARS AND
SOMETIMES PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS-
PAID OUT. FOR PROGRAMS LIKE
HOUSING THE IN HOUSE TOWARDS
CERTAIN MENTAL HEALTH
POPULATIONS WITH APPRENTICESHIP
. THEORETICALLY HOW THAT WOULD
WORK IS THAT IT HAS TO BE A
PRINCE'S RECEIPT- WERE RETAINED
AND- IN RESEARCH BENCHMARKS THAT
THE DOORS WOULD BE ROLLED OUT
ALMOST LIKE IF YOU WERE PAYING
OUT A CONSTRUCTION LOAN YOU PAY
FOR THE FOUNDATION THEN YOU PAY
FOR. THE PLUMBING AND THEN YOU
PAY FOR THE ROOF TO PUT ON- HERE
AND- FIND I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S
WHERE THIS DISCUSSION WAS GOING
BUT- YOU KNOW IT. IT WOULD BE AN
EXCELLENT WAY MADAM CHAIR TO
START TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
THAT YOU ARTICULATED SO WELL
WHICH IS YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE
TO JUST GO OUT AND TRY AND THEN
COME BACK AFTER NINETY DAYS OR
HUNDRED OR YEAR OR WORSE THREE
YEARS AND SAY WE TRIED REALLY
HARD. OF FOR TWO YEARS BUT WE
DIDN'T PUT MUCH OF A DENT IN THE
PROBLEM. AS OPPOSED TO THIS YOU
KNOW IT'S ALMOST A PRIVATE
SECTOR MODEL BUT IT WORKS YOU
KNOW TO SAY- WE WANT TO PAY- FOR
SUCCESS WE WANT TO PAY AS WE
SEE- SUCCESS IN IN THAT'S NOT
MERIT PAY THAT'S A COMPLETE
EVERYTHING THIS IS WHERE. YOU
KNOW PEOPLE- ESSENTIALLY GET THE
DRAW DOWN ON FUNDS AS IS
DEMONSTRATED- YOU KNOW
BENCHMARKS IN RETENTION SO-
YOU'LL PLEASE GO TO THE CURRENT
OF IDEAS PARTICULARY THE-
CONSIDERING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU- EVERYONE- THANK
YOU MS BURNS PRE SHADED ARE
MOVING ON TO ISSUE TOO THIS IS
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNORS MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT AND
THIS WILL GIVE A PRESENTATION
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MORNING AFTER TEN PLUS
DEPARTMENT FINANCED RECOVERING
THE VARIOUS ITEMS AN ISSUE
ANYWAY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM OF.
THE MEMBERS INCLUDES EIGHT POINT
TWO MILLION THIS IS BROKEN DOWN
WITH FOUR POINT SIX POINT
GENERAL FUND THAT INCLUDES SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION
GENERAL SIGNS OF CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY RETIREMENT
COSTS. AND DISCOVER THE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED ANNUAL
STATE CONTRIBUTION TO CALPERS
FOR THE STATE PENSION COSTS THE
DECREASE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY POINT
ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND
SENSITIVE FIRST BUDGET. AND AS A
RESULT ADJUSTMENTS TO RETIREMENT
RATES WHICH WERE APPROVED. BY
THE CALPERS BOARD. IN APRIL. A
REVISION ALSO REFLECTS THE BUNCH
BILLION IN CONSTITUTIONAL
PROPOSITIONS DEBT REPAYMENT
FUNDING THIS INCLUDES TWO POINT
NINE PLAN TO FURTHER REDUCE THE
STATE'S CALPERS UNFUNDED
LIABILITY AS WELL AS THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION FOR
THE GENERAL FUND PORTION OF THE
STATE EMPLOYER SENDS ANOTHER
CUSTOMER PLAN PROFESSOR VOEPEL.
THE SURPLUS MY INVESTMENT ON.
ONE REAP OF A HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
MILLION IS ALSO INCLUDED IN THE
TOTAL PROPOSITION TWO AMOUNTS.
THIS IS AN INCREASE OF EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. BEYOND TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. STATE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CUSTOMERS
INCREASED BY SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. RELATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR A TOTAL OF
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
CONTRIBUTIONS. THIS IS YOUR TO
REVISION AND REPORT RESULTS
STATION FOR K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TEACHERS. AND
FINALLY FRANKLY COMPENSATION.
THE MAYOR VISION INCREASES
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION BY TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
MILLION ON GOING OR SEVENTY
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
. THE INCREASE REFLECTS UPDATED
ESTIMATES FOR HEALTH AND DENTAL
PREMIUMS A PREVIOUSLY COLLECTED.
PREVIOUSLY COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED SALARY INCREASES AND
HOMEWORK STIPENDS AS WELL AS
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE FOR
COMMAND AND RETENTION
DIFFERENTIALS. MIRAGEN ALSO
REFLECTS A DECREASE OF THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWO TO
THREE A RETIREE HEALTH AND
DENTAL BENEFITS PERFECT
REFLECTING LOWER THAN EXPECTED
RETIREMENTS AND UPDATED
ENROLLMENT INFORMATION.
pNEGOTIATIONS AND SIX FARMING
UNITS REPRESENTING ATTORNEYS AND
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES.
FIREFIGHTERS ENGINEERS
SCIENTISTS STATIONARY ENGINEERS
THAN PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS
CONTRACTS OR SENT LETTERS
REMAINS PARKS BUYERS FORMAL
EXPIRE IN SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. WITH REMARKS AND I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES WHO CAN TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE. ON YEAH
I KNOW I'VE GOT GREAT QUESTION
WITH RESPECT TO OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING- SHOW BUT MY MISSION
IS THE MISTRESS CURLY NEGOTIATES
WITH WITH MULTIPLE BARGAINING
UNITS- TO INCLUDE THAT LAW
JUDGES FIREFIGHTERS AS YEARS
SCIENTISTS A SITE TO ACTION
OTHERS. WHOSE CONTRACTOR SIDE
LETTER AGREEMENTS ARE ARE AS
BECAUSE NOTED COUNTY SPARK
THERE'S BEEN A BUNCH OF
DISCUSSION RECENTLY ON ON
RETENTION STIPENDS. FOR WORKERS-
AND SO MY QUESTION IS FOR YOUR
WE INCLUDING THOSE WORKERS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR THE SAME CAUSE
RETENTION STUDY BEEN SORT OF
BEEN DISCUSSED- I GUESS I READ
THE NEWS RECENTLY AS RICH AS IT
RELATES TO THE REVISED. THE
QUESTION TWO OF MY COLLEAGUE AND
FRIEND. YES THE THERE ARE
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON WITH UNIONS
ABOUT- FOR CRIMINAL RETENTION
PAY DIFFERENTIALS FOR STATE
EMPLOYEE HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
THAT IS GOOD TO HEAR SO DIED I
WOULD URGE YOU TO KEEP THAT IN
MIND- THERE IS DESERVING IS
ANYBODY FOR THEIR WORK DURING
THE PANDEMIC. THANKS GREAT THANK
YOU CENTER CIRCUIT AS ANYTHING
ELSE OKAY BOB WE'VE COME TO THE
END. OF OUR ISSUES- WILL HOLD
THIS PROPOSAL AS OTHERS OPENED
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT- WERE NUMBER ONE TO
ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. 844-291-6364
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE FOUR ZERO- DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY. AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS- WE MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS TODAY I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT EACH MEMBER
KEEP THEIR REMARKS WITHIN ONE
MINUTE AND I CAN SEE EVERYBODY
LINE ENOUGH GREAT- SO LET'S
BEGIN FIRST WITH THE- OF FOLKS
WHO BEEN HERE FOR SEVERAL HOURS-
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
PATIENCE. LET'S BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. OF AND AGAIN PLEASE STATE.
YOUR NAME OUT IF YOU ARE FREELY
WITH AN ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
COMMENTS AND IDENTIFY THE ISSUE
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN- GEORGE OSBORNE-
REPRESENTING THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS IN DENNIS-
SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR CORTESE
GOOD MORNING. EACH OF THE
DOCTORS PLEASE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES IT IS AN- BECAUSE OF
TIME CONSTRAINTS RATHER THAN
HAVING ME CONDUCT ALL THE-
INTRODUCTIONS- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR DOUG CHIU PETA AND
UNION PRESIDENT STORED BY SEA I
HAD TO LEAVE THEY HAVE ANOTHER
BUDGET MEETING- WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY OF COURSE IS
THE- EMERGENCY THAT EXISTS. IN
THE NCDC ARE HAVING TO DO WITH
PSYCHIATRIST IN THE HUGE
VACANCIES THAT EXIST- THAT
PARTICULAR. JOB CLASSIFICATION
HAS ON A PERCENTAGE LEVEL MORE
VACANCIES THAN ANY OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEE CLASSIFICATION PERIOD-
THIS IS BY THE WAY A MENTAL
AWARENESS MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH- AND YOU SHOULD
BE AWARE THAT. THESE DOCTORS
NEED YOUR HELP. WHATEVER YOUR
DEFINITION OF EMERGENCY IS- THIS
WOULD CERTAINLY RISE TO THAT
LEVEL. OF THESE DOCTORS HAVE
TAKEN TIME OFF FROM THEIR FROM
THEIR- WORK PERSONAL TIME OFF IN
ORDER TO BE HERE- I PRESENTED TO
YOU A LETTER- SIGNED BY. SEVERAL
SENATORS INCLUDING SENATOR
NEWMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
FROM- SENATOR HERTZBERG- WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT THE- LEGISLATURE
STEP IN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS NOT TO TRY TO AUGMENT. THE
PSYCHIATRIC SELLERS SALARIES
BOTH FOR RECRUITMENT AND FOR
RETENTION OF CURRENT EMPLOYEES-
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR
PSYCHIATRIC PATIENTS IS CRITICAL
AND THEY ARE NOT GETTING TREATED
IT'S JUST THAT SIMPLE YEAH THIS
IS DEFINITELY MEETS EVERY
DEFINITION OF EMERGENCY THAT I'M
AWARE OF. AND WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. AND HI SENATOR THIS
IS AND DOCTOR COUGH HERE BOSSY-
I'M A CIVIL SERVICE PSYCHIATRIST
AIR FROM AT CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT PROGRAM IN
STOCKTON. THAT IS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF IN PATIENT
CARE- MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY IN
THE CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF C. CDC ARE DOCTORS.
SO WE ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
CITY ARE IF YOU NEED YOUR HELP
IN YOUR SPORT BLUE- RESOLVE THIS
SICK GRONIK ONGOING PROBLEM WITH
THE HIGH BEGIN SEATED OF CIVIL
SERVICE PSYCHIATRIST IN THE C.
D. C. R. SYSTEM. AND BECAUSE OF
THIS THIS HEIDI AT ALL TIME
HIGHS AGAIN SEATED IS IT.
IMPACTING OUR PATIENTS IN MENTAL
HEALTH CARE BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO GET THE ALERT AND
QUALITY CARE THEY ARE SUPPOSED
TO GET BUSY BECAUSE OF THE
VACANCY AT HIGH LOAD OFF CASES.
AB FOUR DOCTORS YOU KNOW. ANDREA
SO THAT'S THE REASON WE ARE HERE
TO ASK YOUR HELP YOU KNOW SO
THAT THEY DON'T REASONS FOR THIS
IT- HIGHLIGHTED TO OFFER BEGINS
OF CIVIL SERVICE PSYCHIATRIST
TO- THE STATE IS IN ACTUALLY AND
IN A- I WOULD SAY IT COULD.
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION CRISIS
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO INCLUDE IT
IN THE CIVIL SERVICE
PSYCHIATRIST. AND IT THERE ARE A
FEW REASONS NUMBER ONE IS THERE
TO. THE CIVIL SERVICE I GOT TO
SELL IT IS NOT COMPETITIVE WITH
THE COMMUNITY. IT IS THE BELOW
THE CURRENT MARKET. AND NUMBER
TWO IS THERE IS NO-
CONSIDERATION THERE IS NO
COMPENSATION FOR THE BOARD AND
DANGEROUS WORKING ENVIRONMENT
AND CONDITION IN THE PRISON
HOSPITALS. BECAUSE WE ARE ALL
SUBJECTED TO A YOU KNOW LIKE WHY
LANCE WE CAN BE CARED ANY MINUTE
JOURNAL. AND IT IS SO THAT IS
NOT CONSIDERED PART OF OUR
SALARY. AND IT IT'S HURTING IS
BECAUSE OF THIS HIGH YOU TO
VACANCY. STATE TO- TRY TO USE
THE CONTRACTOR JUSTER
PSYCHIATRIST TO FILL THE
VACANCIES TEMPORARILY
TECHNICALLY THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE LOCKED UP- SOLUTION FOR THIS
HIGH VACANCY SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE TO YOU. MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS HERE AND THESE PATIENTS
ARE LIKE SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL
THAT HE- EXTREMELY VULNERABLE
PATIENT POPULATION. IN CONSIDER
TO THE SYSTEM YOU KNOW. AND HOW
ABOUT YOU COULD IT UP SO WE CAN
LIST OKAY. SEEMS LIKE THAT THAT
IS BEING JUNE LIKE AS IF YOU
KNOW LIKE PRIMARY MEANS OF FEEL
THE VACANCIES STIRRED BY YOUR
NOSE WE HAVE THE LIKE I. AWSKI
THAT. YOU KNOW RAISING OURSELVES
TO MAKE IT COMPETITIVE WITH THE
COMMUNITY AT LEAST 25% AND OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
PREACHING TO. NEXT PLEASE. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S NOT VERY
FUN I AM A PSYCHIATRIST WITH
CITY C. R. I STARTED OUT IN
CITIES HERE IN TWENTY ELEVEN AS
A CONTRACTOR- AND I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR COMPETITIVE
SALARIES FOR CIVIL SERVICE THAT
CATCHES- I JUST WANT TO MENTION
THAT YOU KNOW I MENTIONED I
STARTED OUT AS A CONTRACTOR
CONTRACT ASAP PLEASE SINCE I WAS
A CONTRACTOR HAVE GONE UP. OVER
2100% OF WHAT IT USED TO BE BUT-
CIVIL SERVICE SALARIES HAVE NOT
AND CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES
ACTUALLY MAKING INCLUDING THEIR
BENEFITS A LOT LESS THAN WHAT
CONTRACTORS ARE MAKING RIGHT
NOW- CONTRACTORS CANNOT PROVIDE
THE SAME CARE OF CIVIL SERVANTS
THEY COME AND GO AS EARLY TO GO
UP AND DOWN AND THERE'S NO
CONTINUITY OF CARE PROVIDED BY
CONTRACTORS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN FEDERAL JUDGE MILLER-
ACCURATELY CAPTURED THE OTHER
REASON WE CANNOT RECRUIT OR
RETAIN AT ARE CUT IN SALARIES.
TO DESCRIBE CDCR- ON IN. DESPITE
WORKPLACE THAT DOES NOT VALUE
THE ESSENTIAL TREATMENT
PERSPECTIVES I THINK I JUST HAVE
TO ORDER. AND CREATES AN
ATMOSPHERE WHERE MORAL IS LOW.
THE DEFINITION OF INSANITY IS
DOING THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER ANY AGAIN AND EXPECTING A
DIFFERENT RESULT. NOTHING CAN
REPLACE THE DIRECT PATIENT CARE
PROVIDED BY CIVIL SERVANTS A. K.
PSYCHIATRIST. IN CDCR- MORE
MONEY NEEDS TO GO TO OR TO
DISCUSS THE CATCHES PACE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS G. THAT HAD
BEEN ON THE PSYCHIATRISTS
CURRENTLY WORKING IN CSP SARCASM
IN AND DIVISION OF CDCR. I HAVE
WORKED SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
BOTH AS A CONTRACTOR AND A CIVIL
SERVANT- AND I DID ALSO MAKE IT
SHORT ATTEMPTING TWENTY EIGHT.
AND TWENTY TWO RETIRED
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WAS NOT
SUSTAINABLE. WITH THE EARS I HAD
OVER TWELVE YEARS- I HAVE-
WORKED BONE ALMOST HALF OF THE
TIME AS A CONTRACTOR VERSUS
CIVIL SERVANTS SO I'M- THE
PERSON TO ACTUALLY EXPERIENCE
THEM THE NEGATIVE ASPECTS OF THE
CONTRACT SYSTEM. SAID THE
MANAGEMENT SOLUTION CURRENTLY
NEITHER MANAGES THEIR OWN
PSYCHIATRIST NOR PROVIDE ANY
LONG TERM SOLUTION FOR
PSYCHIATRIC SHORTAGE. RIGHT NOW
SEE ABSOLUTELY CITIES THE
ARTISAN HUGE CRISIS WHAT IS THE
LACK OF ADEQUATE SELECTIVE STOPS
AND THE SEVERITY OF MENTAL
ILLNESS GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THERE IS A HUGE. PREVALENCE OF
ACTIVE SUBSTANCE USE IN PRISON-
IT'S LIKE THE SEVERITY OF
MANAGEMENT'S. VERY VERY COMPLEX
MYSELF I'M TO PUT BUSH CERTIFIED
HOWEVER AND THE AVERAGE JOE.
SAIKAI ISSUES WHOSE- HIRED BY
MANAGEMENT SOLUTION THE SELDOM
HAS THE TRAINING THAT'S EVEN AN
AVERAGE PSYCHIATRIST HOTTEST AND
OVERALL THEY ARE VERY UNFAIR
SYSTEM QUITE FRANKLY A GOOD
PORTION OF EVEN THE CONTRACTORS
PSYCHOLOGIST GOES FOR MANAGEMENT
SOLUTION THEIR OWN SALARIES AND
THEY DO NOT PROVIDE IF IT UP
PLEASE YES AND THEY DO NOT
PROVIDE SUPERVISION I DECIDE.
TRAINING THAT PSYCHIATRISTS NEED
TO DEAL WITH THIS VIOLENCE
INMATES THAT THEY ARE AT RISK OF
GETTING HOSTAGE WITHOUT ANY
TRAINING THAT'S PROVIDED TO THEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF
YOU COULD PLEASE- TRY TO KEEP
YOUR REMARKS CLOSE OF SHORTER
SURE OTHERS THANK YOU SO MUCH GO
AHEAD SIR OKAY I'M- A METABOLIC
COMMA DOCTOR AT THE CITY OF
STOCKTON AND I'M A PSYCHIATRIST
AND I'M GOING TO REPEAT ON THE
POINTS THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY MADE AND- THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION IS A
CRISIS SITUATION. A STATE
PSYCHIATRIST IS INVESTED IN THE
PLACE WHERE HE WORKS HE
UNDERSTANDS THE CDC ARE YOU
UNDERSTAND THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
OF WORKING IN THE C. D. C. R. TO
POLITICAL IT MAKES SENSE TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN A CIVIL-
SACRAMENTO PSYCHIATRIST BECAUSE
THEY ARE URBAN PROVIDE LONG TERM
CARE TO THESE PATIENTS- BECAUSE
THEY WILL MAKE SURE THAT THE
PATIENTS GET BETTER AND THEN
TRANSFERRED LOWER LEVEL OF CARE.
SO CLINICALLY IT MAKES SENSE
FINANCIALLY ALSO IT MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE THEY CAN BE HARD AT A
LOWER PRICE COMPARED TO THE
CONTACTS PSYCHIATRIST WILL MAKE
MORE THAN DOUBLE THE STATE.
EMPLOYEES- SO WHEN I DO SIXTY
AGO DOES SALARY WAS. A BATCH
SINCE THEN WE HAVE SEEN THE
SELLER THAT NOT PACE WITH THE
MARKET RATES ARE OVER THE
COUNTER- PSYCHIATRIST. THANK YOU
THOSE ARE NOT THOSE OF BROWN'S
AMOUNT OF HIGHLY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. NEXT PLEASE CAN MEN
CHAIR FOR LETTING ME SPEAK I'M
DOCTOR SHERMAN PSYCHIATRISTS
FROM CSC OF STOCKTON AS WELL I
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE PATIENT
CARE ISSUES WE HAVE VERY HIGH
BUT CONCEDED FOR A LONG TIME WE
ARE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE
TREATING THE MOST SICKEST
PATIENTS WHO ARE VERY VIOLENT
PSYCHOTIC SUICIDAL AND GAVE YOU
TO SAVE. NEW TO THEIR MENTAL
ILLNESS STATE IS PAYING- DOUBLE
THE CONTRACT IS NOT HELPING WITH
THE ISSUE BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
CONTINUITY OF CARE AND AS A FEW
OF MY COLLEAGUES I'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED- THE THEY ARE FLOATING
THERE. IS YOU KNOW THEY COME AND
GO- THE PATIENTS HAVE DIFFICULTY
TRUSTING THEM. BECAUSE THEY'RE
JUST FILLING THE GAPS- THERE IS
A STATE PSYCHIATRIST ON INVESTED
IN TAKING CARE OF THESE
PATIENTS. THE PENSION PLAN FOR
THE STATE'S PSYCHIATRIST IS ALSO
OF EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTING- NOT
ATTRACTIVE AT ALL FOR THE NEW
INCOMING- PSYCHIATRIST. WHEN
THEY EXCEED THE COMPARISON
BETWEEN HOW MUCH THEY'RE PAID AT
SIX STATES THAT CHARACTERS AT
ONE THIRTY FOUR DOLLARS COMPARED
TO THREE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS-
AS A CONTRACT PSYCHIATRIST.
THANK YOU SIR IF YOU COULD WRAP
UP YES THE ONLY TO SOLUTION
WOULD BE TWO LINES- BEING THE
SIX STATES THAT CARD IS TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. MORE WHICH WILL BE
COMPATIBLE TO A COMMUNITY
STANDARDS WILL ALLOW COMPENSATED
THE STATE'S ICARDI'S WORKING IN
THESE DANGEROUS ENVIRONMENTS
TAKING CARE OF MOST SICKEST
PATIENT ANDINTIMIDATION OF THE
PEPPER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOU COMING.
NEXT GOOD MORNING HONORABLE
SENATORS MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
JENNY CRAIG I AM IN TRIPS A
CERTIFIED INTERPRETER IN SPANISH
LANGUAGE FOR THE COUNTY OF
MADERA I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF INTERPRETERS- ALSO
KNOWN AS CFI CFI IS FULL STATE
WHAT UNION THAT REPRESENTS
INTRUDERS WORKING AT THE STATE
COURTS AND WE ARE HERE TO MAKE
CALM IN SOME REGARDS TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO- WE SUPPORT THE
BUDGET ITEM ALLOCATING FUNDS TO
COURT EMPLOYEES IN INCREASES IN
BENEFITS AND RETIREMENT HOWEVER.
IT IS NOT CLEAR THAT IF THE
COURT INTERPRETERS ARE ALSO
INCLUDED IN THIS ITEM WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE INCLUDED
WERE SPECIFIED THAT THE
INTERPRETER BUDGET LINE ITEM IS
ALSO SUFFICIENT ERNIE ALMOND
TREATED FOR THE SAME INCREASE WE
ALSO NEED BUDGET LANGUAGE TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THE INTERPRETER
BUDGET LINE ITEM CAN BE USED FOR
RACES SINCE LOCAL COURTS REFUSED
TO GIVE RACES CLAIMING THAT THE
LEGISLATOR HAS NOT CLEARLY
STATED AUTHORITY TO SPEND THE
BUDGET MONEY ON RACES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAVE A GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THOUGHT WE
HAD ADDRESS THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR
WE REALLY NEED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT INTERPRETERS IN
OUR- COURTS. YES PLEASE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
CRISTINA CARO REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC TELEVISION ALL
THE PUBLIC BROADCASTING STATIONS
IN THE STATE. ASKING FOR A
SPECIAL REQUEST IF WE COULD
BEFORE THE SUBCOMMITTEE CLOSES
OUT THE CAL OH YES BUDGET
RELATIVE TO THE EARLY EARTHQUAKE
WARNING SYSTEM. YOU MAY RECALL
THAT WE WERE BEFORE YOU BEFORE-
REQUESTING THAT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE FUNDS THAT ARE
SET ASIDE FOR THE EARLY
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEM IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. BE
SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED TO ON
BOARDING THE REMAINING PUBLIC
BROADCASTING STATIONS THAT WERE
NOT PART OF THE PHASE ONE
PROJECT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE
PILOT AS YOU REMEMBER
DEMONSTRATED THATWE ARE GIVING
OF FIRE STATIONS FOR EXAMPLE A
THREE SECOND HEADS UP SO THAT
THEY CAN ROLL UP THEIR DOORS.
AND THEY CAN GET THEIR TRUCKS
OUT SAFELY BEFORE AN EARTHQUAKE
OCCURS WE'VE HAD EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH CALLAWAY YES
MADAM CHAIR YOU'VE BEEN SO
HELPFUL OF A DOCTOR BRECK BILL
AS WELL. AND THIS WEEK WE
PROVIDED DOCTOR BRECK BILL WITH
SOME. OTHER LANGUAGE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WE THINK WOULD
PROVIDE AS THE CLARITY THAT WERE
AFTER ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
AND WE JUST ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THAT REQUEST
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR THE ROLE
THAT YOU PLAY IN OUR-
EMERGENCIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT PLEASE YES SIR MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE CARROLL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY- TWO ISSUES THAT WE
WANTED TO BRING UP TODAY. PURSES
THAT WE WERE DISAPPOINTED IN THE
GAPS BUDGET DID NOT PROVIDE A
COMPLETE REPEAL OF CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS IN THE TRAFFIC
COURT. HAS HAS BEEN REQUESTED BY
ORGANIZATION OF MANY OF THE
LEGAL SERVICES WE KNOW YOU'VE
HEARD THIS. THIS ISSUE IN OUR-
HEARING AND WE REALLY PRE. THE
STATEMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY
MANY OF YOU THAT TIME THEY WERE
LOOKING THAT THAT THAT WHEN YOU.
COME TO THE INAL BUDGET THAT
YOU ARE ACTUALLY COMPLETELY
REPEAL CIVIL ASSESSMENTS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT THAT CAN BE WORKED OUT WITH
THE GOVERNOR. AND THEN THE
SECOND THING THAT I WANT TO
RAISE IS THAT I WANT TO SECEDE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS OF
SENATOR CORTESE IN YOU MADAM
CHAIR. RELATING TO CARE COURT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
I WILL JUST FOCUS RIGHT NOW I
THINK ON THE- COMMENTS THAT.
CENTER CORTESE REYES UP WHICH I
THINK ARE SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WHICH IS WHAT IS THE
PLAN FOR HOUSING PEOPLE. THIS
PLAN DOES NOT YET HAVE A PLAN. I
THINK THE POINTS THAT THE
SENATOR RAISED. ABOUT THE
INITIAL STAGES AND WHAT THE
WHERE THE BEDS ARE IS ONE ASPECT
OF THAT WITHIN A VERY
SIGNIFICANT OUT. HIS WHERE IS
THE- HOUSING WHERE'S THE FUNDING
AND HOW ARE WE GOING TO HOUSE
PEOPLE. HE'S GOING TO BE THROUGH
RENTAL SUBSIDIES ARE WE GONNA
PROVIDE SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. AND
IS THE FUNDING IN THE BUDGET AND
IS GOING TO BE COMMITTED FOR THE
LONG TERM. MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO NEED HELP. NOT FOR
TWENTY SIX MONTHS OR ONE YEAR.
THEY'RE GONNA NEED IT FOR.
ONGOING PERIOD OF TIME. AND WE
IS A STATE MUST FINALLY COMMIT
OUR- LIVES. TO PROVIDING HOUSING
ONGOING RENTAL HOUSING
ASSISTANCE THAT WILL. INSPIRE
LESS THAT CAN BE PROVIDED IN
THIS WE WOULD URGE YOU TO REJECT
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF
YOU. CAN SEND THIS BACK TO
POLICY FOR FURTHER
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- YES. OKAY GOOD-
CHAIR COMMITTEE MAY- DE CHIPPER
EXACT DIRECTOR FOR THE UNION. OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS ALSO THE-
CHAIR OF THE- EXECUTIVE BOARD
FOR ASHLEY CALIFORNIA. I
APOLOGIZE WE WERE HERE EARLIER
WE HAD TO GO TO ANOTHER MEETING
WITH DR ROMULO BURKE WE'RE BACK-
WE WERE MEETING WITH HIM ON A
CITY SURVEY COULD FEES FOR
PSYCHIATRY. THE ESTATE HAS A
VERY SIMILAR PROBLEM- CDCR. AT
LEAST WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE FOR DSA SHE PUT IN NINE
AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WORKER RETENTION. ALBEIT NEED
NEEDS TO BE COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN
AS SOMEONE WHO SHARED THE LAST
TWO BARGAINING SESSIONS WITH THE
STATE. KELLY JR WILL NOT
RECOGNIZE OR GIVE US ANYTHING AT
THE TABLE WITH RESPECT. TO THE
PSYCHOLOGIST EVEN THOUGH WE'VE
GOT A 50% VACANCY RATE SO I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU PUT A
RECRUITMENT RETENTION. BONUS TO
BRING BACK CIVIL SERVICE TO
WHERE IT SHOULD BE PATIENTS ARE
SUFFERING. AND WE HAVE SEVERAL
DOCTORS HERE. WHO COULD ALLUDE
TO THAT AND TESTIFIED I LIKE TO
CALL HER BOARD PRESIDENT DR
STUART BUSSY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU DOUG
GRANDPARENTS VENTURE. EVER AND-
MR NEWMAN ASTIR CORTESE. THE
ESSAY OF A SOUND THAT WAS
MENTIONED IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS I THINK- DOVETAILS NICELY
WITH OUR PROBLEMS. MUST BE AN
EMERGENCY HIGH BAR- YES THERE'S
53% VACANCY SO IS A KNOWN
PROBLEM. SOLUTIONS THAT ARE MADE
FOR GOALS. OF THE SOLUTIONS AS
PER THE SPECIAL MASTER AND ALL
THE OTHER REPORTS THAT HAVE
INDICATED THAT CDCR. NEEDS OVER-
FOR. OVER PER. AS WELL AS- AND
MORE GARAGE. BY THE REPORT THAT
WE DO. WITH THE STATE FOR EIGHT
MONTHS. BOB SO WHERE IS IT AS
DOUG SAID STONEWALLED AT THE
TABLE. WE HAVE PEOPLE BEHIND ME
THEY'RE GONNA YOU KNOW TALK
ABOUT THE- WHAT THEIR IT'S GOING
OUT TO KAISER AND EVERYWHERE
ELSE. ALL THE PLOT AND ALL THE
COMMON MISSION STATEMENT SAID
FOR EQUAL CARE THAT IN MAY TWO
PRISONERS DESERVE IT. THEY
DESERVE STAFFING THEY DESERVE.
VISITS THAT AREN'T CANCEL
BECAUSE OF LACK OF NUMBERS SO
RECRUITMENT ATTENTION AS AS YOU
GOING HERE NOW IS THE KEY WORDS
SELF CORRECTING LINE. THANK YOU
X. PLEASE HI MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS THE DR CHUNG AND I WORK AT.
IN STATE HOSPITAL IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY- MANY OF MY
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES LIVE
IN L. A. COUNTY HIGH MYSELF ALSO
LIVE IN LA COUNTY AND I'VE BEEN
WITH THE STATE FOR OVER FOURTEEN
YEARS I CAN TELL YOU WHEN I
STARTED. AS A YOUNG CAREER
PSYCHIATRISTS THE STATE- WITH
THE IT JOB AND IT IT PAID US FOR
OUR TALENTS AND IT WAS IT WAS
COMPETITIVE IT PAID US WHAT WE
WERE WORTH. AND SO A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN A COHORT WE MOVED
FROM KAISER OR FROM OUTSIDE
PLACES TO COME AND WORK FOR THE
STATE. IT WAS IT WAS GOOD.
CURRENTLY AND WE WERE ABOUT
HUNDRED PSYCHIATRISTS BACK THEN.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE TWENTY NINE.
STAFF PSYCHIATRIST. YEAH WE
WE'VE LOST A LOT OF PEOPLE THE
VACANCY RATE IS. AN ABSOLUTE
CRISIS WE ARE THE NUMBER ONE JOB
VACANCY I'M I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
I'M- I'M PROBABLY REPEATING
THINGS THAT EVERYONE HAVE A HAS
ALREADY TOLD YOU. BUT IT'S YOU
KNOW I SEE IT ON MY UNIT I SEE
IT IN THE BACK BECAUSE I KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE THAT THE-
BACKLOG IN THE COUNTY JAILS
THEY'RE JUST. SUFFERING IN JAIL
WAITING TO BE HOUSED IN A STATE
HOSPITAL NOT MEDICATED AND SO
IT'S AN EXTREME CRISIS OUR
PATIENTS ARE THE MOST CRITICALLY
ILL. WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL.
PATIENTS WITHIN THE PRISONS AND
WITHIN THE HOSPITALS AND- IT'S
IT IS IT'S A CRISIS THERE THE
NUMBERS ARE INCREASING- AND
SUICIDE RATES ARE INCREASING
DRUG OVERDOSES ARE AT ALL TIME
HIGH. WE'RE SEEING THE IMPACT.
YOU KNOW WITH THE PATIENTS THAT
WE TREAT THE MENTAL PSYCHOSIS
DRUG INDUCED PSYCHOSIS. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF SUFFERING AND
BECAUSE OF THE VACANCY RATE IT'S
IMAGINING YOU KNOW. PERHAPS
IMAGINE IF YOU WERE IN A
HOSPITAL. AS A PATIENT AND THE
UNITS ONLY 45% STAFFED YEAH
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE RUNNING ON
FUMES RIGHT NOW AND SO. WE
IMPLORE YOU TO PLEASE HELP US-
WITH- GIVING US A COMPETITIVE.
DIFFERENTIAL SALARY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. HI MY
NAME IS DR NEIL KHANNA DOMINO'S
PSYCHIATRIST AT NAPA STATE
HOSPITAL AND- I'VE BEEN THERE
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS- I CAN TELL
YOU STUDLEY THE WORKLOAD HAS
BEEN GOING UP- JUST ABOUT TWO
MONTHS AGO WE ON THE UNIT ABOVE
MINE. THE PSYCHIATRIST OF THE
CONTRACTS THAT HIGH INTEREST
LEFT. AND SO WE DIDN'T NOBODY
HAS BEEN ABLE TO COVER THAT UNIT
SENSE. AND SO- DAY PULLED US
FROM DIFFERENT UNITS TO COVER
SOME OF THE POPULATION- SADLY
THIS IS THIS IS THE WAY IT SEEMS
TO BE GOING THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
HOSPITAL- IT IT'S GETTING WORSE-
THE- YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
SALARIES AND SO ON- THE
LEADERSHIP. BARELY EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT'S AN ISSUE-
THEY HAD TO FIX THE PROBLEMS
THEY'RE TRYING TO HIRE
CONTRACTORS WHO WIND UP COSTING
AT LEAST TWICE AS MUCH- WHICH-
AND THEY CAN'T PROVIDE THE SAME
LEVEL OF SERVICE BECAUSE THEY
THERE'S NO CONTINUITY CARE THE
COMING FOR A FEW MONTHS AND THEN
THEY'RE GONE- SO COULD YOU
PLEASE WRAP UP THANK YOU YEAH
YEAH SO BASICALLY YOU KNOW THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE NEED TO
RELEASE- AND WE NEED SOME HELP.
WITH OUR SALARIES AND OUR-
HOPEFULLY SOME READ A RETENTION
AND GREEN RETIREMENT BENEFITS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING. HI I'M DOCTOR JEFF
NEW BARS I'M A GENERAL
PRACTITIONER I'M NOT A
PSYCHIATRIST BUT I WORK WITH A
PSYCHIATRIST AT KALINGA STATE
HOSPITAL I'M A STATE EMPLOYEE.
WE NEED MORE STATE PSYCHIATRISTS
I'VE GOT ONE STATE PSYCHIATRIST
TACKLING A STATE HOSPITAL ONE.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE THEY THEY
JUST DON'T PAY ENOUGH IF WE
COULD GET SOME R. AND R. THAT
WOULD BRING SOME PSYCHIATRIST TO
CLEAN GOOD BE WONDERFUL. WE HAVE
CONTRACTS PSYCHIATRIST THEY TRY
TO DO A GOOD JOB BUT THEY'RE
ONLY THERE FROM THREE TO SIX
MONTHS AT A TIME THEY DON'T HAVE
A CLOSE CONNECTION TO THE
PATIENTS. THE PATIENTS JUST
DON'T RESPOND AS WELL
THERAPEUTICALLY THAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE YOU NEED A STATE
WORKER THAT'S COMMITTED TO THE
INSTITUTION. THANKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. I'M DOCTOR SUSAN
ANDREWS AND I'VE BEEN A POSITION
FOR ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN YEARS.
I'VE WORKED IN THE COUNTY AND
PRIVATE PRACTICE AND NOW. I'M A
STAFF PSYCHIATRIST SAID
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IN THE PIPP PROGRAM. IN
STOCKTON. I HAVE WORKED ON THE
A. B. THIRTY FOUR PROGRAM WHICH
HOUSE THE HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL
. I'VE WORKED IN COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH. AND I'VE LISTENED TO THE
DISCUSSIONS TODAY. WHEN YOU WERE
ASKING WHERE ARE WE GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF THESE PEOPLE. I
TELL YOU WHERE YOU'RE TAKING
CARE OF THEM IN PRISON OKAY AND
WITH THE CLOSURES AT ALL OF THE
ACT IT'S NOT GONNA ALLEVIATE
THAT PROBLEM. ONCE YOU HAVE
THESE PEOPLE HARRELL'S IN THE
PRISON FECHTER. THEY ARE
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL. BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE STAFFING FOR THAT NOT
ONLY OUR COLLEAGUES HERE WHO ARE
AT THE TOP OF THIS BUT YOU DON'T
HAVE NEVER SEEN YOU DON'T HEALTH
PSYCHOLOGY YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY. SO ALL I WOULD SAY TO
YOU AS A VERY HAPPY TAX PAID. WE
REALLY NEED TO WRAP HER HIPS
AROUND AND LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ACTUALLY AT GROUND ZERO
YOU ARE IN A NINE ELEVEN
SITUATION. AND WE LOVE OUR
PATIENTS AS DIFFICULT AS THEY
ARE BUT FEEL WE HAVE THE
SOLUTION CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FACILITY CAN BE THE FLAG SHIP.
HOSPITAL IN THE ENTIRE NATION IF
YOU WOULD JUST LISTEN TO YOUR
CIVIL SERVANT PSYCHIATRISTS SO
WE WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO COME
VISIT US. WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
A PRACTICE SESSION WITH YOU
WHATEVER YOU NEED FOR USTO GIVE
YOU THE SOLUTIONS BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A SOLUTION. WE DO HAVE AN
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING THANK
YOU FOR COMING. PRECIADO VERY
MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
WHO IS HERE IN PERSON TOOK THE
TIME TO COME AND MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS WE GREATLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR YOUR TESTIMONIES WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ANYONE- YES
JERRY HAVE OTHERS ON THIS ISSUE
POINT I NOW BEFORE WE GET TO THE
TELEPHONIC. TO TRY I WANT TO
THANK THE PSYCHIATRIST FOR BEING
HERE TODAY IS FOR SHEER
LEADERSHIP. AND POINT OUT THE
OBVIOUS RIGHT WHICH IS WHERE BUT
THE PRISON SYSTEM DO WE NEED
PSYCHIATRISTS THE MOST IF WE
BELIEVE TRULY IN REHABILITATION-
CENTER COURT JUDGMENT MENTIONED
HE AND I WERE IT. SOLANO STATE
PRISON LAST WEEK WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES THE
PRISONERS TRULY NEED FOR ALL OF
THE ISSUES THAT BROUGHT THEM
THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE TO BE
I. D. YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY IS
WELL HER TODAY- AND I APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I'M SORRY WE HAVE ONE
MORE. IN PERSON ONE MORE WITNESS
IN PERSON GO AHEAD SIR. HI I AM-
WILLIAM HELLER AND M. D. I'M A
SKY TRYST- WITH CDCR. I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR APPROXIMATELY TEN
YEARS- I'M UP IN FOLSOM. DONALD
WORKING AT- A LEVEL FOUR. AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT. THE END
WHAT WORK ENVIRONMENT IS
DIFFICULT NOW I I'VE HAD PRIVATE
I WORKED IN PRIVATE PRACTICE I
WORK FOR- COUNTY FACILITIES.
THIS IS DEFINITELY A MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT SITUATION THERE HAD
SOFT AT TIMES DANGEROUS IT'S
OFTEN HOSTILE. YOU KNOW AND IT'S
- BECAUSE OF HOW WE ARE STAFFED
RIGHT NOW. YOU DON'T GET TO STAY
WITH YOUR PATIENTS STILL MOVE
YOU FROM ONE BLOCK TO ANOTHER
AND SO THAT'S DIFFICULT WHEN IT
WHEN IT WAS BETTER I GOT TO KNOW
MY PATIENCE AND BAND WE KNEW
WHAT. I KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON
WHAT THEY NEEDED I COULD SEE IF
THEY WERE DOING BETTER OR NOT
DOING BETTER NOW IT'S MUCH MORE
OF A YOU KNOW AN IMMEDIATE- HE
FELL AND THEN YOU GO ON THAT
WHICH EVEN IF YOU READ THE
RECORDS. IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
AND I DO THINK THAT THERE'S A
REAL CALL FOR SKY TRISH TO
LEAVE. YOU KNOW TO GO TO A MUCH
NICER PLACE. ALLEN AND THAT'S-
UNDERSTANDABLE. YOU KNOW I'M ON
. I AM CONSIDERING GOING MYSELF
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR- EVEN
THOUGH I'VE BEEN THERE. IT'S
FRUSTRATING AND I OFTEN FEEL
THAT WERE. WERE AS CHARACTERS
FOR THE STATE WE'RE NOT TREATED
VERY WELL. YOU KNOW WHEN- OTHER-
INSTITUTIONS AND OTHER
PRACTITIONERS SOCKET RAISES AND
GET TAKEN CARE OF. WE OFTEN
DON'T AND SO. I CAN SEE THE
FRUSTRATION BECAUSE I FEEL IT-
BUT YOU DO NEED PEOPLE THAT HAVE
A HIGH TOLERANCE IT'S A SPECIAL
BREED THAT CAN THAT CAN WORK
WITH- VERY VERY ANGRY PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW AND STILL SEE THEM AS
PEOPLE YOU KNOW INSTILLED AND
STILL- SEE WHAT COULD HELP THEM.
EVEN THE LIFERS BIG BASS BEEN
NEED US TO YEAH. SO LEAVE CAN
THAT YES THANKS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DARKER AGAIN. TO REITERATE
WHAT US THAT ARE NEWMAN SAID WE-
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE YOU. AND
MORE SO AFTER HEARING YOUR
TESTIMONY IT REALLY MATTERS THAT
YOU TOOK THE TIME. TO COME HERE
PERSONALLY AND SHARE YOUR
EXPERIENCES AND WE WILL DO OUR
BEST WE WILL DO OUR BEST OF THE
FIGHT FOR THE THINGS THAT YOU
NEED. TO BE ABLE TO GIVE THE
BEST SERVICE IN THESE- IN THESE
FACILITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO-
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. WE CAN
BEGIN WITH THE TELECONFERENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR-
WE DO HAVE A BUNCH CUED UP
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO EIGHTY JEOPARDY
WILL QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE AND PLEASE WRITE
BACK IN THE QUEUE WILL BEGIN
TODAY WITH WIND THIRTY ARE YOU
COULD TAKE ON THAT TYPE MODERATE
RIGHT NOW MODERATE COULD YOU
PLEASE- GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY.
PROXIBID COURSE I CAN'T- ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE- LITTLE OVER THIRTY CUED UP
RIGHT NOW MADAM CHAIR OKAY GO
AHEAD MR MODERATOR. THANKS MUCH
LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANIELLE AND
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER I'M
CALLING TODAY- CALL ATTENTION
TO- THAT SAFETY NET FOR ALL
COALITION AND URGE THE SENATE TO
ADOPT THE SIXTEEN SIX HUNDRED
AND NINETY MILLION REQUEST FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
EXCLUDED WORKERS AS PART OF THE
PRIORITIES FOR THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR. EVEN SHORT TERM BLOCKED
OFF THIS LOT STOPLOSS THIS CAN
BE CATASTROPHIC CATASTROPHIC
CALIFORNIA WORKERS I KNOW
WORKERS SHOULD BE EXCLUDED OUR
COMMUNITIES CAN'T WAIT FOR IT
THANKS DISASTER AND WE HOPE TO
SEE THIS IMPLEMENTED THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANKS FOR CALLING NEXT
. WHY TWENTY FIVE EUROPE. THAT
AFTERNOON KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
HERNANDEZ AND I'M CALLING WITH
THE INLAND EMPIRE IMMIGRANT
YOUTH COLLECTIVE I'M CALLING A
PART OF THE SAFETY NETWORK I
THINK THE NEXT FOR ALL COALITION
AND I'M ALSO CALLING TO URGE THE
SENATE DOES NOT THE SIX HUNDRED
NINETY DOLLARS MILLION REQUEST
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WORK
THE FOURTEENTH THANK YOU WOULD
MENTION. CERTAIN DROP BOXES CAN
BE CATASTROPHIC THANK YOU. SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT
TWENTY ARE ALL. THANK YOU SORRY
MA'AM AT APPEAR- ON MY TWENTY
FIFTH GO AHEAD. HI MANY
RODRIGUEZ AND I'M WITH THE CAR
WASH PERCENT CALLING A PART OF
THE C. NET FOR ALL. I'M TO URGE
THE FOR TO ADOPT THIS SIX
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION REQUEST
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS BURKE
GOOD IT WORKERS AS PART OF THE
PARTY FOR THE BUDGET THIS YEAR.
EVEN SHORT TERM JOB LOSSES CAN
BE CATASTROPHIC FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS IN ORDER SHOULD BE
EXCLUDED OUR COMMUNITY CAN'T
WAIT FOR THE NEXT THE STAFF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ADD TO THE MEANING OF
MY NAME IS TO BE LIKE A CALL AND
I'M CALLING BECAUSE YOU ARE
AFRAID OF SPEAKING AT ALL
COALITION I'M URGING FOLKS TO
ADOPT. SIX SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS. BERMAN
AND BERMAN AND- DON'T WANT OTHER
BUDGET IS. BOB MICHAEL THE LATE
IN OUR FUTURE. I COULD. NOT ON
MON AFTER SO MANY AND FRIENDS
BECAUSE TO TRY TO IMMIGRANT
WORKERS DURING THE DOT. TO FIND
PROTECT THE WAGES AND IT IS NOT
A FEW- NONPROFIT ON PRIVATE MAKE
IT AND WE REALLY NEED THINK
ACTION. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT. BECAUSE LINE
FIFTY. FIVE FIFTY YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO. YES GO AHEAD GO AHEAD
MALCOLM. THE NUMBER IS NINE THE
GENERAL PRODUCT BY FEEL THE LOVE
POLICY ON RELATIVELY ENOUGH I
DON'T FOLLOW THE THREE AMONG THE
FINAL IN THE NOVEL I GOT A LOOK.
THEY HANDLE NOVENTA ME YOUR NAME
BUT I READ IT BECAUSE OF THIS
AND THEY OPEN UP A LOT OF PEOPLE
FROM ALL PARTS OF THE BUILDING
LEARNING AND ACTION AND BRITAIN
FOOTBALL IN I KNOW SIMPLE OF.
THAT PART OF THE DABABNEH AND
EXAMPLE BUT INSTEAD. BUT BUT-
BUTTON THREE CAPITAL TO A WHOLE
LOT IN THE AN EQUAL LEGAL. WE
WILL FOLLOW THE EVENTS OF GOING
. RIGHT BUT FOR ME THAT IS I'M
IMPROPER VOTER ROOKIE MORE. OKAY.
I'LL TAKE A FIGHT TO KILL WILL-
ONLINE FIFTY NINE MEDICARE OKAY
. IT BURNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND IF YOU
LEAVE OUT I LIVE I AM ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR AT THE END COALITION
FOR IMMIGRANT SHOT THAT- WE ARE
ALL PART OF THE NIGHT FOR ALL
COALITION. I'M CALLING TO URGE
THE SENATE TO ADOPT THE THREE
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION REQUEST
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
EXCLUDED WORKERS OKAY NINETEEN
REMINDED US OF THE CREDIT
INFORMED ROLE THESE WORKERS
EIGHT IN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
THESE ARE EMERGENCY OFFERING MY
NANA HOW VULNERABLE THESE
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
DURING THE AMERICAN SEAT BECAUSE
OF. THE INJURY AT ALL ONE
EMPLOYMENT LAW. HEY WE NEED TO
ARE YOU HELP THESE WORKERS NEED
YOUR- A VACANT WE ARE PART THREE
BILLION. IN STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES- BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
MARKET IF THEY ARE MOSTLY
EXCLUDED FROM- BENEFITS THAT
PREVENT THEM FROM FOR THEIR
FALLING INTO. EXTREME POVERTY I
THANK YOU WILL VOTE IN FAVOR OF
THE- ALL HE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING PLEASE. FORTY YOUR
OFFICE. ONE OF THE NEW NUMBER IS
THAT THE RECORD YOU MENTIONED BY
THE PROPOSAL FOR A COUPLE
HUNDRED OF THE BUILDING WHAT
WHAT PART ACCORDING HUNDRED
FORTY THAT HARMFUL. THE YOUNG
MAN LOOKED OKAY THAT'S ANOTHER
YEAH DEBATE IN OF YOUR NAY WATER
THE MINUTE OF IT AND THEY'LL ARE
PROPERLY FIFTY WE DON'T MARKET A
LOT THAT IS THE PROCESS POINT
PLANE IF THEY ARE. INCLUDES
THIRTY GOT A PHONE CALL BACK
FROM THE DOCTOR PUT THE BUCKLE
POINTED OUT THAT BECAUSE WITH
APPLICABLE TO PEOPLE IN ONE OF
OUR PROBABILITY IT IS LEGAL.
HELLO NEED IS NOT GETTING BACK.
RIGHT THE NETWORK. PART OF THEIR
PARTY FOR THEIR BUDGET NEXT
YEAR. YEAH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
. NEXT PLEASE FIND THANK YOU
LINE SEVENTY YOUR OPEN. HELLO
NUMBER ONE SHE WANTED CENTER THE
CLOSEST AWARDED THE BODEGA SHE
JUMPED FROM ABOUT THE A LOT OF
FUN ONE THAT WOULD IT WOULD DO
THAT BUT I. YEAH MOM ALL ARE NOT
DOUBLE THINK FOR EXAMPLE ON THE
- BROTHER IN THE FUTURE AND- ARE
UP HOLIDAYS JULIE. FROM THIRTY
THE OTHER PRODUCTS YOU FOR THE-
INCLUDES LAST. AWFUL AWFUL.
GO AHEAD ARE YOU. HELLOWE ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING YOU.
WELL LET'S SEE HERE GO ON YES
NOW WE CAN'T. OKAY PERFECT SORRY
ABOUT THAT GUYS WILL HELLO MY
NAME IS GOOD FOR AFFORDABLE
WAREHOUSE WORK WHICH IS TEN AS
FOLLOWING A- NET FOR ALL
POLLUTION I'M CALLING URGE
SENATE TO FIFTY HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS- AND THEN THE-
FOR EXCLUDE WORKERS AT OF THE-
TOWARDS ITS BUDGET HERE. I'LL
KEEP AN EYE AND SHORT AND
PROTECT. THANK YOU HAVE LACK OF
. THANK YOU FOR CALLING. GO
AHEAD SIXTY. SIXTY EIGHT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PASS. YEAH YES AHEAD
THANK YOU MY NAME A FAMILY I'M
CALLING FROM WORKERS YOU
VOCALISTS AND ALSO CUTTING OF
SECOND FROG. AND I'M CALLING TO
URGE THE TO SIXTY NINE MILLION
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
EXPO WORK AS PART ALREADY FOR
THIS YEAR'S- ALREADY PASSED BILL
WOULD HAVE FEARED SUPPORTERS AND
SHE DOWN ON WORKERS WHO DON'T
ANY- ACCESS TO BETTER EIGHT AND
THE- IN KIND ARE BEING THE
WORKER SO- IT SHOULD IT WILL BE
TOUGH FOR THE FORTY TO BE ABLE
TO GET THE AID- MOVING FORWARD
AND- HOPEFULLY AND I WOULD WAIT
TILL THAT THE TO HAVE- FOR THIS
IS A FOR SO IS SUPPORTING THE
JEFF. ADOPTED SIXTEEN MANY
DOLLARS ONE POINT BENEFITS WORKS
WORKERS THANK YOU THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO EVERY. KEEP IT AS
SHORT YOU COUNT WE CAN EVERY.
EVERYBODY SAYS. GO AHEAD
MODERATE. SEVENTY ONE YEAR OLD
PLEASE GO. THIS SEVEN ONE WHICH
I TESTIFY HELLO. BECAUSE I HAD.
HELLO WITH FIVE IS BETTER
GONZALEZ MADE. A LOCAL APPOINTED
LIKE GO ON THE SYSTEM THIS WILL
BE THE PRODUCT. FOR YOUR MIND OF
WHAT- SHE SAID ABOUT A IS THE
MOMENT I'M GONNA FIND OUT IF YOU
JUST THIS OF POLY A HOLLOW THIS.
AS SOON AS A PROPOSED BUDGET
CUTS ISSUE THAT'S AS SOON. NEXT
PLEASE BY SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE MY NAME IS ZERO
WASTE YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD.
OKAY FACT HI MY NAME IS EVA AND
I AM PART OF THE WHOLE NATION
DEALS REJUVENATED CALLING AS
PART OF THE NATIONAL COALITION
I'M CALLING TO URGE THE SENATE.
TO ALLOCATE SIX HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SIDE
EFFECTS- BROWN INCIDENT FOR
EXCLUDED WORKERS AS PART OF
THEIR PRIORITIES IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR INCLUDING- LOSSES OF
JOBS EVEN FOR SHORT TIME
PERIODS- CAN BE INCREDIBLY
CAPTURE CATASTROPHIC FOR WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA A NOTE FROM-
WORKERS SHOULD BE EXCLUDED OR
COMMUNITIES ARE ANXIOUS FOR THE
NEXT DISASTER. I NEED TO PROTECT
THEM GIVEN THAT THEY PROTECTED
THE REST OF OUR COMMUNITIES
DURING THE PANDEMIC CHEAPER THE
ONES WORKING WELL MANY OF US
WERE PEOPLE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
TO STAY HOME IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE PROTECT THEM IN ADOPTING THIS. BUDGET PRIORITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANKS
TWO FIVE ME ON SO SORRY ONE
SEVEN FOUR PER GO AHEAD. AFTER
MADAM CHAIRMAN OF IS A LIST OF
ENOUGH ON BEHALF OF A PERFECT
COUNTY HEALTH AND WORLD COUNTY
WERE. OF CALIFORNIA OFFERING
COMMENT ON YOUR QUICK PROPOSAL.
SORT OF YOUR PART EIGHT I. WE
REALLY THE FROM COMMITTEES COMER
. THIS MORNING- ABOUT THIS AND
TO BE AND POINT WE WANT TO ON.
AND TRAINING. TO LEADERS A
KNOWLEDGE COUNTY WILL NEED AND
OF FUNDING IMPLEMENT OR AND
ENSURE THE PROGRAM SIX. WE DO
INTO THERE WERE BE IMPAIR ACROSS
COUNTY. BECAUSE ALL HEALTH
DEFENDER. ALREADY BEEN
CONSERVING. DON'T WE DO A PRE IT
MINISTRY ALL. AND THE B. THREE
TALK THAT THEY TO WORK OKAY FROM
CALL THAT AND BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE. A ONE ON
RESEARCH AND BUT GOOD FOR YOU
CAN RESPOND LEGAL. BUT FINALLY
WE THE WOULD BE REAL VALUE OF
FISCAL AND OPERATIONALLY YOUR
CORE INCOME PRINT INCREMENTAL
PHASED APPROACH A PLANT BROWN UP
THAT WOULD BEGIN AND THEN A
COHORT OF EARLY COUNTY WOULD GET
STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTNERS ALL
LEVELS FROM THE OPPORTUNITY TO I
DON'T. THE CORRECT AND CHALLENGE
AND BARRIERS TO PROGRAM FIX MAKE
IT BASED ON THAT INITIAL
APPEARANCE AND ULTIMATELY THE A
STRONG MORE WE OVER TIME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR OF THE APPROACH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AND THE
NEXT PLEASE. W. PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AND
I'M CALL FROM SAN GOING THE
SPEAKING FOR ALL. I'M CALLING TO
THE SENATE BECAUSE HUNDRED
NINETY DOLLAR REQUIRED FOR THE-THIS YEAR CREATE AN UNEMPLOYED
AND PROGRAM FOR A IMMIGRANT
WORKER. ANYWAY OF JOB LOSS IT
COMPLIES- GUITAR WITHOUT WORK
AND OUT A STRONG FOR IN WORKERS
AND HEALTH IN OUR COMMUNITY
CAN'T KEEP BEING EXCLUDED
ESSENTIAL UNEMPLOYMENT RELIEF
HOPE YOU'RE PRIORITY AND THE
BUDGET YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK PLEASE. ONE SIX TO EUROPE
. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE THIS
IS BONTA THAT ON ON THE OF MY
AND PART THE FIFTEEN FOR ALL.
FOR CALLING TO URGE AND IT
REALLY TO A DOT HUNDRED MIL
FUNDING BENEFITS RECRUITED
WORKERS AS PART OF THE BUDGET
PARTY HERE AS YOU KNOW WHEN THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HIT ON
MILLIONS LOST YOUR JOB AND
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CAPITAL
FLOATED AN ESSENTIAL LIFELINE
HOWEVER AN OUTDATED- AND
EXCLUSIONARY POLICIES
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT WORKERS
WHO COMPRISE ONE IN SIXTEEN
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA WORK
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THANK YOU I THINK SOME
OF THE MOST SEVERELY IMPACTED I
CALL THE NINETEENTH WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SIX HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT PLEASE. THIRTY SIX
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR COMMITTEE AND STAFF WRITER
MORE MENU WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ASETEK APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
DISCUSSION ON CARE COURT IN
PARTICULAR THE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE CHAIR AND
SENATOR CORTESE- WE SHARE
CONCERNS OF HOUSING OPTIONS AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND
ONGOING FUNDING FOR NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH MEMBERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DETERMINE
COUNTY CAUGHT THAT AS ALSO
TOUCHED ON EARLIER CONCERNED HOW
MANY PETITIONS WILL BE FILED.
AND HOW MANY PUT AT PARTICIPANTS
WILL REQUIRE SERVICES TREATMENT
AND HAVING PLANS WHEN THE FACT
THE PROTEIN BUDGET LEGISLATIVE
DEADLINES AND UKNOWN FISCAL
IMPACT WE AGO COMMENTS FROM MY
COUNTY PARTNERS AND PROPOSED A
PHASED IN APPROACH FOR ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT THE MEASURE
TRUE PROGRAM CAUGHT BEFORE
MANDATING IMPLEMENTATION ACROSS
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
AGAIN- WITH THIS COMMITTEE BOTH
HOUSES IN ADMINISTRATION. THANK
YOU. THANKS PLEASE. I WANT ONE
PLEASE GO. AFTER DANIEL SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE PROBATION
OFFICER INTO OF THE PROVISION
PROPOS FOR TWO MILLION FROM THE
LITTLE CENTER TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS ON OUR COURT ORDERED
REQUIREMENTS AND REALLY IT
REMOVED TECHNOLOGY AND
TRANSPORTATION BARRIERS AND
MEETING INDIVIDUALS WHERE THEY
ARE TO HELP THEM BE SUCCESSFUL-
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL OF A HUNDRED MILLION
FOR COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITY
MODERNIZATION. AND SPECIFICALLY
CALLED ATTENTION TO TWO OTHER
BUDGET REQUEST WE PUT BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE THE
FIRST BEING TWENTY NINE MILLION
AND PLANNING GRANTS TO PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO INVEST IN LONGER
TERM JUVENILE JUSTICE CONTINUE
ONE AND ONE BILLION FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM TO
ALLOW PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO
APPLY FOR FUNDING TO CARRY OUT
THE VISIONARY PLANS DEVELOPED AS
A RESULT OF THESE PLANNING
GRANTS. EITHER CRITICAL
RESOURCES NEEDED TO CARRY OUT
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES VESTED TO
PROBATION AND ULTIMATELY TO
ENHANCE THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ADD TO PROVIDE FOR
THOSE IN OUR CARE WE LOOK FOR TO
MORE CONVERSATION THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME THANKS FOR CALLING NEXT
PLEASE. I EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON CHARTER ALSO
AND SENATOR NEWMAN ALL MY NAME
IS SEAN YOUNG GOING TO WORK FOR
THE FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT DR
AFTER STRUCTURE I'M TODAY AS FAR
OF GATTACA JUSTICE HOW COALITION
. PARK SHE TO WANTED TO ACT THE
WESTERN STANDARDS BECAUSE ON THE
SIDE AND RESPECTFULLY SOMEONE
THE JEB. COMPLETELY LET THE US
IN THE MARKET BUT FROM DIESEL
TRUCKS HAVE NOTHING TO WITH
PUBLIC. AT DID YOU MAKING MY OFF
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE CRIME
LEGAL IS THE LARGEST TO DROP
WORK TOGETHER TO KEEP MONEY
ACOSTA NOT JUST CUT IN HALF OF
HOLMAN FOR WOMEN H. IS THE ONLY
ADEQUATE TO PASS THE WELL. YOU
WALK ABOUT TOWN. YOUR SON. NEXT
PLEASE. WINA EIGHT EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HELLO IT
INTO YOUR- ALL. C. ON THE
PORTABLE. FOLLOW THE NUMBER ON
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY AT THE GOING
OUT OF BUSINESS. YOU KNOW WHAT
THE STREET BY. HELLO MY OPEN UP
THE LET THEM GO TO THE MOVIE
ABOUT THAT ONLY. OUR PHOTOS YOU
THAT'S ANOTHER THAT'S ANOTHER
FIFTY OF MIND FROM YOUR OTHER TO
AT THE OPEN UP A WHOLE FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS FROM APART.
THIRTY DATA FIVE BUT FOR THE.
THANKS PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS BETTER THAN THE WAY FOR
HEALTH WORKERS IT FOR CENTER
CALLING A PART OF THE STATE IN A
FOR ALL POLLUTION I'M CALLING TO
URGE THE SENATE TO ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. FOR
EXPLODED WORKERS ACT WHAT ARE
THE PRIORITY FOR THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR KEEPING THAT SHORT. THANK
PLEASE. SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I WITH INLAND COALITION
FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE ALSO
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BIG
ENOUGH FOR ALL OUR COALITION
URGED THE SENATE TO ADOPT THE
SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY. WHY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR THE
INCLUDED WORKER THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. MY
NAME IS SHELBY KAMALI ON THE
TWENTY COMMITTEE A COMMUNITY
LAWCENTER I'M HERE TO COLLECT
INSPIRING THE FINANCIAL TIMES
THE PROJECT- ACTION FOR FIVE
MINUTES. THE SENATE PRIORITIZE
MOST ELIMINATION LONG GOING
BUDGET AND- ONLY ELIMINATE THE
TIME THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THANKS. PLEASE WE WILL NINETY
FOUR YOU'RE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BRENDA WHAT I AND I WITH THE
WORK WORK THERE RESEARCH I'M
CALLING THE IT NET LOCALLY. TWO
OR TWO SENATE BUT BUILT THE
COUNTRY AND I MILLION MOMENT AND
I THINK WHAT IT. FOR THIRTY. OF
THE PRIORITIES FOR THE- YEAR NO
ONE THREE NEED TO INCLUDE. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING NECK PLEASE.
EXPOSED NINETY SIX BEFORE. THE
MAN CARE CENTERS THE IS KOBE
PRESIDING REPRESENT TO CAL SO OF
SET YET TECHNICIANS IN THE C.
THOUSAND- LICENSE EXPECTS THAT
WE ARE REPRESENT IN PRISONS AND
STATE MENTAL- LAST YEAR CITY
JEREMY A PROPOSED TO WIN NEARLY
TWO ONE AND FIFTY SECOND BUT A
TECHNICIAN POSITION. IN THE
PSYCHIATRIC UNITS AND REPLACE
THEM WITH AROUND A HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS
THANKS TO THE OPPOSITION OF
SENATORS NEWMAN KATIE CORTESE
AND YOU MADAM CHAIR THE
ADMINISTRATION AGREED NOT PLAY
ANYONE OFTEN WOULD IMPLEMENT THE
REPLACEMENT OF SIDE EFFECTS AND
SHE NAY STERN- WOULD SEE AN AIDS
THROUGH ATTRITION. AS WE
PREDICTED AS SOON AS THIS PLAN
WAS ANNOUNCES SITE THAT STARTED
LEAVING THESE POSITIONS AND
GROSS ALSO AS PREDICTED THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
FIND ANY CNA'S THAT ARE ONE IN
THE STEPS NOW THE VACANCIES OF
SECTOR HAVE WALKED ALLEGE THAT
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF OVERTIME AND
MANDATORY OVERTIME. I JUST
WANTED THE COMMUNITY TO BE AWARE
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IS THAT
BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
REVISIT- CBC ARTS PLAN TO
ELIMINATE THESE POSITIONS THE
DEPARTMENT WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO
FIND NEXT YEAR CNA'S TO DO THIS
JOB- AND ADDITIONALLY THERE
UNLICENSED BURKE PROVIDERS AND
LESS FIRST POLICY SECTORS- FOR A
SECOND POINT THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED A FIFTY. DOLLAR BILL
COULD YOU PLEASE WRAP. WRAP UP
THANK YOU. YES MA'AM- FOR THOSE
WERE IN THE SECTOR HOW HE WAS.
AS TO HOW MUCH WE BE GIVEN YOU
HEALTHCARE WERE IN PRISON
STATEMENT OBSTACLES AND I DON'T
SANDERS- SAY. WORK IN SYSTEM
DURING MASSIVE CLOSER TO. IN THE
BEGIN WE HAD A PARTY FOR
PROPERTY. TIME OFF WHEN WE CAN.
THE VIRUS MARC. THEN WE HAD TO
FIGHT FOR THAT BAXEEN THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. THE
CENTRAL WERE PAY. WHICH WE NEVER
RECEIVED A CENT AND NOW WE HAVE
TO BUY FOR HELP STATE DIDN'T- OF
THE FOR NURSES I'VE EVER- DIED
AS A RESULT OF CONTRACTING CO
BID FROM THE PATIENTS AND
SUFFERING FROM LONG ALL OF IT.
PLEASE CONSIDER OFFER OPERATES A
NEW LARGER STAKES IN FOR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS ESPECIALLY IN STATE
SERVICE THE TASTE UP FOR TWO
MINUTES AWAY FROM THE PANDEMIC
THANK YOU YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. WHY NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO
. BUT AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR AND
WHO SHALL SIR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTED FIFTY ELECTED
SHERIFF IN THE STATE- WE SUPPORT
ADD SEVEN HOURS AND MADE WITH
VISION FOR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND I TO
FUND GRANTS TO LOCAL ENTITIES
IMPROVE OFFICER WELL MATCHED- WE
ALSO ADDS SUPPORT AND WOULD LIKE
TO THINK THAT MINISTRATION.
APPOINT PUTTING TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE A
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT DURING
DISASTER AND EMERGENCY THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. I'M SORRY MOM EIGHT
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE- LEFT. OUR
MEN HERE LOOKS LIKE WE'RE DOWN
TO SIXTEEN. OKAY THANK YOU
PLEASE KEEP YOUR REMARKS TWO-
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
WHAT THE ISSUE IS THAT YOU'RE
CALLING ABOUT. EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EIGHTY SIX ONE MORE
SHOT WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
WILL MOVE ALONG THE LINE ONE OF
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. ONE OH SIX
PLEASE ON MUTE. YEAH HELLO. GO
BACK- HELLO TO LINE ONE ALL WELL
I WOULD JUST MOVE ON WHAT ELSE
IS OKAY ONE OF ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS OLIVIA
CAMPBELL I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
THAT YOU REJECT IN FULL ALL
BUDGET PROPOSALS FROM U. P. C.
R. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NINETY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON FOLKS MY
NAME IS MARIA MORENO I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE RUSSIAN
OPPORTUNITY CENTRES AND
REPRESENTING THE FIFTY NOTE FOR
ALL COALITION I'M CALLING TO
URGE THE SENATE TO ABOUT THE SIX
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
MILLION DOLLARS HAVE PROGRAM
PARKS FOOD IMMIGRANT WORKERS
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS MAKE THAT
MAKE UP THE BACKBONE OF OUR
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND EMERGENCY
IT INDISCRIMINATELY AFFECTS ALL
OF US. THANK GOODNESS RECENT ALL
OF OUR WORKERS BACK WITH FIFTEEN
AT PROGRAMS THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. WE WILL TO LINE ONE
OF. YOU ARE ALL ONE ON. HELLO MY
NAME ALEX ARE WITH THE MOMENT OF
THE COMMITTEE. WILL CONDUCT FOR
OF THE STATE AT AWFUL. TO URGE
SENATE TO ADOPT A HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST RUNNING
FOR AND BURKE WOULD WORKERS. BUT
IT'S A PRIOR FOR THE BY THIS
YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. ONE OF THE YOU ARE OPEN
. SO MANY BECAUSE THERE WERE- IN
COLLEGE PARTNER JUSTICE
ACCORDING TO NET LOCAL OF COMING
TO URGE SENATE TO ADOPT SIX ON
AND NINETY MILLION DOLLARS TO
WELL ARE UNEMPLOYMENT AND WHICH
IT ESSENTIAL WORKERS THANK YOU.
NEXT. ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI THIS IS EATING- FROM I
HEARD IT FROM THE LIST CALLING I
HAVE SIXTY THAT BROKE SHE BUDGET
URGING THE SENATE TO PUT THE
THUNDER NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
OUT OF THE TWO SURPLUS THAT THE
GOLDEN STATE THANKS FOR THE
WORKING. LAST OF ALL WORKERS
INCLUDING A- ESSENTIAL. PLEASE
THE RIGHT THING THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS INCREASED ON
BEHALF OF MAYOR LICCARDO IN THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE I WOULD LIKE
THEIR CALL AND EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT
TO- INVESTING IN TRANSPORTATION
AND VERIFY HE'S VERY QUICKLY- WE
BELIEVE THE SENATE'S PROPOSED
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE
REPRESENTS THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN TRANSIT
INCLUDED YOU BRING FOR EIGHTY P.
A GREEN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE- PARTICULAR
CALLING OUT THE ELEVEN POINT
EIGHT FOUR THAT TRANSIT RAIL
INVESTMENTS WILL HELP. ENSURE
THAT PROJECTS LIKE THE BOARD TO
EXTENSION OF THE SAN JOSE CAN
LOOK FOR IT NOT BE USED FEDERAL
COMMITMENT ARE AT STAKE IT WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO GET MATCHING STATE
DOLLARS TO THANK YOU AGAIN-
MADAM CHAIR OF THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING SIGNATURE. SPACE
THANK YOU THANK. YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. YOUR ONE TWENTY.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
QUICKLY WE TOOK- AT LEAST ONE
POINT BUT IN THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM- WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE LEGISLATURE AND
PASSED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FOR THE OLYMPICS- IN THE AMOUNT
OF TWO POINT FIVE BILLION TO
ENSURE THAT ALL TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS CAN BE COMPLETED FOR
THAT. WE WOULD ALSO LIKE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
AUGMENTING IMPORTANT PROGRAMS-
NXP ONE ESPECIALLY THE TRADE
CORRIDOR ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM
THANK YOU. TONIGHT HE CAN. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THE MARK ON
EDUCATION. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER WITH MONA ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY CENTERS ARE NOT PART
OF THE FIFTEENTH NEXT BROAD
COALITION. RECALLING TO URGE THE
SENATE TO ADOPT THE SIX HUNDRED
AND NINETY MILLION REQUEST FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
EXCLUDED WORKERS AS PART OF THE
CAR USED THANK YOU. THIS YEAR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DEBORAH
MENDEZ FROM POMONA ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY CENTER AND I'M
CALLING THAT'S PART OF THE STATE
IN A CRAWL. I'M CALLING TO URGE
AND IT'S WITH DOCTOR TO IF THE
COUNTRY NINETY MILLION DOLLARS-
OUR REQUEST FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS WERE EXCLUDED WORKERS
THE ARE DOING THEIR PART I THINK
THE PRIORITY FOR THE BIKE HERE
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU PLEASE. ONE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M STEPHEN
MANGUM RETIRED TOURNEY AFTER
TWENTY THREE YEARS AT BAY AREA
LEGAL AID AND CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF. REGENESIS CALIFORNIA REQUEST
THAT- SYMBOL ASSESSMENTS FEE
AMENDED IN MY YEARS THEY LEGAL I
SAW THE DAMAGE IT DOES TO- FOUND
OF PEOPLE WHO THEIR LICENSES
INSPIRED. IT ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT GET RID OF. THE
ASSESSMENT ALTOGETHER AND NOT
SIMPLY- REDUCE IT BY A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
WHAT THIRTY FIVE ARE OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME OUR HEIGHT OF THE
VEHICLE SO I'M WITH OF THE
EMINEM'S USE COLLECT THEM AFTER
UP AT THE EIGHTEEN FOR ALL. I'M
CALLING TO URGE THE SENATE ADOPT
SIX HUNDRED NINETEEN OH FOR A
BENEFITS THE POLITICAL WORKER. A
FIRE THAT FOR THE BIKE THIS YEAR
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND GIVE NEXT PLEASE. OVER ONE
TWENTY. YOU ARE OPEN. ONE MORE
SHOT ONE TWENTY THESE ARE MUTE.
BUILDING ON ONE OF THREE GO
AHEAD. BUT- FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GO AHEAD ONE OF. C. C. A
WHEN I FEBRUARY- THE NUMBER FOUR
ALLELE MUCH DETERMINE IF THE
AMONG THE BAY CENTER IN NOT W.
YOU CAN NEVER HAVE YOU EAT SO
YOU- YEAH THE OF THE ACT NOVEL
J. IS A LOT- IN THE END OF THE
QUESTEL. THE THAT LOCATION IT
FIFTY SEVEN I THANK THEM IS THAT
THE NUMBER THAT THEY WILL BE
BACK I THOUGHT AT THE FIFTY FROM
KEEP ON A AGAIN I'M NOT. IN
THAT'S ALL THE DRASTIC YES YES
NEXT PLEASE.
BROKE BUT IT WILL KEEP THAT WORK
AND IF YOU'RE- THE- SECTOR FOR
THE STATE WE CAN WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. BORROW SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LINE FOR JOBS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE'RE CALLING AT THE
PORT OF THE TRANSPORTATION PHONY
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
AB RIGHT IS MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
FOR TRANSIT GRADE SEPARATIONS
ENACTED. AND SO WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING PACKAGE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. NEXT PLEASE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD ONE THIRTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT I WILL BE BRIEF AND
SIMPLY SAY THAT PARTS OF COURSE.
THE SENATE'S PROPOSED
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT
PLEASE. ONE CALL ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MALAMI NUMBER
EIGHTY THAT THESE MY YEAH. HELLO
NEEDLES IF THE YOUNG PARKING LOT
POLICE GOVERNMENT IT WILL BE THE
PART OF LITTLE BIT YEAH LOOK BUT
OUR HEAR I WILL UPDATE I LOOK AT
THE AND FUN OF YOUR IT BUT I
IT'S BECAUSE IS EMPLEO BUT AT
THE HIGHLIGHTED PLEASE. I'M
THIRTY DOES PERCENT WIDTH OF
GIVE US IF SINCE IN MY GET A
SENSE BUT MIND NEXT PLEASE.
HELLO CUSTOMER HELLO FLORIDA.
THE PARTICIPANTS DOLLARS. YES
YES NEXT PLEASE. I'M SURE WE
HAVE A CLUSTER THE QUEUE. OKAY
OF. ANY MORE COMING SOON NEWMAN
NO COMMENTS THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY FOR CALLING IN- WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND- ARE SENATORS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
YOUR TESTIMONY WERE VERY
IMPORTANT TO US TODAY WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
FACIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND CORPS
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU.